WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON RESPONSE THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO PROTECT
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS AND
ALL PRODUCTS IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW WILL BE
USING TELECONFERENCE SERVICES
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. INDIVIDUALS
WISHING PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE CODE THE
NEXUS BECAUSE POST OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT. NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE IS
SIX ONE NINE FOUR FOUR EIGHT A
REPEAT TO SPEND NUMBER.
877-692-8957 ACCESS CODE. SIX
ONE NINE FOUR FOUR EIGHT FOR
DETAILED STRUCTURES AND HOW THE
TELECOM SYSTEM WORKS PLEASE
CONTACT PLEASE REFER TO THE
COMPANY'S WEBSITE. WHAT MOOD
PUBLIC COMING YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATE TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THERE MAY BE A SHORT
WAITING PERIOD ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATE TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTE YOU'LL
BE READY. TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING OR
LISTENING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR YOU WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I'LL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAYBE REMOVE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. HAVE THE CONNECTIONS
MUTE. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HIRING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IS CLOSELY MIRRORS
CUSTOMER THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE. OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL. AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. ALL
RIGHT- LET LETS THE ESTABLISHED
A QUORUM SO MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL
IF YOU WOULD CALL THE RULE TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM FOR PURPOSES
OF ESTABLISHING A QUORUM- BIRD
HERE AMBERG HERE PORGES.
GORGEOUS PRESENT CARRY IT ALL.
GUBBIO HERE DID I SO DID I SO
HERE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HERE
HERTZBERG JONES. WHERE DO
BLARED HERE'S STERN WHITE HOUSE
SKI WAY CAL SKI HERE WINNER.
THERE ARE SEVEN MEMBERS PRESENT
YOU HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU-
CHIEF COUNSEL NOTES CORMS BEEN
ESTABLISHED WITHOUT OBJECTION
PHYLUM NUMBER THIRTY A. B.
FIFTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SOLACE WILL BE ADDED TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY.
SIGNALLED JUNCTION- WE HAVE
THIRTY THREE BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA TWENTY OF WHICH ARE ON
CONSENT THE ITEMS OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ARE AS FOLLOWS
ALL RIGHT HERE WE GO. FILE
NUMBER TO A. B. ONE ZERO THREE
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAUER
K. HIM PHONE NUMBER THREE AB
SIX SEVEN FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT. PHONE
NUMBER FOR A. B. EIGHT ONE
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
WITH AMENDMENTS FILE NUMBER
EIGHT AB FOUR SEVEN THREE BY
SEVEN MEMBER CHILD. FILE NUMBER
NINE EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JO BOM NUMBER
ELEVEN AC ARE TWENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD. PROBLEM
NUMBER TWELVE A. B. SIX SIX
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAN
WITH AMENDMENTS FILE NUMBER
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE FIVE SEVEN
FOUR BY IT. THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN THE ECONOMY
PROBLEM NUMBER FIFTEEN EIGHTY
ONE FIVE SEVEN SEVEN BUT IS
SIMPLY JOIN. TO ME BY THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
FILE NUMBER SIXTEEN AB NINE
THREE EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DAVIES FILE NUMBER SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY. THREE FIVE EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLOOR WITH A
MAMMOTH PROBLEM NUMBER TWENTY
A. B. ONE THREE FOUR SEVEN BY
SEVEN MEMBER JORDAN JONES
SAWYER. FOUND OVER TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHT NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW FROM NUMBER
TWENTY THREE A. B. FIVE FOUR
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MANSION.
PHONE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR A. B.
SIX THREE SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MANSION WITH A MAMMOTH PROBLEM
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY ONE
THREE FOUR NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS. FROM
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN AB TWO
EIGHT SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK FOUND OVER TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY SIX ONE ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
FROM NUMBER THIRTY A. B. FIFTY
SIX BY SOME MEMBERS SOLACE AND
FINALLY FOUND NUMBER THIRTY ONE
AB. TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAY ART THOUGH. IS THERE A
MOTION TO CAN CAN. SENT A
COUPLE MOVES THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. BENNETT CHIEF COUNSEL
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR AMBERG
HI- BURKE HI BORJAS. FORGES HI
COVEY IT'LL- COPY AT ALL I DID
ALSO. IT ALSO HI GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG JONES
LAYERED BLARED FIVE STERN WHITE
HOUSE SKI Y. CASKEY II WINNER.
YOU HAVE SEVEN FIVE ZERO RIGHT
NOW WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL-
JUST A MOMENT WE'RE GOING TO
CALL- A. B. THREE SEVEN ONE BUT
LET ME- LET ME. PROVIDE THE
FOLLOWING INFORMATION- DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS OF CLEANING
PROTOCOLS I'M INSTITUTING TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY EACH SIDE
WILL PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME WHICH IS TWO WITNESSES FOR
TWO MINUTES EACH. ALL THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
THEIR FILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE MEASURE. THAT THOSE WISHING
TO ADD- TESTIMONY BEYOND THE
TWO WITNESSES WHO EACH WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES THEY MAY
PROVIDE THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION THE POSITION ON THE
MEASURE- AGAIN EACH SIDE WILL
HAVE. THAT WILL HAVE EQUAL TIME
TWO MINUTES EACH FOR THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES. ALL RIGHT-
FOR MAXIMUM FIFTEEN MINUTES IF
NEED BE ON EACH SIDE. SO SOME
REMEMBER JOHN SO YOU'RE YOU'VE
BEEN WAITING. FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING TO COMMITTING
AMENDMENTS AND THANKING THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE. THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL ONE CAPPED A
DOLLAR AMOUNT FOR THE COST OF
LIABILITY COVERAGE TO EXTEND
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION TO
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. AND THREE REQUIRE NOTICE
TO USERS ABOUT THEIR POTENTIAL
LIABILITY FOR THE USE OF E.
DEVICES THESE AMENDMENTS WILL
ADDRESS INSURANCE COSTS AND
DISCLOSE CONCERNS BY SIX BY
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING THE COST
OF COVERAGE FOR ACCIDENT
VICTIMS AS WELL AS ENSURE EACH
DEVICE RENTERS. ARE MADE AWARE
OF THEIR RESPONSIBILITY I AM
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
ENGAGEMENT WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS WE AIM TO
ENSURE PEDESTRIANS RECEIVE A
SENSIBILITY AND LIABILITY
PROTECTIONS. A. B. THREE SEVEN
ONE EXTENDS LIABILITY
PROTECTION TO PEDESTRIANS IF
THEY ARE INJURED BY AN ELECTRIC
ELECTRIC SCOOTER OR BIKE
COLLECTIVELY CALLED P. DEVICES
AND REQUIRES THE ADDITION OF
BRAILLE AND TACTILE SIGNET BUS
SIGNAGE TO THESE DEVICES. THIS
ENSURES PEDESTRIANS WHO ARE
BLIND OR GRAB VISUAL
IMPAIRMENTS HAVE THE CONTACT
INFORMATION TO FILE AN INJURY
REPORT. IF THEY WOULD
EXPERIENCE AN ACCIDENT SUCH AS
TRIPPING OVER AN ABANDONED P.
DEVICE ON THE SIDEWALK. MY
FIRST APPROACH BY THE BILL'S
SPONSOR THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
OF THE BLIND I IMMEDIATELY
REACHED OUT TO MY BABY BROTHER.
DR FRED JONES AS HE IS ALSO
BLIND. I RECALL A TIME WHEN HE
CAME TO MY WEDDING AND I TOOK
HIM TO THE BATHROOM AND HE
HEARD ME TURN THE LIGHT OFF.
TURN THE LIGHT ON SKEWS ME TO
WHICH HE SAID WHY DID YOU DO
THAT I CAN'T SEE ANYWAYS. IT
WAS AT THAT MOMENT WHERE I
REALIZED THAT TO UNDERSTAND
ISSUES FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
BLIND. YOU CANNOT HAVE YOUR
EYES OPEN ALL THE TIME YOU MUST
ALWAYS UNDERSTAND WHAT IT'S
LIKE. TO BE BLIND. THE USER'S
CURRENT DO YOU THE CURRENT USE
WE ARE FACING IS THAT EXISTING
LIABILITY PROTECTIONS ONLY
COVER USERS. INJURED AS A
RESULT OF OPERATING E. DEVICES
THIS MEANS PEDESTRIANS AND
ACCIDENT VICTIMS INJURED BY
EACH DEVICES ARE LEFT WITHOUT A
METHOD TO RECEIVE COVERAGE FOR
INJURIES CAUSED BY NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN. WHICH IS ESPECIALLY
BURDENSOME TO THOSE WHO ARE
BLIND OR HAVE VISUAL
IMPAIRMENTS THAT THEY RELY ON
CLEAR WALKWAYS. DOES IT MATTER
BOTH UPSET ACCESSIBILITY AND
EQUITY FOR ALL EIGHTY THREE
SEVEN ONE REMOVE REMOVED THE
BURDEN RESPONSIBILITY AWAY FROM
ACCIDENT VICTIMS BY ENSURING
PEDESTRIANS ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO ARE BLIND. THE ELDERLY AND
THOSE WITH DISABILITIES HAVE A
METHOD FOR PARLIAMENTARY REPORT
AND BEING COMPENSATED IF
INJURED BY ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL'S
IMPROPER USE OR STORAGE OF THE
DEVICES. WITH ME TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. THREE SEVEN
ONE. IT'S ACTUALLY MY BROTHER'S
DOCTOR FRED JONES ALSO IN
SUPPORT BECAUSE- IS VIA
TELECONFERENCE LINE IS LAURIE
KASSNER WITH BILL SPONSORED THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF THE
BLIND. THANK. YOU MR CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE EXPECT POLICE ASKED
FOR AND I BOTH. THANK A SALUTE
BROTHER DR FRED JONES IS
PRESENT HERE IN THE GALLERY AND
MISS LORI KASSNER IS ON THE
PHONE IS THAT CORRECT. ALL
RIGHT- SO DR JONES- WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
SURE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS BILL
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND I
WANT TO THANK MY BROTHER FOR
HIS TIRELESS EFFORT IN TRYING
TO GET THIS BILL THROUGH THIS
BILL WILL REVOLUTIONIZE AS WELL
AS- I HAVE DISABLED PEOPLE
WOULD NOT BE INJURED. BY
LEAVING SCOOTERS ON THE
SIDEWALK IF A BLIND PERSON
ENCOUNTERS A SCOOTER ON THE
SIDEWALK THEY- WILL LOSE THE
ORIENTATION AND MAY MOVE TO THE
LEFT OR TO THE RIGHT WHICH
WOULD BRING TO THE INDUSTRY.
WHICH WOULD ALSO RENDER THEM
AND ABLE TO GET HIT BY A CAR SO
IF YOU CONSIDER THIS BILL
CAREFULLY WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THEIR TWO AREAS THAT WE NEED TO
CONSIDER IS BUILT UNDER.
ARCHITECTURAL BARRIERS AND
ATTITUDINAL BARRIERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU UGH DR JONES MISCAST
ARE YOU AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE.
YES I AM ALL RIGHT FLOORS NO
YEARS. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
HEARING MY COMMENTS- I LIVE IN
OAKLAND I'M TOTALLY BLIND AND
I'M A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF THE BLIND ON
DECEMBER SIXTEENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I CROSS THE STREET IN
FRONT OF MY HOME WALKED ABOUT
FIFTY FEET DOWN THE BLOCK AND
SUDDENLY WAS LYING FLAT ON MY
FACE. I HAD CAUGHT MY RIGHT
FOOT UNDER A SHARED SCOOTER
WELL MY WHITE CANE MOVED IN
FRONT OF MY LEFT FOOT AND I
FELT. I WAS SO SHAKEN AND
DISORIENTED I LET A PASSER BY
WALKED ME HOME I REALIZED THAT
I HAD A LARGE CUT ON MY
FOREHEAD I NORMALLY BANDAGE
SMALL MYSELF BUT KNEW I NEEDED
THEIR HELP WITH THIS ONE SO
GUARDED NEIGHBORS ASSISTANCE TO
APPLY GAUZE AND BANDAGES. I HAD
NEVER HEARD OF A SHARED SCOOTER
UNTIL THIS MISHAP SO I DID NOT
MAKE A POLICE REPORT AND DID
NOT THINK OF GOING TO URGENCY.
I THOUGHT ONLY OF GETTING HOME.
BY LATER THAT DAY AS WELL AS
THE BANDAGE CUT I HAD TWO VERY
BLACK GUYS AT A GREATLY SWOLLEN
NOSE. MY INJURIES TOOK SEVERAL
WEEKS TO HEAL AND TO THIS DAY
THE TEXTURE OF THE SKIN ON MY
FOREHEAD IS SLIGHTLY ROUGHENED.
LATER THAT FIRST DAY I LEARNED
ABOUT SHARED SCOOTERS AND
THEY'RE BEING ABANDONED AND
UNSAFE PLACES SUCH AS
SIDEWALKS. THEIR WAYS AND EVEN
THROWN INTO LAKE MERRITT A
LARGE LAKE IN OAKLAND. NOW I
KNOW THE VEHICLES CAN BE
HAZARDOUS. TODAY IF I
ENCOUNTERED A SHARED SCOOTER IN
UNSAFE LOCATIONS I WOULD BE
APPRECIATIVE. I WOULD
APPRECIATE BRAILLE
IDENTIFICATION ON THE VEHICLE I
WOULD BE GRATEFUL. THAT THE
CARRIER WAS REQUIRED TO HAVE
LIABILITY INSURANCE. THANK YOU
FOR THIS A BILL AND I
APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO
COMMENT TODAY. THANK YOU MISS
KASSNER LET ME JUST MAKE A
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENT
BECAUSE I KNOW THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
WAITING IN QUEUE TO TESTIFY ON
ON VARIOUS BILLS- SO. HERE'S A
WE'RE GONNA DO IS SIMPLY MEMBER
COLORANTS BEEN HERE FOR OVER
FORTY MINUTES. SO WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE UP. HER BUILD NEXT
WHICH IS IN FILE ORDER. THAT'S
ITEM NUMBER SIX A. B. NINE ZERO
ONE. YEAH. I'M SORRY STRIKE
THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP-
CHOOSE TWO BILLS WILL TAKE UP A
B. R. NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT NEXT OUR CONCERN
JUVENILES REUNIFICATION THEN
AFTER THAT WOULD TAKE UP A B.
NINE OH ONE- BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KALRA AND- PASSENGER VEHICLE
TRANSACTIONS. AFTER THAT WE'RE
GONNA TAKE SOME OTHER MATTERS
OUT OF ORDER WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
NINE AB NINE SEVEN FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOSE THREE OF
US. AND THEN AFTER- ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY NINE- WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE I'M NUMBER THIRTY
THREE AB ONE FOUR FIVE FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS. SO JUST
TO REVIEW THE BIDDING HERE-
FIRST. AFTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
JOHN SAWYER WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
SOMETHING OR CALL AROUND THEN
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOSE READERS FOR A. B.
NINE SEVEN FOUR THEN TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- WICKS FOR AB
ONE FOUR FIVE FIVE THANK YOU.
THAT INDULGENCE ALL RIGHT. SO
WE'VE WE'VE HEARD FROM TWO
WITNESSES HERE PRIMARY
WITNESSES- NOW RETURN TO OTHERS
TO GIVE US THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION
SO ANYONE OF THE GALLERY WITH
THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY. HERE
SAYING NO ONE IN THE GALLERY.
NOW LET'S MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SIR WANT A ROOM TWELVE
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA TURN THE
PHONE LINES NOW. FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. THREE SEVEN ONE.
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD TO HELP
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF A. B. THREE
SEVEN ONE. CERTAINLY MR SHARE
QUEUE UP AT THIS TIME IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. THREE SEVENTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN IF.
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD AT
THIS TIME. AND AFTER ALLOWING A
FEW MOMENTS FOR THOSE TO QUEUE
UP NO ONE HAS DONE SO AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT LET'S NOW TURN
TO OPPOSITION OPPOSITION TO A.
B. THREE SEVEN ONE IS THERE
ANYONE THE GALLERY THAT WISHES
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION THERE
ARE- THERE MR BRETT MULLER- IS
THE PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- SMALLER NOT GARY
NOT ROOM ONE TWELVE MISTER MALL
ARE YOU ON THE PHONE. HI MISTER
CHAIR YEP I'M ON THE PHONE ALL
RIGHT SMALL FLOOR'S YOURS.
GREAT THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BRETT MILLER
SENIOR PUBLIC POLICY MANAGER AT
FANFARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION
BABY THREE SEVENTY ONE. WE
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS WE'VE
HAD WITH THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
AND THE OTHER STAFF TO TRY AND
FIND A SOLUTION TO BE CLEAR WE
SUPPORT THE ADDITION OF BRAILLE
ON ALL DEVICES I DO NOT DISPUTE
THE OTHER CONTENT WITH THE
INSURANCE REQUIREMENT. WE ARE
FULLY COMMITTED TO IMPROVING
SAFETY FOR PEDESTRIANS
PARTICULARLY THOSE WITH VISUAL
ARE CUT ABILITY ISSUES HOWEVER
DESPITE THE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS AND THE CANADIAN OUT
THAT MUCH REMAINS OUTSTANDING
THERE'S NOT SUFFICIENT DATA AT
THE TIME I DON'T TURN THE
FREQUENCY OR SEVERITY OF
PEDESTRIAN ACCIDENT. TO JUSTIFY
THE PROPOSED INSURANCE
REQUIREMENT IN THE BILL WHEN IT
COMES TO THE PROPOSED AMENDED
POLICY LIMIT PACIFIC WITH A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PER OCCURRENCE
FOR SCOOTERS FOR THE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND PER CAR THERE'S SIMPLY
NO EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THE CAKE
THE TUTORS ARE SIX AND A HALF
TIMES MORE DANGEROUS TO
PEDESTRIANS. AND CARS REGARDING
OUR EXISTING INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS I ALSO WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT ALL SHARED. BY
PROVIDERS ALREADY HAVE ROBUST
COMMERCIAL GENERAL LIABILITY
INSURANCE THAT COVERS WRITER
INTRODUCTORY AND THEN ACCIDENTS
WHERE WE AT THE DEVICE OWNERS
ARE NEGLIGENT IN THIS CASE D.
B. THREE SEVENTY ONE GOES MUCH
FURTHER INCREASES ON PRESIDENT
INSURANCE MANDATE THAT.
TRADITIONAL BY ABILITY AS
WRITTEN EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY
ONE REQUIRES MICHAEL BILITY
COMPANY TO OBTAIN THIRD PARTY
INSURANCE WHICH IN EFFECT WOULD
MAKE US LIABLE FOR THE
NEGLIGENCE OR RECKLESSNESS OF
OUR WRITERS REMARKABLY DIDN'T
EVEN COVER HE DIDN'T HAVE A
LEGAL RIGHT OVER HERE WHERE WE
AS OPERATORS HAVE LIMITED
CONTROL OVER. BUT JUST SOMEONE
RIDING A SCOOTER WHILE
INTOXICATED AND IMPORTANTLY
TRACKING A PEDESTRIAN NO OTHER
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE MODEL
CALLS THIS APPROACH BECAUSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE RIGHTLY HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR OWN
ACTIONS WHEN YOU RENT A CAR IN
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE DRIVERS
ARE REQUIRED TO HOLD THIRD
PARTY INSURANCE THAT COVERS THE
INJURY TO OTHERS. YOU DON'T TO
THE RENTAL CAR COMPANY FOR
DAMAGES EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY
ONE WOULD CHANGETHAT THAT IS
WHY THE ONLY INSURE CHARACTER
OF EACH GOOD OR THANK YOU BYE
IN CALIFORNIA APOLLO AS STATED
IN WRITING THAT THIS BILL WOULD
UNDOUBTEDLY CHANGED THE RISK
PROFILE FOR MICROBIOLOGY
OPERATOR. IN CALIFORNIA AND IT
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT A ALWAYS
ONE TO PROVIDE COVERAGE. IN
THIS WAY. WE BELIEVE. TREAT
THEM ONE A BARELY THINK OUT
THIS WITH.INDUSTRY WELL WE
RECOGNIZE THAT. THREE SEVEN ONE
ISN'T TO GET COVER AND RARE
CASES. THE DEATH. IF CLEAN AND
JERK AND THE NEGLIGENT WRITER
HAS NO ASSETS. THIS BILL RAISES
MANY UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
WRITER TO BEHAVE RECKLESSLY
BREAKING NUMEROUS LAWS
INTERPRET ESTRIN WOULD NOT BE
HELD FINANCIALLY LIABLE UP
FRONT FOR THEIR ACTIONS. THIS
SWEEPING INDUSTRY MANDATE ALSO
CREATE MORAL HAZARD OR MICRO
MOBILITY COMPANIES WITH LIMITED
RESOURCES. WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR CASH PAYOUT FOR WRITER
ACTION BEYOND OUR CONTROL.
LASTLY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CONSIDER THAT SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT OF THIS INSURANCE
MANDATE. ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY KEEP IN MIND OUR
AVERAGE TRIP COST ONLY FOR FIVE
DOLLARS. EVEN AN EXTRA DOLLARS
THAT 25% INCREASE. IT EXPECTED
IMPACT ON ACCESSIBILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY IS WHY THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE OAKLAND AND OTHERS
HAVE RAISED CONCERNS WITH THE
SPELL. FINALLY AS A LEGAL
MATTER D. B. THREE SEVENTY ONE
ALSO POTENTIALLY VIOLATE THE
FEDERAL BRAZEN AND THAT WHICH
PRECLUDES RENTAL CAR COMPANIES
FROM BEING HELD. LIABLE FOR
DAMAGES CAUSED BY RENDERS THE
VEHICLE. FOR THESE REASONS WE
TOGETHER WITH OTHER SCOOTER
OPERATORS CITY BIKE ADVOCATES
AND OTHERS REMAIN OPPOSED TO
FIGHT THE COMMITTEE ON THE NET.
THE CRUX OF THAT AS A MATTER OF
PUBLIC POLICY WE FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT LIABILITY SHOULD FALL WHO
IS AT FAULT. AND THEREFORE
COMPANY SHOULD NOT BE HELD
LIABLE FOR RECKLESS OR
NEGLIGENT WRITER BEHAVIOR
BEYOND THE CONTROL.
UNFORTUNATELY A. B. THREE
SEVENTY ONE ACCURATE AND UP AND
TOUCH LEGAL PRECEDENT AND TREAT
MICHAEL MOBILITY DIFFERENTLY
COMPARED TO ANY OTHER RENTED OR
SHARED PRODUCT IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MR
MILLER- BUT- I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE'S AN PROBLEM WITNESS
OPPOSITION I LET YOU USE UP
MOST OF THE- TWO MINUTES YOU'RE
TWO MINUTES PLUS. ANYONE ELSE'S
TWO MINUTES SO- IF THERE IS
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY WISHES
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO. AB
THREE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SAYING
NON ROOM ONE TWELVE. THING NO
ONE ROOM ONE TWELVE ALL RIGHT
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO AB THREE
SEVENTY ONE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
MAKE YOUR VOICES KNOWN.
REGARDING OPPOSITION A. B.
THREE SEVEN ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN THAT'S
ONE TO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHEN I THINK ABOUT HALF OF THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE BUT THEN I PUT
A LOT THE MINUTE POSITION ON
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO THAT'S. ONE THREE TWO.
INSURING THE MEMBERS SOME.
ONLINE YEAH I COULD HAVE A MUCH
NEEDED POSITION WAS A PART OF
THE PLANET SIX NINE. NEGATIVE
ACTIVITY HOWEVER HAD. BEEN
ASSERTING THAT ARM RD THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT. AND THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE IN OPPOSITION AT
ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE
ON THE PHONE LINE MODERATOR. NO
NO ONE ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE
ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE CHAMBER I SEE SENATOR
BOARD JUST MIKE IS RACE AND A
COUPLE EURO ALSO. PERSONAL
BORDERS. THANK YOU CHAIR. I WAS
IN A IN SAN DIEGO AWHILE BACK.
AND SOMEONE SCOOTER CAME
DANGEROUSLY CLOSE- MY KIDS AND
IT CAUSED ME YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
AS A PARENT I WAS CONCERNED-
BUT THEN YOU KNOW AS THE
MINUTES IN THE HOURS WENT BY
AND JUST KIND OF CURIOUS ON HOW.
THIS BUSINESS MODEL EXISTS AND
LO AND BEHOLD THIS BILL. FOUND
ITS WAY OVER HERE- I KNOW THE
AUTHOR AND I KNOW THAT- HE IS A
MAN OF HIS WORD AND HE'S TRYING
TO DO THE RIGHT THING I THINK
ON THEIR MANY COMPONENTS IN
THIS THAT MAKE A LOT OF SENSE.
FOR EXAMPLE- WHEN YOU LEAVE A
SCOOTER IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
WALKWAY THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE.
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE ARE YOU
KNOW WITH DISABILITIES- WHEN
YOU LEAVE IT- YOU KNOW PARKED
IN. IN DANGER SOCIETIES OR ANY
VARIATION. I THINK THERE NEEDS
TO BE SOME IMPROVEMENT WITH THE
SCOOTER COMPANIES AND THOSE
THAT USE THOSE- PIECES OF
EQUIPMENT THEY HAVE TO HAVE. A
DEGREE OF EXPECTATION
INCOMPETENCE WHEN IT COMES TO
HOW THE IMPACT TO THE COMMUNITY
AND TO THE WORLD AROUND THEM-
BY VIRTUE OF USING THOSE
SERVICES. SO JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT- TO LOSE SOME OF THE
GOOD THINGS THE BRAILLE ISSUE I
THINK THAT THAT'S A GOOD THING.
BUT WE'RE IN THE COURSE OF A OF
A OF A LEGISLATIVE CYCLE WHERE
AMENDMENTS ARE BEING THROWN
QUICKLY AND WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
KEEP UP WITH EVERYTHING THAT'S
BEING. SAID MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THERE WAS A NEW CAP ON THE
INSURANCE- POLICY AMOUNT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS FOR
EXAMPLE I THINK IN MY DRAFT IS
THAT I'M A MILLION. BUT I THINK
THAT'S GOING ON WAS A HUNDRED
THOUSAND. HUNDRED THOUSAND SO
IT OCCURRED TO ME THAT AFTER
TALKING WITH BOTH SIDES ON THIS
ISSUE THAT THERE THIS MIGHT BE
A SITUATION WHERE- THERE COULD
BE EVEN FURTHER COMPROMISE
BECAUSE IF YOU PUT FORWARD A
MANDATE FOR A THIRD PARTY
LIABILITY POLICY. INHABIT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS YOU
COULD VERY WELL FORCE OUT THE
BUSINESS ITSELF MEANING THAT
ITS BUSINESS MODEL MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE- THAT TYPE
OF OVERHEAD ON A PER OCCURRENCE
AT A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
BUT YOU CAN'T JUST. NOT ALLOW
FOR SOME PROTECTIONS INTO WHERE
EXACTLY IS THAT- THAT SWEET
SPOT THAT HAS YET TO BE%
DETERMINED BUT MY CONCERN IS
THAT WE MAY BE SQUEEZING OUT
THIS INDUSTRY BECAUSE IT DOES
HAVE SOME UTILITY- BY VIRTUE OF
THIS INSURANCE POLICY AND I
KNOW IN THE PAST THE
MUNICIPALITIES THAT WERE POSED
WITH A COVERAGE REQUEST. MEAN
THE MUNICIPALITIES OPPOSED IT
AS WELL- SO I WAS WONDERING
IMAGE THROW THIS OUT THERE TO
THE AUTHOR. WHAT IF WE WERE. TO
COME UP WITH A COMPROMISE THAT
IDENTIFIES. A SET DOLLAR AMOUNT.
EVERY TIME SOMEBODY OPENS AN
ACCOUNT TO ARBOR TIME SOMEBODY
USES- THE SCOOTER THAT THERE BE
IN ADDITION TO THE REGULAR
CHARGE A SURCHARGE. LET'S SEE
SEVENTY FIVE CENTS OR A DOLLAR
WHAT WHATEVER IT MAY BE THAT
GOES INTO A VICTIMS
COMPENSATION FUND. SO
ESSENTIALLY BECOMES A
COMPENSATION FUND TO HELP THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN INJURED. AND NEED
TO HAVE SOME PROTECTIONS ARE
FOR WHAT HAS TRANSPIRED BUT IT
DOESN'T UNDO THE BUSINESS MODEL
AND RUN THE ENTIRE SCOOTER
INDUSTRY OUT OF BUSINESS AND I
DIDN'T KNOW IF- I MIGHT BE IN
THE COMMENTS IF THAT'S MORE OF
A QUESTION AT THIS POINT MISTER
CHAIR. OFF I COULD DIRECT IT TO
THE AUTHOR IF HE WOULD BE HIS
THOUGHTS ON THAT IF YOU'RE
WILLING TO CONSIDER THAT
FURTHER SURE BUT LET ME ASK THE
AUTHOR OF. PHONE NUMBER DO YOU
CARE TO RESPOND NOW OR IN YOUR
CLOTHES BUT LET ME RESPOND NOW
ALL RIGHT- AND I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE BECAUSE IT WAS
THEIR AMENDMENTS THAT BROUGHT
IT DOWN. TO THAT NUMBER AND I
BELIEVE SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS
THAT PROBLEM- WE NEED TO HAVE
SOME DOLLAR AMOUNT AND WITHOUT.
WITHOUT SOME DATA WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO PUT IT AT SOME COST.
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS NOT
I REPEAT NOT TO PUT THIS GROUP
IS THIS OUT OF BUSINESS. AND IN
FACT WE'RE HOPING THAT THIS
BECOMES A MITIGATING PART OF IT
BECAUSE MY THE MEMBERS FROM LA
MAY KNOW- THERE ARE ATTORNEYS.
WHO ARE NOW HAVE COMMERCIALS
OUT TO SUE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
INJURED BY STEVE B. DEVICES AND
SCOOTERS WHICH I THINK WILL BE
EVEN MORE DRASTICALLY IMPACT
THAT INDUSTRY I THINK THIS BILL
PROVIDING SOME KIND OF
INSURANCE COULD BUFFER SOME OF
THAT AND SO WE NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER. TO ENSURE THAT THIS
DESCRIPTIVE GO OUT BECAUSE
THEY'RE INDIVIDUALS OUT THERE
THAT MAY NOT HAVE THE. SAME
BEST INTENTIONS AS I DO A THE
KEEP THIS GROUP. IN IN BUSINESS
I DON'T KNOW I'VE HAVE TO LOOK
AT. THE MODEL YOU'RE LOOKING AT
HOW DO YOU IMPLEMENT IS HOW YOU
KNOW ALL THE DIFFERENT
PERMUTATIONS BUT- DEFINITELY
WHO IT IS IF THE SCOOTER
COMPANIES WILL WORK WITH US
LOOK WHEN I FIRST TOLD US THERE
WERE NO INSURANCE COMPANIES WE
HAD TO GO FIND THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES THE CARRIERS FROM ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SAID THEY
WOULD DO IT. NOW YOU KNOW WE'VE
BEEN WE'VE BEEN STYMIED EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY TO GET THIS
DONE AND SO FROM MY CLIENTS ARE
MY PEOPLE I'M REPRESENTING
PEOPLE WHO ARE DISABLED THEY
JUST WANT TO BE ABLE. TO GET
THEIR INJURIES- COMPENSATED FOR
HER WELL THAT'S THAT'S
FANTASTIC TO HEAR I'M GLAD YOU
WERE YOU WERE OPENED ON TO- TO
THIS AS AN IDEA I KNOW THAT-
THE SCOOTER COMPANIES SEEM TO
BE INTERESTED IN TALKING ABOUT
THIS FURTHER- I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO GO TO INSURANCE NEXT
FOR ME BETWEEN NOW AND THEN-
THAT COULD BE SOMETHING THAT
COULD BE- LOOKED INTO IN
GREATER DETAIL. THE OTHER THING
IS- WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE
PREMIUMS OF INSURANCE I DON'T
THINK I'VE SEEN ANY ESTIMATE BY
AN INSURANCE CARRIER. ON WHAT
OVERHEAD THAT WOULD BE. THE I
THINK IS GOING TO BE SSENTIAL
BEFORE LIKE THIS ALSO MOVES
FORWARD. ON TO THE NEXT
COMMITTEE IS THAT IF THE
SCOOTER COMPANY SAYING IT'S
COST PROHIBITIVE. I'D LOVE TO
HEAR IT SEE IT ESTIMATE OR IF
IN YOUR CASE YOU'RE SAYING THAT
IT IS DOABLE I'D LOVE TO SEE AN
ESTIMATE. ON WHAT TYPE OF-
KERRIER LIKE REDUCTIONS.
BECAUSE WE ARE ELEVATING. THE-
THE ARRANGEMENT. BETWEEN FIVE
THE SCOOTER RENTER DISCOVER
COMPANY IN A THIRD PARTY IN
WAYS THAT CERTAINLY DON'T
EXIST. S. COUNTERPARTS TO
RENTING A VEHICLE. AND I THINK
IF WE CAN ANSWER THOSE TOO THEN
I THINK WE- HAVE SOMETHING HERE
THAT CAN WORK FOR EVERYBODY AND
LOOK AFTER THE FOLKS THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AFTER A
SPECIALLY THOSE IN THE DESERT
WITH DISABILITIES. BECAUSE I
THINK IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE
THAT A PERSON COULD BE INJURED.
AND HAVE NO ONE TO GO AFTER IT
DOES THIS MAKE ANY SENSE NOT
THE COMPANY NOT THE INDIVIDUAL
PRESUMABLY THE INDIVIDUAL. WHO
IS RENTING- MAY NOT NECESSARILY
HAVE THE DEEPEST POCKETS GIVEN
POTENTIAL MEDICAL. COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH SUBSTANTIAL
INJURIES TO SOMEWHERE IN
BETWEEN THERE SO FOR YOUR MAN
YOUR WORD I HOPE THAT THESE
SCOOTER COMPANIES WILL WILL
REACH OUT TO YOU IN YOU'LL
DISCUSS THIS AS AN OPTION
BECAUSE I THINK. A COMPENSATION
FUND COULD GIVE YOU EVERYTHING
YOU WANT IN THE PUBLIC WHAT IT
MEANS FOR THE ENTITY TO
CONTINUE TO STAY IN BUSINESS
AND FOR THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
INJURED- TO BE ABLE TO SEEK
ECONOMIC REMEDY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR FOR JUST A SECOND
HERE THAN SAID HERZBERG CYNICAL
EURO. SO THANK MR CHAIR- MY
QUESTIONS ARE MY THE ISSUES
THAT I AM I THAT I HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THEM TO ME JUST
SAY THAT I REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS BELT AND- HI I THINK
YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT TRACK- MY
ONLY CONCERN WAS WITH THE THEM
THE SIZE OF THE INSURANCE- AT
POLICIES AND I GUESS I LOOK AT
IT IN TERMS OF- A MOVING
VEHICLE AND WHAT'S AT THE
MINIMUM WE HAVE TO HAVE AND BY
MOVING AT. A CAR OR A VAN- IT
WILL DO A LOT MORE DAMAGE
POTENTIALLY THEN THIS KIND OF-
VEHICLE WHEN IT'S MOVING SO BUT
I'LL LEAVE THAT TO INSURANCE
IT'S GOING TO GO TO INSURANCE
MY AND ACTUALLY THE ISSUES ARE
RELATED TO INSURANCE I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS
AND I GUESS AS I WAS THINKING
ABOUT THIS- I WAS WONDERING HOW
DO WE DEAL WITH OTHER MOVING.
VEHICLES THAT WE RENT WHETHER
THEIR SKIS YOU KNOW SNOW SKIS
OR WATER SKIS OR THOSE THAT.
DID THE DUES ON THE WATER- SKI
DOOS THAT- THE OUT BICYCLES.
BOATS EIGHT I MEAN THERE IT
JUST SEEMS TO ME LIKE. LIKE WE
OUGHTA JUST LUMP THEM ALL
TOGETHER AND SAY LET'S FIGURE
OUT. A DANGEROUS SPORT ACT LIKE
YOU KNOW A COVERAGE AND THEY
REQUIRE SOME KIND OF WRITER
THAT WOULD COVER A LOT OF THESE
THINGS BECAUSE I'M- I'M- I
THINK THERE THERE SHOULD BE
INSURANCE. I THINK THERE HAS TO
BE BUT- AND I LIKE THAT THE
PROPOSAL THAT- THE SENATOR THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM FRESNO
PROPOSED I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER
IDEAS SOME SELF SELF FUNDED. OR
OR- FUNDED MECHANISM AND MAYBE
IT YOU PAY THE SEVENTY FIVE
CENTS OR A DOLLAR AND IT COMES
TO A STATEWIDE- FIND THAT THEN
IS USED FOR. A LIKE A VICTIMS
COMPENSATION FUND SOMETHING
THAT MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE
DEVICES THAT PEOPLE ARE RENTING
GET COVERED IN THAT THERE'S A
WAY FOR US TO MAKE SURE THAT
ANYBODY THAT'S INJURED. BECAUSE-OF THE NEGLIGENCE OF THE
OPERATOR GETS COVERED AND THAT
WE HAVE A WAY TO DO THAT SO I
APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE I'M IN
THE SPORT OF TODAY. I JUST PUT
PROPOSE THOSE AS WAYS TO LOOK
AT THE ISSUE SO THAT WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE MAKING SURE WE'RE
WE'RE REALLY CAPTURING- AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET PEOPLE
INSURED IN AND- SOMEBODY WHO.
IS RENTING. THE DEVICE AND IS
NEGLIGENT WITH IT WHETHER THEY
LEAVE IT ON THE SIDEWALK OR
THEY RUN SOMEBODY OVER CAN'T
JUST SAY LOOK I DON'T HAVE ANY
ASSETS RIGHT I'M A I'M A
COLLEGE STUDENT AND I DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING YOU CAN TAKE MY
COMPUTER AND THAT'S IT I'M WE
GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
MONEY FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
INJURED SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANKS BYE. THANK YOU SAID A
COUPLE YEARS- THE CELL NUMBER
JOHN SIR DO YOU. WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND BETTER IN YOUR CLOTHES.
I DO MY COWORKERS ARE
APPRECIATE HER THANK YOU LOLA
CENTER HERTZBERG. MAN I'M
GETTING OLD EVERYBODY BECAUSE
I'VE SEEN A LOT OF BILLS BUT-
SCOOTERS IT'S A NEW THING THE
WORLD KEEPS CHANGING IT'S
IMPORTANT THING I'M TOLD OUT IN
CAL STATE CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE
WHERE. PEOPLE PARK AND THEY GO
THE LAST MILE ON THOSE SCOOTERS
HAS BECOME AN IMPORTANT DEAL
YOU KNOW ALL THESE KIDS ARE
AROUND SCOOTERS ABOUT HIT ME
HALF THE TIME I THINK WHEN I
GET TO THIS JOB AND BECOME A
SCOOTER LAWYER AT THESE. RATES
OF- MATURE AND SPLIT. BUT NO
LUCK HE HE IS THE AUTHOR OF
THIS MEASURE IS IT SERIOUS-
FELL IN THE- YOUR FRIEND OF
MINE FOR. MORE YEARS THAN
EITHER OF US WANT TO KNOW. BUT
I THINK I JUST WANTED TO SAY IS
THAT I JUST THINK THE NUMBERS
ARE. UP YOU GOT TO HAVE A THIRD
PARTY PAY RIGHT WHEN THERE'S
ANY LEVEL OF LIABILITY BECAUSE
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN IRAN
WHEN THESE THINGS I'M SCARED
I'LL FALL OFF OF IT. WELL THE
PEOPLE THAT RUN THEM ARE KIDS
GOT NODE YOU GOT NO MONEY. SO
CLEARLY IF THIS CAN SOMEONE
GETS INJURED YOU GOTTA HAVE A
SOURCE ADULT. THE QUESTION IS.
THAT'S A DEFINED TERM MISTER
CHAIRMAN. BUT THE- YOU GOTTA
MAKE SURE ISN'T ALWAYS IS SET
IS A SURCHARGE OR IS IT A-
INSURANCE. FUND IN EITHER
INSTANCE- YOU KNOW IT'S A
QUESTION'S GOING TO RAISE THE
COST OF THE PRODUCT WHICH- AT
WHAT POINT WHAT IS IT
COMPETITIVE WE'RE NOT
COMPETITIVE. BUT I JUST THINK
THE NUMBERS THAT. THE COVERAGE
HERE YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED NOW BUNCH OF TIMES
AND I'M GONNA VOTE FOR THIS
TODAY. BUT I JUST WANT TO PUT
THIS INTO THE ETHER OF THE
DISCUSSION I SUSPECT IT'LL GET
DISCUSSED IN. INSURANCE BUT IF
YOU'RE IN A CAR OR IF YOU'RE A
MINIMUM AMOUNTS IN YOUR CARS
WITH THIRTY GRAND FIFTEEN
THOUSAND OR SOMETHING IN THIS
IS MUCH HIGHER. YOU KNOW IT
JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT. THAT THE
AUTOMOBILE- LIABILITY. LIMITS
SHOULD INFORM THE THINKING HERE
OR THE NATURE OF THE RISK
SHOULD INFORM THE THINKING AND
I KNOW THAT THE OFFICE AS THAT
I JUST. THOUGHT IT WAS
APPROPRIATE TO MENTION IT THE
DISCUSSION OF THE SUPPORTING
HIM. BUT I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
AS WE TALK TO INSURANCE WE'VE
GOT ATTACHED TO SOME OF THOSE
LIMITS. AND HOW THE FUNDING
HAPPENS BUT THERE HAS TO BE A
FUND AS A CENTER CUBBY- SAYS.
OF SOME SORTS WHETHER IT'S
INSURANCE FUNDED OR OTHERWISE
FUNDED. BUT THE NUMBERS NEED TO
REFLECT. THE RISK BUT TO
SOCIETY I THINK THE NUMBERS ARE
JUST WAY OUT OF WHACK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG I CAN. EMPATHIZE WITH
YOUR COMMENTS WITH RESPECT TO
THESE NEW ADVANCED FORMS OF.
MOBILITY BUT YOU'RE YOU'RE IN
LUCK BECAUSE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
NINE DEALS WITH EQUESTRIAN
SAFETY SO IT'LL BE MORE ALONG
THE LINES OF. SOMETHING YOU'RE
FAMILIAR. WITH- ALL RIGHT.
TURNING NOW TO. SENATOR ALL. I
JUST THIS ISN'T A SOLUTION BUT
WHAT MAKES IT MORE COMPLICATED
IS THAT THIS IS PART OF THE GIG
ECONOMY NOW WHERE YOU DON'T
HAVE THE BRICKS AND MORTARS YOU
DRIVE UP YOU KNOW YOU GO UP TO
A BICYCLE RENTAL YOU KNOW WHO
THE COMPANY IS YOU KNOW WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE AND THAT'S THE END
OF THAT. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT. THIS GIG MAKES IT
ALL VERY NEBULOUS BAKES AT ALL
VERY CONFUSING AS TO WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT AND THE
ORIGINAL COMPANY DOESN'T WANT
TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
USER OR ANYONE THAT THEY BUMP
INTO OR CAUSE TO FALL DOWN THE
KNIFE TO BRING IT BACK TO US TO
SOLVE IT IS A REACTION TO
SOMETHING NOT BEING THOUGHT
ABOUT HIM IN THE FIRST PLACE BY
THESE VERY COMPANIES. THEY WANT
TO CREATE IT THEY WANT TO MAKE
THE PROFIT OUT OF IT BUT THEY
DON'T WANT TO THINK ABOUT AND
THEY SHOULD VERY EASILY THINK
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE A MOMENT IN WHICH
THIS IS GOING TO BE TAKEN UP WE
HAVE TO LOOK OUT FOR PEOPLE WHO
WERE INJURED IN ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER SO IF YOU LEAVE IT UP
TO US TO PUT IT. I HAD TO FIND
A SOLUTION THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO END UP WITH SO- AT
THIS POINT I'M NOT SUPPORTING
THE BILL THANK YOU SO THEY'RE
ALSO SAYING NO OTHER
MICROPHONES RAISED- IS THERE A
MOTION. SO A COUPLE EURO MOVES
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT- SALOON
WERE DONE SO UT KERR CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR COMMENTS- SO WE ARE IN
THE NEW WORLD- THE BRICK AND
MORTAR INDUSTRY GET RAND
CERTAIN. SURFBOARDS OR SKIS OR
JET SKIS THEY'RE IN PLACE THEY
HAVE INSURANCE THEY HAVE. WORK
IN THE ACT. E. IMPAIRMENT WHICH
IS A WHOLE NEW TERRITORY AS WAS
MENTIONED. BY SENATOR RADO AND
I BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT STANDARD
COPY I WAS ALLUDING TO. AND IT
ALSO CENTER HERZBERG THAT WE
ARE IN A AND WE'RE IN A
DIFFERENT PLACE. AND SO WE'RE
NOW MAKING RULES AND
REGULATIONS. FOR THAT LIKE WE-
LIKE MANY OF US OUGHT CARE. NOW
WE ALL PROBABLY TAKE LONGER AND
THAT'S IT APPLE DEVICE THAT WE
USE AND NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT
THAT WHAT KIND OF REGULATIONS
SO IN A NEW PLACE RIGHT NOW.
AND SO THIS GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CATCH UP. WITH
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE ARE
SAFE. AND THAT MORE IMPORTANT
THAT PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
DON'T GET LEFT BEHIND IN THIS
AND SO. I WILL WORK BECAUSE
THIS IS THIS IS TOO IMPORTANT
FOR US NOT TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN
THEY HAVE IT SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND SO WHAT EVER IT
TAKES I WILL WORK WITH. THE
OPPOSITION AND THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES I THINK WE'LL BE ABLE
TO GIVE ME SOME IDEA OF WHAT
THEY CAN AND CAN'T DO-
NATIONWIDE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU- IN WITH THAT-
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION THEN SHE
COUNSEL IF YOU CALL THE ROLL
YES THIS IS THE A. B. THREE
SEVENTY ONE BY FAMILY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER. WITH A MOTION BY
SENATOR COPY AT ALL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE AMBER
HI. AMBER I PORCHES. FOR JUST
NOT VOTING YET ALL. CARRY IT
ALL I DID I SAW. THAT I THOUGHT
I'D GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HURTS
BERG. HERZBERG I JONES. LAYERED
LAYERED ICE STERN WHITE HOUSE
SKI WHITE HOUSE SKI AT FIVE
WINNER. YOU HAVE SEVEN TO ZERO
SO FAR WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU NEXT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALL RON THANK YOU FOR
WAITING SO PATIENTLY YOU HAVE
TWO BILLS EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT IN A. B. NINE ZERO ONE-
LET'S START WITH ITEM NUMBER
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN. EIGHTY EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT CLARIFIES THAT FAMILY
REUNIFICATION SERVICES. MAY NOT
BE BY PASSED IF A PARENT WITH A
DRUG ADDICTION SUFFERS A
RELAPSE. AFTER SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETING DRUG TREATMENT.
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
STUDY NEARLY 80% OF
CALIFORNIANS MET THE CRITERIA
FOR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
RELAPSES ARE A REGULAR
OCCURRENCE IN REHABILITATION
JOURNEYS INCLUDING AN
INDIVIDUAL'S ACTIVELY SEEKING
TREATMENT. THE FAMILY BECOMES
INVOLVED WITH THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM THEY SHOULD NOT
AUTOMATICALLY LOSE ACCESS TO
REUNIFICATION SERVICES IF A
PARENT HAS RELAPSED. THIS BILL
PASSED OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY
UNANIMOUSLY AND IS NO
OPPOSITION. I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE ON CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL. WOULD
BE IN SUPPORT OF A. B. SEVEN A.
EIGHT R. JULIA HANNIGAN FROM
DEPENDENCY LEGAL SERVICES AND
AT HOWARD FROM THE CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY INSTITUTE. THANK YOU
BOB MISS HANNIGAN IF YOU'RE
AVAILABLE OR MISTER HOWARD ON
THE PHONE. NOW WOULD BE A GOOD
TIME TO MAKE YOURSELF KNOWN.
THANK YOU- MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JULIE
AND AGAIN I AM RELIEVED PARENTS
TOURNEY IN CINEMA COUNTY AND
POLICY DIRECTOR WITH DEPENDENCY
LEGAL SERVICES. DEPENDENCY
LEGAL SERVICES REPRESENT
PARENTS AND CHILDREN IN CHILD
WELFARE PROCEEDINGS IN EIGHT
COUNTIES ACROSS NORTHERN AND
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT. I HAVE YOUR
ANALYSIS CORRECTLY SUMMARIZES
CALIFORNIA LAW GREATLY
EMPHASIZES KEEPING FAMILIES
TOGETHER AND CHILDREN OUT OF
FOSTER CARE IF POSSIBLE. THIS
IS WHY. WE PROVIDE SERVICES TO
FAMILY INCLUDING DRUG TREATMENT
TO GIVE PARENTS A CHANCE TO
KEEP THEIR FAMILIES TOGETHER.
WE KNOW THAT RELAPSE IS PART OF
RECOVERING FROM THIS DISEASE.
RELAPSING AFTER MEANINGFUL
PROGRESS IN DRUG TREATMENT IS
DEEMED TO BE THE EQUIVALENT OF
REFUSING TO PARTICIPATE IN DRUG
TREATMENT ALTOGETHER THEN WE BY
LAW MAKE THE PERSON'S NEEDS FOR
SERVICES A BASIS FOR DENYING
THEM THE VERY SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED. WITH THE RESULT THAT
FAMILIES THAT COULD BE
PRESERVED ARE NEVER GIVEN THAT
CHANCE. AND THAT'S WHAT EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT IS ABOUT A
CHANCE. PARENTS OFFERING FROM
THE ADDICTION STILL HAVE. YOU
DO WELL ENOUGH IN DRUG
TREATMENT TO PROVE TO A JUDGE
THAT IT IS SAFE FOR THEM TO GET
THEIR CHILDREN BACK EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT DOES NOT
CHANGE THAT. IT JUST SAYS THAT
A RELAPSE DOES NOT
AUTOMATICALLY DISQUALIFY YOU
FROM GETTING BACK TO YOU. THE
CHANCE TO GET HELP TO GET YOUR
CHILDREN BACK IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU MISS HANNIGAN MR HOW'RE YOU
AVAILABLE. I HAVE A GOOD
AFTERNOON ASTRONOMERS AT HOWARD
JUNIOR COUNSEL THE CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY INSTITUTE HE'S A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS IMPORTANT
BUILDING SECTOR LAST YEAR I.
THANK YOU JAMES HOWARD ALL
RIGHT AND- IN THE GALLERY WHICH
TESTIFIED SPORTS SEEING NONE
NOW ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING NOT
A ROOM ONE TWELVE. MATTER IF
YOU QUEUE UP THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF IT- A. B.
SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT WE'D BE
GRATEFUL. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ON THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU WISH TO KEEP OPEN SUPPORT
FOR A. B. SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AT
THIS TIME. AND AFTER ALLOWING A
FEW MOMENTS NO ONE IS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHTY- LET'S
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION I SEE NO
PRINCIPAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY NOR IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SO I SEE- ON THE
PHONE LINES ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN. OPPOSITION TO A. B.
SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT. IN ENERAL
THE PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR
SURE NO ONE IS COMING UP AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE CHAMBER
ANYONE WISH TO ASK QUESTION YES
AN EARLIER. I DON'T WISH TO ASK
A QUESTION- JUST MOVED A BILL
SIMILAR MOVES THE BILL ANYONE
ELSE WISHES TO. COMMENT
QUESTIONS DONE SAYING NONE. ALL
RIGHT. OF THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED- ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA DO
WISH TO CLOSE. AT THANK YOU MR
TERRORISTIC PLANS FOR AN IPO
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. RIGHT
BENCH ACCOUNTS OF YOU CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CALLED IT ON- WITH THE MOTION
BY SENATOR THERE THE MOTION IS
DO YOU PASS. ON BERG HI AMBERG
BY PORTIS. GORGEOUS I CARRY IT
OFF. HEAVY AT ALL I DID ASK.
THE REST I GO INSIDE. GONZALEZ
I HURTS BERG. PITTSBURGH I'D
JONES. LAYERED LAYERED ICE
STERN BY CAL SKI QUAKE OWSKI I
WINNER. YOU HAVE EIGHT ZERO SO
FAR WITH THE MEMBERS MISSED
MISSING ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL NEXT IS AB NINE
ZERO ONE AND BEFORE YOU PRESENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COLORADO- IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING YOU'VE AGREED
TO AMEND THE BILL ON THE SENATE
FLOOR TO INCLUDE THE-
AUTOMOBILE RENTERS CHILDREN OR
PERSONS FOR WHOM THE RENTER IS
A LEGAL GUARDIAN PROVIDED THEY
MEET THE RENTAL CAR COMPANIES
OTHER REQUIREMENTS TO THE
CATEGORY OF DRIVERS WHO CAN
DRIVE A RENTAL CAR WITH AN
ADDITIONAL FEE IS THAT CORRECT.
YES MR COUNTERACTED THEN YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO THOSE AMENDMENTS I
AM SORRY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
ALL RIGHT. SO REMEMBER THE
FORGERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
EIGHTY NINE EITHER ONE WOULD
MODERNIZE STATE LAWS GOVERNING
THE RENTAL CAR INDUSTRY THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
TAKEN A TOLL ON THIS INDUSTRY
WITH NEARLY TWO THIRDS DECLINE
OF REVENUE FOR AIRPORT RENTALS
SINCE THE START OF THE PANDEMIC
UNFORTUNATELY CURRENT LAW
IMPOSES. SOME REASONABLE
RESTRICTIONS THAT DO NOT MAKE
SENSE IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR
INSTANCE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT THE DAMAGE WAIVER PRICE
CAP WAS SET AT NINE DOLLARS TO
CURB COURSE OF SALES TAX AT THE
COUNTER. THIRTY THREE YEARS
LATER NEARLY HALF OF DAMAGE
WAIVERS ARE PURCHASED ONLINE
AND HAD A NINE DOLLAR AMOUNT
KEPT UP WITH INFLATION THESE
OPTIONAL DAMAGE WAIVERS WOULD
COST TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS
INSTEAD OF TODAY'S STATUTORY
AMOUNT OF ELEVEN DOLLARS. A. B.
NINE ZERO ONE IS A BALANCED
APPROACH TO GIVE THE RENTAL CAR
INDUSTRY SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC
WITHOUT SACRIFICING IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THIS BILL
DOES NOT ELIMINATE DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER TO REMOVE
A CONSUMER'S ABILITY TO PURSUE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION. SHOULD
THIS BILL MAKE IT OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY I COMMIT TO
AMENDING ANY NINE ONE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR AND TO INCLUDE
SUGGESTIONS FROM THE CHAIR. ON
THE PHONE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IS RONA ALARMING
OF ON BEHALF OF ENTERPRISE. AND
JOHN ROSS ON BEHALF OF HERTZ.
ALREADY MR ROSSI AVAILABLE. I
AM HERE ALL RIGHT MR ROSS
CLOSURES. GUN RIGHTS IF YOU
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
HERTZ CORPORATION I WILL FOCUS
MY COMMENTS ON THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL THAT PROPOSES TO
LET THE STATUTORY CAP. ON WHAT
INSURERS I HAVE MENTIONED THE
DAMAGE WAIVERS ORIGINALLY CAP
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AT
NINE DOLLARS AN INCREASE A
DECADE AGO. TO ELEVEN SEVENTY
DOLLARS DEPENDING ON THE PRICE
OF THE CAR. FIRST A LOT OF
DAMAGE WAIVER IS AN OPTIONAL
PRODUCT. IS NOT REQUIRED TO
RENT A CAR. RENTAL COMPANIES
ARE REQUIRED TO DISCLOSE THAT
IT IS NOT REQUIRED AND THAT
THEIR OWN INSURANCE YOUR CREDIT
CARD MAY PROVIDE SIMILAR
COVERAGE. CONSUMERS UNDERSTAND
THE PRODUCT WITH THE OPTIONAL.
ROUGHLY 80% OF CONSUMERS
DECLINED THE OPTION. THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE TWO PARTS OF
THE DAMAGE WAIVER ARE MEMBERS
OF BUSINESS PROGRAMS ANOTHER
LOYALTY PROGRAM. AND CONSUMERS
ARE PRICE SENSITIVE. CONSUMERS
SELECT THE OPTION IN STATES
WITH HIGHER RATES. SECOND THE
MANNER IN WHICH MOST PEOPLE
REGARDLESS CHANGED DRAMATICALLY
BOTH CONSUMERS RENT CARS IN
ADVANCE. ONLINE AND THE
LEGISLATURE RECENTLY REWROTE
THE RULES GOVERNING HOW RENTAL
CAR RATES ARE QUOTED IN CHARGE.
EVERY CONSUMER NOW RECEIVES AN
OUT THE DOOR QUOTE. THAT
INCLUDES ALL MANDATORY CHARGES
AND ANY OPTION SELECTED BY THE
CONSUMER INCLUDING THE DAMAGE
WAIVER. AMOUNT QUOTED BY PEOPLE
THE AMOUNT CHARGED. AND IF WE
GET ANY OF THE WRONG CURRENT
LAW HAD A SPECIFIC PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION APPLICABLE TO
RENTAL CAR TRANSACTIONS. ALLOW
CONSUMERS TO STILL. I KNOW THE
CAP CURRENT LAW THAT GETS IT
AND WHAT CONFLATION AS YOUR
FAMILY MEMBER MENTIONED THE
NINE DOLLAR CAP ACTED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WITH
PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS
TODAY ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION.
FIVE CALIFORNIA ONLY NEW YORK
AS WELL IMAGE WAVERED
POTENTIALLY BELOW MARKET.
ILLINOIS RECENTLY REVEALED
THEIR CAP. THIS BILL CONTAINS
THE THREE ARE FUNDS THAT WHICH
WILL ALLOW THE COMMITTEE TO
EVALUATE RENTAL COMPANIES
BEHAVIOR AND REVISIT THE ISSUE
IF NEEDED. ARTICLE SHORTLY
EMERGE FROM BANKRUPTCY AND
MODEST RELIEF PROVIDED BY THIS
BILL WILL HELP US GET
OPERATIONS BACK TO NORMAL IN
CALIFORNIA- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME YOU HAVE. THANK YOU BUT
RUN ACT ALARMING. YES THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN BIRDS ROCKING
LONNIE FROM NEW YORK TO MARK
MARK ON BEHALF OF ENTERPRISE
HOLDINGS COMPRISED OF
ENTERPRISE ALAMO AND NATIONAL
BRAND STRONG SUPPORT AT EIGHTY
NINE OH ONE WHICH PASSED THE
SENATE UNANIMOUSLY WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THE FILTER
AT THE AT THE RENTAL CAR A LOT
OF DAMAGE WAIT FOR CAPPING THE
PARTIALLY REMOVED A PROHIBITION
AGAINST ADDITIONAL DRIVER FEES
BOTH OF WHICH AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED ARE OPTIONAL CONSUMER
OFFERING WE BELIEVE IT'S HARD
TO BELIEVETHEM ALL GIVEN A
THREE YEAR FACT THAT ENABLES
THE LEGISLATURE TO REVISIT THE
CAPPUCCINO. AND THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT CAN NARROW THEIR
DISCOGRAPHY IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT BACKSTREET CAP ARE ON
AN OPTIONAL PRODUCTS SHOULD NOT
BE CONFUSED WITH TRANSPARENCY
OR CONSUMER PROTECTION CONTRARY
TO THE OPPONENT'S ARGUMENT THEY
ARE NOT NECESSARY IN ORDER FOR
CONSUMERS TO KNOW THE TOTAL
PRICE OF THE CAR THAT THEY'RE
RENTING IN FACT EIGHTY NINE OH
ONE PRESERVES ALL OF THE
EXISTING MANDATORY DISCLOSURES
AND NOTICES THAT INSURABLE
TRANSPARENCY IN PRICING AND
RELATED CONSUMER DISCLOSURES
SHOULD WE VIOLATE THOSE
PROTECTIONS THAT MENTION MY
DOCTOR WE ARE SUBJECT TO AN
EXISTING PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION. BY WAY OF EXAMPLE PAGES
THREE AND FOUR OF THE BILL
BEFORE YOU WORK BACK MANDATES
THAT WE MAKE CLEAR AND
CONSPICUOUS DISCLOSURES
RELATING TO THE COST OF ANY
DAMAGE WAIVER THAT IS IN
ADDITION TO THE RENTAL RATE THE
POTENTIAL FOR SOME OR ALL OF
THE RUNNERS LIABILITY TO BE
COVERED UNDER THEIR OWN
PERSONAL INSURANCE OR THE
CREDIT CARD USED TO PAY FOR THE
RENTAL AND THE FACT THAT DAMAGE
WHATEVER MAYBE DUPLICATE.
COVERAGE YOU KNOW I DON'T WANT
TO CHANGE ANY OF THESE AFTER
CONCERNS THAT CONSUMERS CAN BE
MISLED BY ADVERTISEMENTS THAT
DO NOT BECAUSE THE FULL RATE
FOR AN ADDITIONAL PRIVACY ABOUT
THE PROHIBITION IT'S DESIGNED
TO LET THE CONSUMER KNOW THE
FULL RATE THEIR PAIN WE KNOW
THAT SECTION ONE NINETY THREE
NINE POINT ONE LINE OF THE
CIVIL CODE REFLECTED ON PAGE
TEN INCLUDES A BEVY OF CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AROUND
ADVERTISEMENT ALTHOUGH IT WOULD
CONTINUE TO APPLY ULTIMATELY AS
A RESULT OF EXISTING LOT RENTAL
CAR COMPANIES ARE REQUIRED TO
CALL A TOTAL OUT THE DOOR
PRICE. WHICH MUST INCLUDE ANY
OPTION SELECTED BY THE CONSUMER
WHETHER YOU CHARGE. FOR DAMAGE
WAIVER BABY FEAT HE RACKED OUR
OTHER. SAID I'LL TRY TO MAKE IT
THAT MY QUOTED. EIGHTY NINE OH
ONE PER. ALL THE PROJECTS IN
WINNING THING. ALREADY THANK
YOU- ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY WHICH IS BROTHER
NOW THEIR AFFILIATES IN THERE
BUT SAYING NONE- ROOM ONE
SEEING NONE OF ONE TWO. MATER
IF YOU CHEW UP- WHICH IS IN
SOME OF A BEATEN OH. THAT WOULD
BE WONDERFUL. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE YOUR VOICE HEARD
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
IT'S ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE WILL
START WITH A LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR THAT'S
ONE THREE FOUR. HELLO CHAIR
NUMBER A MILLION MONEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRAVELED TO HOUSTON CALLING AT
THE PORT OF EIGHTY NINE ZERO
ONE. ZERO THANK YOU. WELL
MEXICO LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE CENTS ONE TO
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
KERRY MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IN ORDER LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
IT'S THE ONLY ONES DOING Q. I
DON'T KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
THERE- NUMBER PROVIDED ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. IT APPEARS A
FOREVER THEMSELVES FROM THE
QUEUE. ALL RIGHTY THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY NINE OH ONE.
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME SIR OKAY- LET'S NOT TURN
THE OPPOSITION I BELIEVE MR
DANIEL GET TEAR THIS IS-
AVAILABLE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION. MR GUTERRES. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT LONG FOUGHT
FOR CONSUMER RIGHTS AND
PROTECTIONS WE LOOKED
UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSED EIGHTY
NINE OH ONE BECAUSE IT
ELIMINATES THE SPECIAL
PROTECTIONS FOR CAR RENTAL
CUSTOMERS. SPECIFICALLY THE
BILL WOULD ELIMINATE EXISTING
CAP ON HOW MUCH A CONSUMER
COULD BE CHARGED FOR THE
VEHICLE DAMAGE WAIVER THE
CAPITAL IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION THAT WAS ORIGINALLY
DESIGNED TO DEFEND RECORD
AGAINST COURSE OF BELT
TECHNIQUES USED TO SELL THEM TO
TERRORISTS WHICH ARE OFTEN
DUPLICATIVE OF EXISTING
COVERAGE FROM A RENTER'S CREDIT
CARD. WHAT OPPONENTS HAVE
ARGUED AT THE TOP IS NO LONGER
NEEDED GIVEN THE FACT THAT MOST
INDIVIDUALS BOOK RENTAL ONLINE
IT IS STILL COMMON PRACTICE FOR
CAR RENTAL ASSOCIATE TO BRING
UP THE DAMAGE WAIVER AND HAVE
TO SELL IT WHEN THE COUPLE
ARRIVED TO PICK UP THEIR CAR.
LEAVING THEM VULNERABLE TO
THESE KINDS OF SALES TACTICS
THIS CHANGE WOULD ALSO SUBJECT
ALL CORPORATE BUYER RATINGS AT
THE COMPANY'S DISCRETION
REGARDLESS WHETHER THE BOOK
ONLINE OR NOT THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION HAS SUGGESTED SOME
MIDDLE GROUND AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD INCREASE THE CAP BY 50%
AND I GOT A LOAN THROUGH
INFLATION GOING INTO THE
FUTURE. AND WE BELIEVE THIS
WOULD BE FAIR AND WOULD PROTECT
CONSUMERS FROM EVER HIGHER RATE
FOR THE DAMAGE WAIVER. WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING THE INTERNET EXPANDING
THE AUTHORIZED- CORRECT HE
PROBATION OF A CHARGING AN
AUTHORIZED DRIVER FOR THE
RENTER'S CHILDREN- WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT EXPANDED A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER TO OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS INCLUDING
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS- BUT
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK. THE
OFFICE FOR THAT THAT THAT WAS
TAKEN. ONE LAST. DURING THE
CONSUMER CREDIT HAD WITH IT
JUST THE CHARGE OF TWICE THE
AUTHOR DRIVERS BE ON OFF
DRIVERS WHICH WE BELIEVE IT
KIND OF IGNORES THE
COMPLEXITIES OF EVERYDAY LIFE
THE RECORD MAY FACE HOW WHY
SHOULD SOMEONE BE CHARGED EXTRA
FOR HAVING A FRIEND TRIED THE
BOTTLE IN A RENTAL CAR DURING
AN EMERGENCY- THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION ELIEVE THAT THIS
SPEECH SHOULD BE CHANGED SO
THAT IT IS THE SAME. AS THE
AUTHORIZED DRIVER THE- THANK
YOU DON'T. THANK YOU MR GOOD
TEARS ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION- HERE
IN THE GALLERY SEEING NONE ROOM
ONE TWELVE SEEING ONE
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP THOSE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINE OH ONE
NAME AFFILIATION POSITION. IF
YOU WISH TO QUEUE UP IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY NINE OH
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR SURE NO
ONE IS COMING UP IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. ALREADY THANK
YOU- WELL ALL I SEE SENATOR
SENATOR ASOS MICROPHONES RACE
AND- THEY'RE ALSO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR BUT QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR- COUPLE QUESTIONS ARE
ONE IS. WHY THE SUNSET CHANGE
OF SUNSET IT'S THREE YEARS WHY
NOT DO A SHORTER TIME AND THEN
ALL WHITE COMPLETELY ELIMINATE
THE CAP THERE HAS BEEN-
OBVIOUSLY SOME CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR THAT AND-
THERE'S A GOOD ARGUMENT TO BE
MADE THAT THAT HASN'T BEEN
ALLOWED TO. KEEP UP WITH THAT
THE COST OF OVERTIME BUT IT
SEEMS TO BE GOING TO THE OTHER
EXTREME WHICH IS COMPLETELY
ELIMINATING THE CAP AND- I
KNOW. YOU KNOW I READ A LOT OF
CARS ESPECIALLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC I DIDN'T FLY- AND I
DON'T EVER REMEMBER GETTING AN
ORAL. EXPLANATION AS TO YOU
KNOW THIS- COLLISION DAMAGE
WAIVER AND THE USE OF IT SO I
HAVE SOME CONCERNS- I'M READY
I'D BE WILLING TO SUPPORT BUT
IF YOU COULD ANSWER THOSE TWO
QUESTIONS APPRECIATED SIR
SIMILAR CALL RON DO YOU CARE TO
RESPOND OUR NEW CLOTHES. I'M
ALWAYS FINE NOW I ACTUALLY
THINK THE SENATOR TORONTO FOR
THOSE QUESTIONS AND I'M GOING
TO DEFER TO YOU MIGHT WITNESS A
EITHER JOHN ROSS OR RUN BACK.
MR ROSS ARE YOU AVAILABLE. FOR
YEAH I'M- ON THE FIRST TRIP THE
TIME THE DEFENSE THAT YOU KNOW
SHORTER THAN THREE YEARS- WOULD
MEAN WE'D HAVE TO COME BACK IN
A YEAR WITH VERY LITTLE
EXPERIENCE AND PASS THE BILL
THE FIRST YEAR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE. SESSION THE IDEA
WAS TO PUT IT INTO EFFECT
JANUARY ONE- UP NEXT YEAR THAT
THERE WOULD BE A YEAR OR SO OF
EXPERIENCE THE BILL COULD BE
INTERVIEWED ON THE TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND AND WE
HAVE THE- PROTECTION TO. DEBATE
THE FRONT THAT THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE. A
REASONABLE PERIOD OF TIME TO
SEE WHAT HAPPENS AND THEN A
REPORTER AT THE TIME TO. PASS
THE BILL- THAT ONE YOU KNOW ADD
TO- THE DISCLOSURES THAT ARE
REQUIRED- THERE'S AN ORAL
DISCLOSURE REQUIRED IF YOU'RE
AT THE COUNTER IF YOU'RE
BOOKING ONLINE OR BOOKING- TO A
PROGRAM OR YOUR EMPLOYER.
TYPICALLY DOES DISCLOSURES ARE
MADE IN ADVANCE AND IN WRITING
I'M NOT TECHNICAL CHANGES THOSE
DISCLOSURES- THERE ON PAGE
THREE FOUR AND FIVE OF THE
BILL. AND AGAIN IF WE- NOT BAD
OUT LEGAL TERM OF ART- THERE.
IS THE ABILITY TO DO THE
COMPANY DIRECTLY. OUR FROM SORT
OF DRUG DOES RESP YOUR QUESTION
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU IN ELSE A
YES AND A COUPLE. YES MISTER
CHAIR- IT COULD YOU US WHAT IT
WHAT THE RANGE OF THE FEES THAT
ARE CHARGED GENERALLY FOR THESE
PARTICULAR- THINGS THAT YOU'RE
ASKING TO BE SUSPENDED- I I'M I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S PROBABLY A
RANGE AND- SET IT SO THAT WE
CAN KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT ON THE
BILL IT'S INTENTIONAL. FOR CAR
RENTAL. YES YES YOU CAN RESPOND
OPEN HAPPENS TO ROSS INTEREST
ROSSER MISSED THE ALARMING.
YEAH SURE THE INDUSTRY
COMMISSIONED A STUDY THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO THE COMMITTEE HERE
AND THEN THE ASSEMBLY A LOOK AT
THAT AND PROVIDE SOME SPECIFIC
CONCERNS THE CENTER CALERO I
THINK WHAT THE STUDY FOUND IS
IN THOSE STATES WITH NO CAPS
THE PRICES RANGE BETWEEN TWENTY
TWO AND TWENTY SEVEN DOLLARS
GIVE OR TAKE- AS I MENTIONED IN
MY STATEMENT ONLY- NEW YORK YOU
KNOW STILL HAS A CAPITAL MARKET
THE PRICES ARE DEPRESSED THERE
BUT- YOU KNOW IN ILLINOIS WHICH
RECENTLY REMOVED THE CAP I
THINK THAT. THE RICES LANDED.
SOMEWHERE IN THE TWENTY FIVE
DOLLAR RANGE. AND THEY'RE BOTH
IN HEY'RE TWO SEPARATE FEES
RIGHT. QUESTION DO YOU MISTER
ROSS. ARE YOU THERE IS A THERE
IS A FEE THAT IS REGULATED FOR-
BAD DAMAGE WAIVER AND THERE IS
A TEAR TO BE UNDER EXISTING LAW
FOR COMPACT CARS AND MID SIZED
CARS- BEGAN YEAH THE BILL
PROPOSES TO ALLOW THE COMPANY
TO SET THOSE- CHARGES. THAT
SEPARATELY I GUESS WE CAN
DISCUSS THIS WITH THE
ADDITIONAL DRIVER- AND THAT HAS
NOT BEEN A REGULATED CHARGE
IT'S JUST BEEN- A CHARGE THAT
WAS LIMITED IN THE INSTANCE
THAT THERE COULD BE A POP IN
POP UP BOOK BOTH THE CHARGES
ARE UP AGAIN FOR OPTIONAL
PRODUCTS NO ONE'S REQUIRED. TO
BUY EITHER IN ORDER TO GET. A
CAR I HOPE THAT ANSWERS THE
QUESTION. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THAT SO IS RIGHT. MORE AND
ONE IS NOT SO THE UNREGULATED
FEE COULD ACTUALLY BE WHATEVER
THE CAR COMPANY WANTS TO CHARGE
IS THAT GENERALLY HOW IT GETS
SET. CORRECT THANK YOU FOR THE
CARRIER SAID WHAT KELSEY DID
YOU HAVE A QUESTION. I GUESS
pDISCUSSION MR CHERRY SAID THE
OPPOSITION WHICH IS
REPRESENTING THE CONSUMERS IS
WILLING TO REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION AND LET THE FEET GO
UP BY FIFTY PERCENT. WITH THE
THREE YEAR SUNSET SO PRESUMABLY
OF TO THE FEE FOR A COMPACT
CARS ELEVEN DOLLARS GOES TO
SIXTEEN FIFTY IN A MID SIZE
SEVENTEEN DOLLARS GOES TO.
TWENTY TWO FIFTY OR TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY. THE RENTAL COMPANIES I
MEAN THIS IS SAID ADD ON FOR A
FEATURE THAT THEY HAVE NOT
THEIR THEIR BREAD AND BUTTER IS
TO RENT CARS AND WE'VE HEARD
ANECDOTALLY THAT. TICKET OR
RENT A CAR TODAY HIS NEXT
IMPOSSIBLE BECAUSE IT'S SO HOT
THE FLEETS OR DELETE DEPLETED I
UNDERSTAND THE URGENCY FOR THE-
FOR THE FOR THE BILL- I'M JUST.
I'M I HAVEN'T BEEN PERSUADED BY
THE AUTHOR- HE'S TAKING. THE
LIMITED INCREASE VERSUS THE
WAIVER WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL TO
THE RECOVERY OF THE RENTAL CAR
BUSINESS SINCE OUR BRAND BETTER
IS TO RENT THE CARS AND THEN
COME BACK IN. IN THREE YEARS
THEY GET THE COST OF LIVING
ANYWAY AND COME IN AND ASKED
FOR. A FURTHER ADJUSTMENT IF
IT'S SUPPOSED TO GO UP TO
TWENTY TWO DOLLARS AND MAKE THE
CASE IT SEEMS LIKE THIS IS A-
THIS IS A GOOD. GOOD CONSUMER-
OF PROTECTION BUT ALSO TRYING
TO HELP OUT THE PEOPLE TODAY-
DOING BUSINESS HERE SO. I'M
GUTTED. I'M NOT THERE YET ON
THE ON THE BILL I GUESS IS WHAT
I'M SAYING ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SIR WHAT CAL SKATE OTHER
QUESTIONS CMMENTS SAYING NONE
OF CENTER. THANK YOU- MISTER
CHAIR AND JUST. I WILL SUPPORT
THE BILL AS WELL FIVE TODAY BUT
JUST A QUESTION THAT I DON'T
KNOW THAT WAS ANSWERED AS WELL
ON THE- IN THE OPPOSITION THAT-
THE RENTAL COMPANIES CAN CHARGE
UP TO TWICE THE AUTHORIZED
DRIVER FEE IF THEY DISCOVER
THAT AN AUTHORIZED DRIVER HAS
DRIVEN THE VEHICLE. I JUST WANT
TO ENSURE THAT THAT. IS STILL
THE CASE. IN THIS IN THIS BILL
THAT HASN'T BEEN ADDRESSED. I
DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S BEEN
ADDRESSED MR ROTH'S FIGHT BE
ABLE TO SPEAK TO THAT GREAT
THANK. I'M SORRY I I'M NOT SURE
IF IT'S THE ONLY NUMBER WHETHER
THAT WAS IN THE- OFFICE. THAT
THEY REQUESTED THAT YOU. WERE
NOT. THE CURRENT. IF I MAY.
YEAH HELLO. SORRY MR CHAIRMAN
ROCKY ALLOW ME. TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION I THINK ONE OF THE
DIFFICULTIES AND I BELIEVE THAT
WAS AN AMENDMENT SEEKING COMING
OUT OF PRIVATE BLOODY HELL THAT
WAS MEANT TO BE PROTECTED FOR
US TO UNDO WHAT WE WOULD
BASICALLY BE DOING THE WORK OF
ANOTHER COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHTY
DOES THAT RESPOND TO YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR DOLE'S HERE
THAT HAS BEEN TAKEN OUT AND
MENDED OUT AND ANOTHER
COMMITTEE. THE IDEA OF
PERSONALITY TRAITS BY THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY GREAT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT YES SENATOR RUSSELL.
I AM I'M GOING TO SUPPORT TODAY
BUT I REALLY URGE THE AUTHOR
AND THE PROPONENTS TO RE LOOK
AT THE- THE CAP ISSUE I
RECONSIDER THAT AT SOMETHING
THAT'S- MUCH MORE- REASONABLE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR RUSSELL
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS SAYING
NONE ALL RIGHT IS THERE A
MOTION FROM. SERVERS BERG MOVED
TO BILL BELICHICK K. O. G. LIKE
CLOSE SEVEN OR CHOLERA YES
MA'AM THANK YOU AT TEN MISTER
CHAIRMAN- I APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS- FROM
THIS BODY AND- I ASKED
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT
OUT. THANK YOU BELGIC COUNTS
THE CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
EIGHTY NINE OH ONE BY A FAMILY
MEMBER BECAUSE THEY DON'T- MET
WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG MOTION IS TO PASS. A
BERG HI AMBER I'D BURGESS
BURGESS I GOT IT ALL. CREATE A
I DID ALSO. DID I THOUGHT I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HURTS BERG
HURTS BERG I JONES. LAYERED
LAYERED ICE STERN WHITE HOUSE
SKI. QUAKE OWSKI NO WINNER.
THAT IS. THREE ONE TWO FOUR SIX
SEVEN TO ONE SO FAR WITH
MEMBERS MISSING. ALL RIGHTY
THANK YOU PUT THE BILL ON CALL-
NEXT WE HAVE- THE BUILD IT THAT
SERVE HERTZBERG'S BEEN WAITING
FOR THAT'S- ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY NINE SEVEN FOUR SO
REMEMBER LOUIS REAVIS
CONCERNING. EQUESTRIAN SAFETY.
BUT. SEVEN NUMBER REVERSE THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND SENATORS AB
NINE SEVENTY FOUR REQUIRES
MINERS TO WEAR A HELMET WHEN
RIDING A HORSE ON PAVED
HIGHWAYS AND MANDATES THAT ALL
WRITERS OR THEIR EQUINES WEAR
REFLECTIVE GEAR- LIGHTS AT
SUNDOWN. ANANICH TOBER EVENING
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN A
VEHICLE STRUCK TWO INDIVIDUALS
RIDING THEIR HORSES IN THE
COMMUNITY OF LAKE VIEW TERRACE
OF LOS ANGELES WHICH IS LOCATED
IN MY DISTRICT. THIS CRASH
KILLED THE TWO HORSES AND LEFT
THE TWO RIDERS IN CRITICAL
CONDITION MEMBERS OF MY
COMMUNITY WHICH YOU WILL HEAR
FROM SHORTLY BROUGHT THE SAFETY
CONCERNS TO MY ATTENTION. AFTER
RESEARCHING THIS ISSUE WE FOUND
SIMILAR COLLISIONS IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF SAUGUS AND WILL
TEND IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S COMMON
FOR HORSES TO SHARE THE ROAD
WITH VEHICLES HOWEVER IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT FOR DRIVERS TO SEE
RIDERS AND THEIR HORSES IN THE
DARK. WHEN THESE COLLISIONS
OCCUR THE WRITERS YOU ARE
USUALLY THROWN OFF THEIR HORSES
LEAVING THEM IN CRITICAL
CONDITION. THE HORSES USUALLY
DIE UPON COLLISION OR MUST BE
EUTHANIZED DUE TO THE INJURIES
THAT THEY SUSTAINED. EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTY FOUR IS THE
DISTRICT GENERATED PROPOSAL
THAT FURTHER PROTECTS WRITERS
AND THEIR EQUINES THROUGH
INCREASED VISIBILITY AND SAFETY
MEASURES. TODAY I HAVE WITH ME
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY- THEY ARE
LEADERS OF THE EQUESTRIAN
COMMUNITY IN LOS ANGELES I HAVE
GENE A CRUISE AND- SURE RE
BLOUSE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU-
MISS CRUISER MISSED PLUS
AVAILABLE. YES THIS IS GINA
CREEP I'M HERE. MISS CRUZ
CLOSURES. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- AS I SAID
MY NAME IS GINA CRUZ I'M FROM
THE COMMUNITY OF LAKEVIEW
TERRACE I'M HERE TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY FOUR I LIVE ON A RANCH
IN THE WORD COMMUNITY AT A
SUBURBAN AREA THE CITY LOS
ANGELES ALL WITH MY FAMILY IN
FIVE COURSES LIKE MANY WRITERS
AND SUBURBAN AREAS MY DAUGHTER
AND I REGULARLY WRITER HORSES
ON CITY STREETS THE ACTOR FOR
LOCAL TRAILS. IT'S VERY COMMON
TO SEE HORSES ON THE STREET IN
MY COMMUNITY IN FACT MANY OF
THE STREETS IN OUR COMMUNITY
ARE DESIGNATED EQUESTRIAN TRAIL
WELL WE DON'T HAVE A CONTINUOUS
BATTLE CAP ON THE STREET THE
SEPARATE RIDERS FROM TRAFFIC SO
WE SHARE THE ROAD THE CARD
ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO AS A FAMILY
MEMBER READ AS MENTIONED THERE
WAS A TERRIBLE ACCIDENT HERE ON
A BUSY STREET INVOLVING A
QUESTION THAT A VEHICLE. A
COUPLE WAS RIDING ALONG
FOOTHILL BOULEVARD AT NIGHT
WHEN THEY WERE STRUCK FROM
BEHIND THE RIGHT OF RETURN FROM
THEIR HORSES THAT WERE TO BE
REALLY INJURED REQUIRING
HOSPITALIZATION BOTH HORSES
CATTLE WERE KILLED IF THE
WRITERS HAVE BEEN WEARING
REFLECTIVE GEAR IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT THE TRIBAL ACCENT COULD
HAVE BEEN AVOIDED AND THIS IS
NOT THE FIRST TIME SUCH AN
INCIDENT HAS HAPPENED HERE AND
IT LIKELY WON'T BE THE LAST
CHANGES ARE MADE. WHEN MY
DAUGHTER AND I WRITE AT NIGHT
ALWAYS WEAR REFLECTIVE VESTS
AND PUT REFLECTIVE GEAR ON THE
HORSES IT'S JUST THE SMART
THING TO DO NOT ONLY FOR SAFETY
OF THE WRITERS AND THE FORCES
BUT ALSO FOR DRIVERS SO THAT
THEY CAN SEE IF ONE WERE ON THE
BOAT ROAD AND AVOID A COLLISION
WE ALSO ALWAYS WEAR HELMETS
WHEN WE RIDE HORSES ARE FLIGHT
ANIMALS IT DOESN'T TAKE MUCH TO
POTENTIALLY IF THE COURT. AND
IF TE WRITER FROM BOB THERE
CAN BE SERIOUS RISK OF HEAD
INJURY PARTICULARLY ONE FALLING
ONTO PEDRO'S. CAN MAKE THEIR
OWN DECISIONS ON THE LEVEL OF
RISK THEY WANT TO TAKE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT CHILDREN BE
PROTECTED BY REQUIRING THEY
WEAR A HELMET WHEN RIDING ON
THE STREET I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME TODAY AND RIGHT BACK BILLY
OPERATOR I BUILT IN FAVOR OF
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY FOUR TO
INCREASE THE SAFETY AND
VISIBILITY OF QUESTIONS AND
HORSES WHEN WE'RE SHARING THE
ROAD WITH EHICLES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CRUZ MISSED PLUS.
PLUS IT. I THINK SHE NOT BE
AVAILABLE ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT
LET'S TELL YOU HERE- SHE'S A
GREAT SOUNDING LAOS THEY ALL
RIGHT YEAH BOB ZERO SHARES HI
I'M SHERRY BLOAT I AM A
LONGTIME RESIDENT OF CELLMARK
WORDS VERY NORTH EAST END OF
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY IN
EXTREMELY HEAVY EQUESTRIAN
COMMUNITY I'M A LOCAL I'M ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE LOCAL-
EQUESTRIAN CLUB CROWD TWELVE
I'M ALSO THE REPRESENTATIVE.
FOR THE SUMMER NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL. I AND HIS SUPPORT
THANK ISSUE HAS BEEN AN ISSUE
WITH US FOR A VERY LONG TIME
AND WE'VE SUPPORTED IT AT A
LOCAL LEVEL. IN THE PAST WE'VE
HANDED OUT. MANY MANY
REFLECTIVE GEAR PACKAGES BUT
THERE WAS NO REQUIREMENT THAT
THE WRITERS ACTUALLY HAVE TO
WEAR THEM. AND SO THEY THEY
DON'T HAVE HORSE ACCIDENTS
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN. MANY OF THE
LOCAL WRITERS IN OUR AREA COME
HOME FROM WORK PACK UP THEIR
HORSE THAT HAD FOR THE TRAILS
FOR TO WORK THEIR FORCES OUT.
THEY STAY OUT AS LATE AS THEY
CAN ON A WARM SUMMER EVENING IN
THAT HEAD HOME AFTER THE SUN
HAS COME DOWN. IF THERE IS
NOTHING WORSE THAN COMING UP
AGAINST A- DARK HORSE. BUT THE
RIDER WITH DARK CLOTHES ON A
DARK STREET IT'S A DISASTER
THERE'S NOTHING WORSE THAN IN
CALGARY NOW THIS IS A RECIPE
FOR THIS AFTER THE HORSES AND
RIDERS ARE ALWAYS A LOSER. I
STRONGLY RECOMMEND. SUPPORTING
THIS BILL BECOME MANDATORY THAT
THEY- THAT THEY WEAR THE
REFLECTIVE GEAR. HI THANK YOU
I'M SORRY GO AHEAD. I'M DONE-
OKAY THANK YOU AS WELL CORRECT
THIS OTHER OTHERS IN SUPPORT
NAME AFFILIATION- AND POSITION
IN THE GALLERY BY THE WAY
WELCOME TO OUR GUESTS IN THE
GALLERY WE'RE PLEASED TO HAVE
YOU HERE- ALL RIGHT. NO ONE IN
THE GALLERY WE SHOULD TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
NOT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. A
MATTER IF YOU QUEUE UP THOSE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF-
AB. EIGHT NINE SEVEN FOUR. I
WOULD ENTER IF I SELFISHLY
ACQUIRE. THANK YOU I WOULD LIKE
TO GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS IT'S
ONE THEN ZERO TO VOICE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE B. NINE SEVEN
FOUR. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP WE'RE JUST WAITING
FOR A LINE NUMBER ONE MOMENT.
MAN WHAT A LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE THAT'S
ONE TO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
JOSEPHINE SORRY AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AV SKIPPING. EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINE. THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE COULD UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT LET'S TURNED OPPOSITION I
SEE THERE'S NO PRINCIPAL
WITNESS AN OPPOSITION LISTED
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY SEEING
NONE ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING IT
NONE. ARE ON THE PHONE LINE.
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY CALLERS
ON THE PHONE LINE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
NINE SEVEN FOUR. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF A. B.
NINE SEVEN FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
MR SURE THERE'S NO ONE COMING
UP IN OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT I
SEE NO ONE IN OPPOSITION EXCUSE
ME STRIKE THAT. BACK TO THE
CHAMBER- IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS A CEASE AND HURTS
BERG'S MICROPHONES UP CENTERS
FOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS A BILL
I CAN RELATE TO. LET ME TELL
YOU THAT JUST BECAUSE I COME
FROM A DIFFERENT GENERATION BUT
I ALSO COME FROM. THE AUTHORS
DISTRICTS HANDS. AT A TIME WHEN
THE- VENTANA IS WAS A- QUESTION
AREA WE RODE HORSES THAT ARE
KEENLY STABLES OFF INTO THE
SUPPORT OVER THE BASIN AND NOW
IT'S A TARGET STORE SO I HOPE
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN TO THE
PORTION OF THE DISTRICT THAT
THE AUTHOR AND I SHARED
TOGETHER YEAH I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD IDEA AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AUTHOR IF
I COULD JOIN WITH HER AS A CO
AUTHOR PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR JOIN
OTHER ANYWAY SHE'LL HAVE ME I
WOULD APPRECIATE THESE
IMPORTANT- PUBLIC POLICY ISSUE
FOR CALIFORNIA AND FOR THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REPRESENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG WE
WILL KEEP YOU POSTED AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT WE RECEIVE ANY
BUTTER CHURNING BILLS ALL
RIGHT. SO NEXT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS SAID HERZBERG MOVES
THE BILL- CELL NUMBER REVERSED
YOU COULD CLOSE SURE FIRST
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
FOR WORKING- WITH ME ON THIS
SPELL I'D LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
HERTZBERG- AS HE MENTIONED WE
SHARE- THIS PART OF THE
DISTRICT AND OUR EQUESTRIAN
COMMUNITY. CAME TO ME WITH
THESE IDEAS AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK OUR CONSTITUENTS UP FOR
COMING FORWARD WITH THIS BILL
AND WE'VE MADE IT THIS FAR- AND
I'D LOVE TO HAVE SENATOR- OF
HERZBERG AS A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR AND JOINING ME ON THIS
EFFORT. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIVEAU
ALREADY THANK YOU- HAVING BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
MANAGE ACCOUNTS OF YOUR CALL
THE ROLL THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOOSE THREE OF
US WAIT A MOTION BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
AMBERG HI AM BERG I BORJAS.
SEVEN ZERO I DON'T I DID
AWESOME HI IT ALSO I GONZALEZ
HI WHEN SILAS I HURTS BERG ALL
RIGHT HURTS BURGER I JONES.
JONES I LAYERED. LAYERED I
STERN. WHITE HOUSE SKI MY
CASKET I MEAN- YEP EIGHT ZERO
SO FAR WITH MEMBERS MISSING.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU PUT THAT
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU NEXT UP
AS ANNOUNCED EARLIER WE'RE
GOING A BIT OUT OF ORDER NEXT
UP IS A B. ONE FOUR FIVE FIVE-
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER- WICKS.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU MR CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THE
WORK ON THIS BILL I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AT
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE EXTENDS THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
VICTIMS WHO WERE SEXUALLY
ASSAULTEDBY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TO TEN YEARS AFTER THE
DATE OF JUDGMENT IN A CRIMINAL
CASE. FOR THE CRIME OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT FOR TEN YEARS AFTER
JUDGMENT FOR DIFFERENT CRIME
WHEN THE ORIGINAL CHARGES
INCLUDE SEXUAL ASSAULT
ADDITIONALLY A. B. FOURTEEN
FIFTY FIVE WOULD REVIVE
OTHERWISE TIME BARRED CIVIL
CLAIMS AN EXEMPT THESE CLAIMS
FOR PRISON PRESENTATION
REQUIREMENTS IF THE ALLEGED
SEXUAL ASSAULT OCCURRED WHILE
THE OFFICER WAS EMPLOYED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. MEMBERS AS
BILL DIRECTLY ADDRESSES THE
INTIMIDATION BARRIERS TO
REPORTING VICTIMS FACE WHEN
THEY KNOW THEY'RE ATTACKERS CAN
PUNISH ARREST RETALIATE AGAINST
THEM FROM A POSITION OF POWER
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S LAW CENTER
CONSUMER JOURNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER AND NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IS. PAM
GLANDS ARE. ALREADY THANK YOU-
THIS CLEANSER ARE YOU AVAILABLE
ON THE PHONE. I AM ALL RIGHT
CLOSURES. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS PAMELA
CLAYTOR I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH
THE MANUAL LOG GROUP THE FIRM
THAT REPRESENTS SEVERAL BRAVE
SURVIVORS WHO'VE BEEN BRUTALLY
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. HAD A
SIMPLY NUMBER WICKS AND
URINALYSIS HAVE EXPLAINED
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THOSE WHO
ARE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO
SEE THEM IN OPEN COURT FOR
THOSE OFFICERS MAY VERY WELL
STILL BE ON DUTY FILTERING AN
AUTHORIZED TO DISCHARGE THEIR
SERVICE WEAPONS- EMPOWERED TO
ARREST THEIR VICTIMS. FOR THEIR
VICTIMS LOVED ONES STILL ABLE
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TO BRING TO
BEAR THE INTIMIDATING POWER
THAT FACILITATED THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT IN THE FIRST PLACE. NOT
JUST BAD POLICY FOR THOSE
ALREADY TRAUMATIZED AND
VICTIMIZED THOSE CAREFULLY
SELECTED BY THE ASSAILANTS
BECAUSE THEY'RE VULNERABLE. IT
IS BAD POLICY BECAUSE IT MEANS
THAT LAWSUITS THAT MIGHT
ALERTED HER DEPARTMENTS TO THE
EXISTENCE OF PROBLEM OFFICERS
ARE NEVER FILED WITH THE RESULT
BEING MORE OF A MORE VICTIMS.
ONE OF MY CLIENTS SHERRY IS THE
US NAVY VETERAN WHO WAS RAPED
BY OFFICER NO WINCHESTER
WINCHESTER WAS EMPLOYED BY
THREE DIFFERENT POLICE
DEPARTMENTS. BEFORE FINALLY
BEING APPREHENDED AND IS NOW
SERVING EIGHTY ONE YEARS TO
LIFE IN PRISON FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULT THE FOUR OF THE VICTIMS.
HE MADE THE CASE FOR THE SELL
FAR BETTER THAN I EVER COULD
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID WHEN SHE
TESTIFIED THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IN APRIL
QUOTE. OFFICER WINCHESTER FOUND
ME AT MY WORST AND HE KNEW IT
PREDATORS LIKE HIM USE THE
AUTHORITY OF THEIR BADGES THE
HUNDRED WOMEN LIKE ME. I WAS
VULNERABLE HOMELESS ALONE AND
LOSING MY BATTLE WITH
ADDICTION. THE OFFICER WAS ON
THE CLOCK RIGHT BY A PATROL
VEHICLE WITH HIS BADGE HIS GUN.
AND A FLASHLIGHT USED TO
INSPECT MY BODY AT THE
THREATENED TO ARREST ME FOR
MAKING ME FOLLOW HIM TO A DARK
AREA. WHERE HE RAPED ME OVER
AND OVER WHAT CAN I DO. CALL
THE POLICE. I WAS POWERLESS AND
QUOTE. ON BEHALF OF SHERRY AND
OTHER VICTIMS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU EMPOWER SURVIVORS
DESERVE THEIR DAY IN COURT
PLEASE VOTE YES ON. EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. ALL
RIGHT OTHERS SUPPORT OF SAYING
NO WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NO WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT OF A
B. ONE FOUR FIVE FIVE. IF YOU
WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE FOUR
FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN THAT'S ONE ONE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK. ONE
ONE FOURTEEN I CAN HEAR SOME
BACKGROUND NOISE YOU'RE FREE TO
SPEAK. OKAY BUT WE CAN HEAR YOU
NOW GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU THIS IS JENNIFER PARKS WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPELLS THANK YOU. AND ALEXA
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE THAT'S ONE THREE
FIVE ZERO ONE IS OPEN. NOT NOT
QUALITY CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND MISTER
CHAIR THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME AND SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT LET'S TURN THE
OPPOSITION I SEE NO WITNESSES
NO PRINCIPAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE
SAYING NONE SAYING NONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE LET'S TURN TO THE
PHONE LINE. MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE FOUR FIVE
FIVE. IF YOU LIKE TO MAKE YOUR
VOICE HEARD IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. ONE FOUR FIVE FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MR SURE THERE'S NO ONE COMING
UP IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT- LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE CHAMBER- CENTER LAYERED.
MOVED TO BELL SAID EARLIER MOST
OF BILL ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS SAYING NONE.
ALL RIGHT WELL BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED. ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS TO
CARE CLOSE TO SPEND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE NINE.
THANK YOU BETTER TO COUNSEL IF
YOU CALL THE ROLL THIS IS ABC
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WITH THE MOTION
AND WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
THEY'RE THE MOST STANDS D.
PASS. AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND THEN RE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AMBERG. HI AMBERG BY BURGESS.
ZERO FIVE ZERO I DID I SAW.
THAT I SAW I GONZALEZ HI WHEN
SILENCE I HURTS BERG. HERTZBERG
BY JONES. LAYERED HI LAYERED
ICE STERN. WHITE HOUSE SKI WHAT
CASKEY I WINNER. HE HAVE
SEVENTY ZERO SO FAR WITH
MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SAVING TRAVEL
SOMEONE MEMBER WICKS ALL RIGHT
NEXT- A. B. SEVEN FOUR SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SERVE ON THIS.
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF OUR DOES
WELCOME THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
FOUR SIX WHICH WILL CODIFY THE
ELIMINATION OF A MINIMUM
MARRIAGE REQUIREMENT INTO LAW
THAT APPLIES TO ALL COUPLES
SEED A STEPPARENT ADOPTION. AND
ENSURE THAT PARENTAGE LAWS
REFLECT AND FURTHER PROTECT ALL
FAMILIES IN OUR STATE
ADDITIONALLY IT WILL ELIMINATE
INCOME AND EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE EQUAL
ACCESS TO PARENTAGE
HISTORICALLY SAME SEX COUPLES
ARE MET WITH MORE OBSTACLES TO
BECOME ADOPTED PARENTS. THAN
THEIR HETEROSEXUAL COUNTERPARTS
ADOPTION HAS NOT BEEN EASY FOR
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY FOR MANY
DECADES THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN BANNED FROM
ADOPTING CHILDREN EITHER DUE TO
LEGAL BARRIERS DISCRIMINATION
OR MULTI LAYER PROCESS MANY GO
THROUGH TO HAVE CHILDREN. OUR
CURRENT LAWS ALLOW MANY
FAMILIES TO ENCOUNTER EXPLICIT-
COVERED DISCRIMINATION WHEN
ATTEMPTING TO FILE FOR ADOPTION
THIS PROCESS SHOULD NOT BE
CHALLENGING BUT RATHER
SEAMLESS. CALIFORNIA PROVIDES
MANY PROTECTIONS FOR NON
BIOLOGICAL PARENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN ADOPTED BUT MANY STATES DO
NOT. THIS IS WHY EXPEDIENCY IN
THE PROCESS IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL OUR LAWS DO NOT
PROHIBIT COURTS FROM USING
THEIR DISCRETION TO ADD A
MINIMUM MARRIAGE REQUIREMENT
COUNTY WIDE- BEFORE COUPLES CAN
SEE COULD STEP PARENT ADOPTION
AS WELL AS AN EDUCATION AND
INCOME REQUIREMENTS. THIS
MISALIGNMENT OF EXPLICIT
PROHIBITION HAS LED TO
CONFUSION AND AMBIGUITY IN
PRACTICE FAMILIES GOING THROUGH
THE STEPPARENT ADOPTION PROCESS
ALREADY ENCOUNTER A VERY
CONFUSING AND COMPLEX SYSTEM
WHAT STATE AND COUNTY POLICIES
THAT VERY ACROSS THE STATE. WE
MUST ENSURE THAT WE REMOVE
THESE BARRIERS AND HINDER
THOUGHT DO- HINDER AND THE
ADOPTION PROCESS. FOR ALL
FAMILIES ESPECIALLY LGBTQ PLUS
FAMILIES AND COUPLES WHO
EXPERIENCE PERVASIVE OBSTACLES
WITHIN THE PROCESS WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IS MY WIFE COURTNEY SAID ABOUT
THIS DOWNS AND GABRIEL
MALDONADO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR I
TRUE EVOLUTION. ALREADY THANK
YOU WELCOME MISS AROUND HIS
DOWNS IF YOU'RE ON THE PHONE
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD TIME TO
TESTIFY. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBER
MY NAME IS COURTNEY FOR CONTENT
DOWNS AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY SIX. OF THEM
BUT I GOT A CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF ADOPTING OUR
EIGHTEEN MONTH OLD TRIPLETS I
KNOW FIRST HAND THE CHALLENGES
THAT PARENTS FACE WHEN GOING
THROUGH THE ADOPTION PROCESS.
MY WIFE AND I WERE EAGER TO
EXPAND OUR FAMILY AFTER
MARRIAGE OUR TOPIC HERE HAD
LUCKILY TOOK US ALMOST TWO
YEARS FROM START TO BOTH OF OUR
CHILDREN BUT THAT IS NOT THE
CASE FOR ALL FAMILIES.DURING
MY ADOPTION PROCESS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY I TOOK AT
LEAST FIVE INDIVIDUALS WITHIN
THE FAMILY LAW DIVISION AND ALL
OF THEM HAD THE SAME FIRST.
FIRST QUESTION. FOR YOU AND
YOUR WIFE LEGALLY MARRIED AT
LEAST ONE YEAR PRIOR TO THE
CHILDREN FOR. BECAUSE IF YOU
WERE NOT YOU ARE NOT ELIGIBLE
TO ADOPT I WOULD ALSO QUESTION
ABOUT MY LEVEL OF EDUCATION AND
INCOME WELL I DIDN'T MIND
PROVIDING THAT INFORMATION. IN
MY OPINION THAT IS ANOTHER
LEVEL OF DISCRIMINATION ONE
LEVEL EDUCATION OR INCOME
SHOULD NOT DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT THEY SHOULD LEGALLY BE
RECOGNIZED BY THE PARENTS. ANY
OF YOU ARE PARENTS OR
CAREGIVERS YOU UNDERSTAND THE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT YOUR
CHILDREN ARE ALWAYS IN SAFE
HANDS AND SECURE. CAN YOU
IMAGINE HAVING TO ADOPT YOUR
OWN CHILDREN. WELL THAT'S A
REALITY IN LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY
SO WHY MAKE ADDITIONAL LEGAL
BARRIERS TO RESTRICT THAT BUT
BEING RECOGNIZED FOR SOMETHING
WE HAVE TO TRY SO HARD TO GET
INTO THE GAME WITH. OUR
PREGNANCY WAS NOT UNPLANNED OR
UNINTENDED WE'RE VERY
INTENTIONAL ABOUT OCCURRING IN
OUR FAMILY. IN CALIFORNIA ARE
FAMILY FULLY PROTECTED AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S EQUAL PARTS
MY WIFE BUT THAT IS NOT THE
CASE IN OTHER STATES AND
COUNTRIES. THAT IS WHY WE
DECIDED TO CONFIRM MY PARENTS
LIVED THROUGH THE LEGAL SYSTEM.
BY TOPPING EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY
SIX AND ELIMINATE THE LEGAL
BARRIER TO ADOPT A CHILD IT
PROVIDES A CLEAR DUE TO THE
COURT. AT LAST WEEK THE SAME
SEX COUPLES WANTING TO EXPAND
THEIR FAMILY AND IT DOESN'T PUT
A TIME STAMP ON ONE OF THE ONLY
TO FIGHT LIKE CHILDREN. I
RESPECTFULLY OPRY COULD PUT
YOURSELF IN MY SHOES AND MANY
IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT ARE
LIVING IN FEAR BECAUSE THEIR
CHILDREN DON'T HAVE TO LEGAL
PARENTS. PLEASE EQUALLY PROTECT
ALL OF OUR FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN BY CONTINUING TO
REDUCE BARRIERS AND ADOPT THEM.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
STARTING AT SEVEN. CORTEX THANK
MISTER ROGERS DOWN ARE MAULED.
YES GOOD EVENING STANDARD- MY
NAME CAPABLE AND I SERVE AS THE
FOUNDER AND OF THE- WE ARE
HEALTH HELPING NEW AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION THIRTY
LGBTQ COMMUNITY RIVERSIDE AND
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY. AND I
GREET YOU THIS EVENING WITH MY
FULL AND BE THE ADMIN SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY SIX NOT
ONLY AS AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
AT AN LGBT ADVOCATE BUT AS THE
GAME OUT OF COLOR MYSELF I
RECOGNIZE THE VITAL NECESSITY
THAT THIS LEGISLATION HAS BEEN
ADDRESSING THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS.
OF OUR NATION'S MOST VULNERABLE
OUR CHILDREN AND AS HE BEGAN AT
THE NATION TO EMBARK UPON THE
JOURNEY OF FULLY HALF OF THE
COUNTRY CHILDREN OUT OF POVERTY
TOOLS SUCH AS GUARDIANSHIP AND
FAMILY WILL BE AT THE FOREFRONT
OF THIS MISSION. AT LGBTQ YOUTH
ARE OFTEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY DISCRIMINATION AND
HEALTH DISPARITIES VIOLENT
EXTREME SOCIAL ISOLATION NOT
ONLY THAT SYMBOLIC MEETING BUT
THE LEGAL RIGHTS OF ADOPTION
WILL BE FUNDAMENTAL IF WE SPEAK
TO RESPOND TO BOTH THE LGBTQ
AND NON LGBTQ CHILDREN WHO ARE
LEFT. WITHOUT GUARDIANSHIP IN
AMERICA. DEFLATION I DON'T REP.
THE FAT IN JACK. FOR OLD.
PARENTS BUT ALSO WILL BE A
TRULY TO REFER TO THE MANY NEED
THE POVERTY HOMELESSNESS MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS AFFECTING
YOUTH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO REQUIRE
GUARDIANSHIP LOVING HUMAN
DIGNITY. AND I WOULD JUST CLOSE
ON A PERSONAL NOTE THAT WHILE I
BEGAN TO BE HAD- AN EXPERT
WITNESS- FROM A PROFESSIONAL
STANDPOINT I MADE THE DECISION
TO HEAR THAT I WANTED TO BECOME
A PARENT MYSELF. AND SO THIS IS
REALLY. A PERSONAL TOUCH FOR ME
AS WELL. AND SO I CAN'T BE IN
THIS LEGISLATION. THANK YOU MR
MANADO YOU ALL RIGHT- ANYONE
ELSE OF IN SUPPORT OF. ABC
SEVEN FOUR SIX I SEE NO ONE IN
THE GALLERY TO SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINE MODERATOR- IS THERE
ANYONETHE PHONE LINE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
SEVEN FOUR SIX NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION. IF
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. SEVEN FORTY SIX AM BUT
SURE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THAT'S ONE FOUR ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR THIS IS ALICE KESSLER
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA BRIDGE
STRONG SUPPORT AND WE THINK THE
AUTHOR AND THEN- SERVE ON
DISCOUNTS FOR SHARING THEIR
STORY. THANK YOU. I MISSED HERE
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME OKAY LET'S LET'S TURN
THE OPPOSITION I SEE NO
WITNESSES LISTED IN OPPOSITION
I SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE LET'S TURN THE PHONE
LINES ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES
IN OPPOSITION TO AB. SEVEN FOUR
SIX. IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB SEVEN FORTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE QUEUING UP IN OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVEN FORTY SIX ALL RIGHT
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBER SAID HERZBERG. CENTERS
FOR MOVES A BILL ANY. OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS SEEING NONE.
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF OUR DOES DO
YOU CARE TO CLOSE. COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I. VO ON
A. B. SEVEN FOUR SIX ALL RIGHT.
EXCELLENT CLOSE- MANAGING
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL. YES THIS IS A B. SEVEN
FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SAID RUN THIS WITH A MOTION BY
HER. SENATOR HERTZBERG. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS ON BERG I'M-
A BURGER I BARGES. ZERO HI. I
DID ALSO. HI THE DRESS SO I
GONZALEZ HYPHEN SELES I HURTS
BERG. PRINCE BURGER I'D JONES
HI. JONES I LAYERED HI. LAYERED
I STERN. WHITE HOUSE SKI.
WINNER. THAT'S SEVENTY ZERO SO
FAR WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WOULD BE ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX BY SOMEONE
WHICH I DO NOT SEE HIM
PRESIDENT BUT I DO SEE-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD SO- WHAT DO
WE DO THIS LET'S GO OUT OF
ORDER SOMEONE MEMBER WARD HAS
A. B- TWO ONE EIGHT ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY TWO- WITHOUT OBJECTION
LET'S GO FORWARD SEVEN MEMBER
WARD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ACCORDING TO A TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SURVEY OF
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS ONLY
11% OF THE RESPONDENTS REPORTED
THAT THEIR IDENTITY IDENTITY
DOCUMENTS MATCHED THE PREFERRED
NAME AND GENDER IDENTITY
EXISTING ACCURATE CONSISTENT
INFORMATION DOCUMENTS IS
ESSENTIAL TO BASIC SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC FUNCTIONING IN OUR
COUNTRY YET FOR MANY
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE OBTAINING
IDENTITY DOCUMENTS THAT MATCH
THEIR GENDER IS A MAJOR HURDLE
EIGHTY TWO ONE EIGHT SIMPLY
ALIGNS THE PROCESS FOR UPDATING
TRANSGENDER MERIT CERTIFICATES.
AND THE BIRTH CERTIFICATES OF
THE CHILDREN WITH THE PROCESS
ALREADY IN PLACE FOR UPDATING
THEIR OWN PERSPECTIVE TICKET
THIS GIVES INDIVIDUALS THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO OBTAIN
ACCURATE IDENTIFICATION
DOCUMENTS FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR CHILDREN PROTECTING YOUR
PRIVACY IN THEIR WELL BEING
WE'VE INCORPORATED AMENDMENTS
TO LAST YEAR'S PETER MESSAGE OF
S. B. SEVEN FORTY ONE AND ARE
WORKING WITH- CD P. H. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ANSWER THEIR
CONCERNS ARE PROPERLY
ADDRESSED. ON THE LINE WE HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WILL SPEAK
BRIEFLY KENNY MARTIN THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND YOUR
HUSBAND BUSH. FOUNDER OF ALL
FAMILY LEGAL. FOR THANK YOU
SOME. WARD TERRY MARTIN OR- I'M
MARI HUSBAND BUSH ARE OTHER
VIEW AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE.
YEAH THANK YOU CHAIRING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS TAMMY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA BUT THE SPONSOR OF
AB Q. ONE EIGHT THIS IS A BILL
THAT IS NOT ONLY ABOUT ACCURATE
VITAL RECORDS BUT ALSO ABOUT
AUTHENTIC LIVING AND ABOUT
PROVIDING THE HUMAN EXPERIENCE
WITH DIGNITY SO I'LL BE BRIEF
IN A MOMENT MY- COLDNESS AND
HERE I WILL EXPLAIN THE VERY
REAL IMPACT THE PROPOSAL WILL
HAVE ON PEOPLE'S LIVES. AND THE
IMPACT OF BORNE OUT BY THE DATA
AS WELL AS THE AUTHORS MENTION
THE SMALL FRACTION OF
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE HAVE THEIR
CORRECT NAME AND GENDER LISTED
ON ALL OF THEIR DENTITY
DOCUMENTS AND OVER ONE THIRD OF
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
FOR EXAMPLE ASSAULTED ASKED TO
LEAVE OR OTHERWISE HARM SIMPLY
FOR PRESENTING AN IDENTITY
DOCUMENT. THAT HAS A NAME OR
GENDER ON IT NOT MATCH THEIR
GENDER PRESENTATION SO. MORE
WORK TO DO AND SO AND OTHER
IMPORTANT FACTORS IT FOLLOWS IN
THE FOOTSTEPS OF THE GENDER
RECOGNITION ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN BY IT PRETENDS HOW
MANY ACCIDENTS. AMONG OTHER
LIVES THAT LAY THE FOUNDATION
FOR ACCURATE AND AFFIRMING
IDENTITY DOCUMENTS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE VERY GRATEFUL
TO A FAMILY MEMBER BOARD
COMPRISING AHEAD ON THIS ISSUE
AND RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY AS WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU MISS MARTIN-
AMARI HAASAN BUSH. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR ME HERE.
MY NAME IS AMIR A BUSH IRON SO
A LOT FIRM ANGELES. THE FOCUSES
ON LGBT INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES- THAT. I THANK. KLEIN
OBTAIN LEGAL NAME AND GENDER
CHANGES HELP WITH THAT FIVE AND
HALF YEARS WORKING FOR THE- OF.
AN LGBT RESEARCH CENTER YOU
KELLY BLOCK. JOCHEM PROVIDED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO BUILD A
MONOLOGUE THAT IMPACTED THE
LGBT COMMUNITY. SUFFERING AND
YET THE BILL I WORK FOR THE
CLIENT WITH GOING TO AN
AMICABLE DIVORCE SHOULD YOU
DECIDE TO TAKE BACK HER MAIDEN
NAME. AND BOTH SHE AND HER
HUSBAND AGREE TYPE MADE THEIR
CHILDREN'S LAST NAMES AS A
RESULT. HOWEVER WHEN SHE ASKED
IF SHE COULD MODIFY THE OLDER
CHILD BIRTH CERTIFICATE TO
REFLECT HER HUSBAND'S GENDER.
TRANSITION TO MALE BETWEEN. THE
BIRTH OF THEIR FIRST AND SECOND
CHILD. ALL I COULD TELL THERE
WERE THAT IT WOULD COST MORE
MONEY AND I COULD GUARANTEE
OUTCOME. PICTURE NOT TO MAKE
THAT AT ALL AND HE IS STILL
LISTED AS THE CHILD'S MOTHER ON
THE BIRTH CERTIFICATE. I
COMPLETED A NAME AND GENDER
CHANGE FOR ANOTHER CLIENT ABOUT
A YEAR AGO SHE RECEIVED HER
COURT ORDER NAME AND GENDER
CHANGE EIGHT WEEKS AFTER WE
FILED A PETITION WITH THE
COURT. BUT IT TOOK A LEGAL
MOTION THE COURT HEARING IN
EIGHT MONTHS OF ARGUING WITH
VITAL RECORDS TO AMEND HER
MARRIAGE CERTIFICATE. AT
SIXTEEN AND ON BEHALF OF MY
CLIENT BUT THE AST MAJORITY OF
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE DO NOT HAVE
THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO HIRE
PRIVATE COUNSEL. TO COMPLETE
THEIR NAME AND GENDER CHANGE
PAPERWORK AND I HONESTLY DON'T
THINK THAT OUR MARRIAGE
CERTIFICATE AND THEN THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN COMPLETE WITHOUT THE
OBSTACLE LAWYER. FRANKLY I
WASN'T EVEN SURE WHAT I COULD
DO IT AND I'M NOT SURE THAT
EVERYBODY WILL GET THE SAME
OUTCOME. SH IN THE LAST YEAR
WE'VE COME TO APPRECIATE HOW
VITAL ACCESS. TO HOSPITALS AND
VISITING OUR SICK LOVED ONES
AS- NO ONE WANTS TO BE THE
NIGHT TIME WITH THEIR CHILD OR
SPOUSE WHENEVER AN EMERGENCY IN
ADDING THE EXTRA COMPLICATION
AND- A FUNNY LOOKING BIRTH
CERTIFICATE OR MARRIAGE
CERTIFICATE WITH AMENDMENTS IN
TWO PAGES. COULD LEAD TO
CONFUSION ABOUT AND
DISCRIMINATION AT WORST. LITTLE
WOULD REDUCE AT LEAST ONE
BARRIER BY ALLOWING SUCH
DOCUMENTATION TO ACCURATELY
REFLECT TRANSGENDERS PEOPLE'S
NAMES. AND GENDERS WITHOUT OUT
OF CONFUSION. BUT TO BE ABLE
TO. THEIR LEGAL. AND GENDER
EQUITY PROBABLY ON ALL OF THE-
ADMINISTER. DOCKING NOT. PAPER
CERTIFICATE. BILL TO DO JUST
THAT. THANK YOU MRS BUSH
EXACTLY TWO MINUTES- ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT I SEE NO ONE
IN THE GALLERY NO IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- ON THE PHONE LINE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. TWO ONE EIGHT
PLEASE QUEUE UP AT THIS MOMENT
MODERATED WITH ANYONE ON THE
LINE. IN SUPPORT. YES IF YOU'D
LIKE TO QUEUE UP IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. TWO ONE EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE WILL GO WITH LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO THAT'S ONE FIVE TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRIN MEMBERS CALLS WORSE THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION CAN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND WE DO HAVE
TWO MORE THAT ARE JUST QUEUED
UP PLEASE ALLOW A MOMENT TO
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBER. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN THAT'S ONE ONE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JOHN CLARK
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND JUST ONE MORE MOMENT PLEASE
FOR THE FINAL ONE. WHAT A LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
THAT'S ONE OF FOUR ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CAROLINA APPEARED
ON BEHALF OF CAROL ACTION. IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SURE THERE'S NO ONE ELSE SECURE
AT THIS TIME ALREADY THANK YOU
LET'S TURN THE OPPOSITION I SEE
NO ONE IN THE GALLERY NO IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION I NOTE
THAT THERE SEEMS TO BE NO- NO
ONE WISH AND TESTIFY IN
PRINCIPLE OPPOSITION. ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WE SHOULD
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
ONE EIGHT. IF YOU ARE ON THE
PHONE LINES AND WISH TO VOICE
OPPOSITION TO A. B. TWO ONE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE CARING AND UP
IN OPPOSITION OF A. B. TWO ONE
EIGHT AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT.
BRING IT BACK TO THE FLOOR-
CENTER LAYERED AND MOVED THE
BILL EARLIER MOVES THE BILL ANY
OTHER. COMMENTS QUESTIONS
SEEING NONE- I'M SORRY SENATOR
GONZALEZ THANK YOU- MISTER
CHAIR I WAS GOING TO MOVE THE
BILL BUT SENATOR LAYERED BEAT
ME TO IT BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU- SO MUCH FOR. A TO
THE OTHER FOR BRINGING THIS FOR
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
DIGNITY OF ALL- PART OF OUR
LGBTQ COMMUNITY MEMBERS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SANTA GOOD
SOLACE ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE
SAYING NO ONE ELSE- WHICH COULD
CLOSE FAMILY MEMBER WARD THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. MAN CHIEF
COUNSEL TO CALL THE ROLL THIS
IS A B. TWO ONE EIGHT BY A
FAMILY MEMBER WARD WHEN THE
MOTION BY. SENATOR LAYERED THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH YEAH AMBERG HI. AMBERG
BY BURGESS TO WINNIE. ZERO
FOUR. FOUR JUST NOT VOTING. AT
ALL HI I'LL BE AT ALL I DID I
SO. THE ADDRESS SO I CAN TELL
THIS. ONE SO THIS I HURTS BERG.
HURTS BERG HI JONES NO. JONES
NO LAYERED ON. LAYERED I STERN.
WHITE HOUSE SKI. WINNER SO FAR
YOU HAVE SIX TO ONE WITH
MEMBERS MISSING. AUTHORITIES
THANK YOU- I'M GOING TO TURN
THE GAVEL OVER TO SENATOR
BORJAS. WELL IT'S ON CALL. IF I
COULD TURN THE GAVEL MOTOR
CENTER BOARD JUST- TEMPORARILY.
AND-
ALL RIGHT FOLKS. OUR
FEARLESS LEADER IS OFTEN IN THE
COMMITTEE AND I AM FILLING IN
IN HIS STEAD. DO WE HAVE A
FAMILY MEMBER- CHILD PRESENT
THERE WE GO. ALL RIGHT WELCOME
IS A MEMBER CHOKING PLEASE
PRESENT D. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND MISS SENATORS AT
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX WOULD BRING
HEALTH INFORMATION COLLECTED BY
DIGITAL HEALTH PRODUCTS TO BE
UNDER THE PROTECTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL PRIVACY
LAW THE C. M. I. A. DIGITAL
HEALTH PRODUCTS ARE GIVING
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS NEW WAYS
TO GET USEFUL AND ACCURATE
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
PATIENTS. FOR EXAMPLE A DIGITAL
AND MOBILE CONNECTED INHALER
CAN DETECT WHEN THE DEVICES
USED TO MEASURE THE STRENGTH OF
THE USERS IN ELEVATION AND
TRANSMIT THIS INFORMATION TO
THE USERS DR. ALSO SEVERAL
FORMS OF DIGITAL PILLS ARE
ALREADY IN USE THESE PILLS CAN
RECORD THE TIME AND QUANTITY OF
DRUGS TAKEN ONCE TEMPERATURE
ACTIVITY LEVEL AND HEART RATE.
ALL OF THIS INFORMATION CAN BE
HIGHLY SENSITIVE AND WOULD
UNDER OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES BE
PROTECTED UNDER THE C. M. I. A.
AND HIPAA. HOWEVER IN ORDER FOR
THIS KIND OF DATA TO BE
CONSIDERED MEDICAL INFORMATION
IT NORMALLY NEEDS TO BE
GENERATED BY A HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER. INFORMATION COLLECTED
AT THE PATIENT LEVEL AND
OUTSIDE OF A MEDICAL FACILITY
WILL NOT NECESSARILY BE CAPTURE
UNDER MEDICAL PRIVACY LAWS AT
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX WILL BRING
THESE TECHNOLOGIES AND THE
INFORMATION THEY COLLECT UNDER
C. M. I. A. BY CONSIDERING ANY
BUSINESS THAT OFFERS SUCH AN
APP. OR DEVICE TO A CONSUMER TO
BE A PROVIDER OF HEALTH CARE
WITH RESPECT TO THAT APPLE
DEVICE THIS WILL ENSURE THAT
SENSITIVE. HEALTH DATA IS
TREATED WITH THE SAME CARE AS
STATED THAT IS GENERATED IN THE
TRADITIONAL MEDICAL SETTING AND
PROHIBIT THAT INFORMATION FROM
BEING SHARED. WITHOUT THE
PATIENT'S WRITTEN CONSENT. WELL
TODAY I HAVE A MARINA MAHER ON
BEHALF OF CONSUMER REPORTS-
READY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THAT WE GOT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ADULTS.
THANK YOU SAM A MEMBER- NOW
MOVING ON TO ANYONE WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AS THE
AUTHOR INDICATED WE HAVE A
MARINE MAHONEY ON THE LINE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT- SHE
AVAILABLE. YEAH HOLY TERROR
NUMBERS OF THE- THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
MY NAME IS MARIE MAHONEY I'M A
SENIOR POLICY ANALYST AT
CONSUMER REPORTS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT A B. FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX BECAUSE IT WOULD EXTEND
EXISTING STRONG HEALTH PRIVACY
LAW THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF
MEDICAL INFORMATION ACT THE
CENTER OF HEALTH INFORMATION
GENERATED BY NEW FORMS. OF
HEALTH TECHNOLOGY. STRONG
PROTECTIONS OVER THIS
INFORMATION IS ESSENTIAL FOR
EXAMPLE CONSUMER REPORTS
TESTING. THIS ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH APPS SHARE INFORMATION
ABOUT YOU WITH TECH COMPANIES
THE TRACTOR BEHAVIOR ACROSS
OTHER APPS. THAT INFORMATION
COULDBE COMBINED WITH OTHER
DATA USED TO TARGET ADS TO YOU.
BASED ON INFORMATION ABOUT YOUR
HEALTH STATUS DOWN THE ROAD IT
COULD BE OBTAINED BY OTHER
THIRD PARTIES AND USED TO MAKE
IMPORTANT DECISIONS ABOUT YOU.
CONSUMERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
REACH OUT FOR HELP WITHOUT
WORRYING ABOUT HOW THAT DATA
MIGHT BE SHARED OR MISUSED. IN
CALIFORNIA PATIENT PRIVACY IS
PROTECTED BY THE CIA AND HIPAA
HOWEVER THESE TWO ARE THE ONLY
PROTECT SENSITIVE HEALTH
INFORMATION IS GENERATED BY
CERTAIN. ENTITIES THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
WOULD APPLY TO. THE DATA THAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING TODAY BUT THE
LAW IS NOT AS STRONG. FOR
EXAMPLE THE CITY PA ALLOWS
CONSUMERS TO STOP THE SELL
THEIR INFORMATION BUT SEE MY
HEY BY THE FALL PROHIBITS MOST
CASES SHOWING AT ALL. THINKING
THEY WERE PROCESSING IT FROM
THE CONSUMERS OFTEN EXPERIENCE
DIFFICULTY OPTING OUT OF THE
SALE OF THEIR INFORMATION UNDER
THE CCPA. SENSITIVE MEDICAL
INFORMATION SHOULDN'T BE
GOVERNED BY WEAKER SET OF LAWS
JUST BECAUSE IT'S COLLECTED BY
AN ONLINE SERVICE. OTHER NEW
TECHNOLOGY. MAYBE FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX WHAT ADDRESS HERE'S
GAPS IN PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
OVER CONSUMERS SENSE OF HEALTH
DATA WE URGE. YOU TO ADVANCE A
STYLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOT
SPEAK WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN THE SENATE GALLERY. I DO NOT
SEE ANY FOLKS HERE- LET'S MOVE
OVER- TO ROOM ONE TWELVE OR-
FORTY TWO OR. THREE OKAY NOT
OVER THERE AS WELL ALL RIGHT-
ANY WITNESS ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISHES TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE B. FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX ONE
TWELVE. THAT'S WERE LOOKING AT
BEFORE SAYING NONE ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE ON TO A SUPPORT
WITNESSES WILL TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR. PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX. AND WE CAN BEGIN.
ANY CALLS IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR COULD LIKE TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AT THIS TIME.
AND WE WILL GOWITH LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN THAT'S
ONE ONE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO JENNIFER PROPAGANDA WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION F
SOCIAL WORKERS. CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER. PART OF THE CELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU N.
MODERATOR HI HOW MANY CALLS WE
HAVE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE.
FATHERS ONE MORE IN THE QUEUE
WE'LL GO TO A FAMILY PLAN ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE. NINE ONE
FOUR ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
CAROLINA FOOD- BEHALF OF ACLU
CONTACTED IN SUPPORT. OR LET'S
LET'S GIVE A FINAL SHOT OUT TO
THE FOLKS IN THE QUEUE WISHING
TO- BE IN SUPPORT. MODERATORS
HEARING NONE. THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
OKAY I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION- THERE DOESN'T
APPEAR TO BE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- BUT THERE IS-
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. LET'S
MOVE TWENTY WITNESSES HERE IN
THE SENATE GALLERY. SIR HI DON
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF INTERNET
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
SENATE GALLERY SEEING NONE. ARE
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WE SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX. SEEING A NINE ALL
RIGHT- LET'S MOVE ON OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WAYNE TESTIFIED VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR IF YOU
PLEASE BROUGHT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION AND GIVE ME
ACCOUNT OF THOSE WHO WERE IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE. CERTAINLY
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
VOICE OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU
PROVIDE YOUR LINE NUMBER. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE SUPPORT IN THE
QUEUE IN OPPOSITION. WE'LL
START WITH ONE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE THAT'S
ONE FIVE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS CHRIS QUICKLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
AND OXYGEN GET AT FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU GOT A LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIX ONE ZERO SIX OR
ONE IS OPEN. THE NEW CHAIR
MEMBERS CAN MAKE SURE ABOUT THE
TICKET IN THIS PARTICULAR
POSITION AT. FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX. AND PLEASE ALLOW A MOMENT
FOR SYSTEM TO CATCH UP. LAWYERS
USE WILL GROW LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THAT'S ONE
FIVE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JUSTIN
HIGHER WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL AT
THE TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT THAT'S
ONE FIVE H. R. ONE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU AFTER THE NUMBERS
CHANGE HELP ON BEHALF OF THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN RESPECT WHAT
POSITION ABOUT THANK YOU. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN THAT'S
ONE THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CLOTURE MEMBERS MANAGE
WHAT MUHAMMAD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
I DO HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. WILL
GO I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX THAT'S ONE FIVE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE SHARE
MEMBERS JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE
HAPPY DANCE MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ADMIT ALSO OPPOSED.
AND WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE OF
OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU MODERATOR
THANK YOU CENTER BOARD JUST FOR
YOUR EXCELLENT CHAIRMANSHIP-
ALL RIGHT. NO ONE ELSE ON THE
PHONE SUPPORT OPPOSITION RETURN
HERE TO THE FLOOR- QUESTIONS
SENATOR RUSSELL. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. THE QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR YES- I'M TRYING TO
NARROW DOWN HERE WHEN I THINK
OF ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL
ISSUES AND AS I UNDERSTAND IT
AND YOU CAN CORRECT ME- THAT
THERE IS A CODE ISSUE OF USING
INFORMATION WITHOUT THE USERS
CONSENT- BUT THEN THERE'S ALSO.
DRAWING THE LINE BETWEEN WHAT'S
CONSIDERED CONSUMER INFORMATION
AND PRIVATE MEDICAL
INFORMATION- I TOTALLY AGREE
THAT SHARING WITHOUT THE USERS
CONSENT IS A REALLY BIG PROBLEM
AND WE'VE COME ACROSS THIS OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN- NOT
HAVING THE USER'S PERMISSION.
ON THE OTHER ISSUE OF DRAWING
THE LINE IT IT SEEMS TO ME AND
THIS IS WHERE I'D APPRECIATE
SOME GUIDANCE FROM THE AUTHOR
IT SEEMS TO ME THERE IS A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN YOU KNOW A
FIT BIT- OR CERTAIN MONITORS
THAT WE MIGHT WEAR. AND THE-
MUCH MORE- EXTENSIVE INSTRUCTOR
MEDICAL PRIVACY LAWS LIKE MY
MEDICAL RECORD WOULD BE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT FROM UP
FITBIT SO I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES AT HAND
IS THERE ANY WAY TO AMEND TO
ADDRESS THOSE ARE THOSE
CONCERNS BECAUSE I DO THINK IT
MIGHT BE EXTENDING THAT SO MUCH
TO. CONSIDER ALL OF THESE
PRODUCTS AS UNDER THE OF MORE
STRICTER C. M. I. A. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A SENATOR
FOR YOUR QUESTION- WITH RESPECT
TO THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LET'S
SAY CONSUMER INFORMATION VERSUS
MEDICAL INFORMATION. I THINK
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO KIND A TO TRY TO
ADDRESS IN THIS BILL IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT MEDICAL INFORMATION
IS PROTECTED. ALL WHETHER IT IS
BEING GENERATED AND A DOCTOR'S
OFFICE OR COLLECTED BY WAY OF A
DEVICE OR APPLICATION. NOW
CURRENT LAW ALREADY PROVIDES
THAT BUSINESSES ATTACKED OUR
MANUFACTURER PRODUCED ALL
SOFTWARE OR HARDWARE THAT
COLLECTS MEDICAL INFORMATION TO
BE SUBJECT OF UNDER CLIA SO IN
OTHER WORDS LET'S SEE A DOCTOR-
HOUSE AN APPLICATION THAT
WOULD. COLLECT INFORMATION
PATIENT INFORMATION HEART RATES
OR OTHERWISE THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED MEDICAL INFORMATION
THAT IS UNDER CLIA. ON THE
OTHER HAND IF SOMEBODY USES- AN
APPLICATION FOR SUBMISSION
FITBIT SO IF SOMEBODY USES THE
FITBIT TO START RECORDING
INFORMATION SUCH AS HEART RATE
OR PULSE RATE OR OTHER VERY
SIMILAR- INFORMATION FOR EATING
REGULAR SLEEPING RATE OR
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE. THAT
INFORMATION IS NOT COVERED
UNDER CLIA BECAUSE SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT IT IS
BEING COLLECTED OUTSIDE OF THE
CONFINES OF THE MEDICAL OFFICE
OR NOT BEING IN POSSESSION OF
THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE SAME SET OF
INFORMATION BOTH HEART RATE.
HEART RATE AND SLEEPING
PATTERNS OF BREATHING RATE IN
BOTH SCENARIOS BUT IN ONE
SCENARIO IT IS COVERED UNDER
CMI ON THE OTHER HAND IT IS NOT
COVER IF THE INFORMATION IS
BEING COLLECTED BY THE DEVICE
OR THE APPLICATION. SO WE TRY
TO CLOSE THAT GAP. SO DOT IS
THE IS THE- YOU KNOW THAT IS
THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GET OUT SO IT
WOULD TALK ABOUT THE SAME
INFORMATION THE SAME HEALTH
INFORMATION. YOU KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT HEART RATE BREATHING RATE
STRESS LEVEL SLEEPING PATTERNS
BLOOD SUGAR LEVEL AND ALL THAT
INFORMATION IS A SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED MEDICAL INFORMATION
BECAUSE IT IS CONSIDERED
MEDICAL INFORMATION. IT IS
GENERATED LET'S SAY IN A
DOCTOR'S OFFICE. SO WE TRY TO
CLOSE THAT GAP. FOR THE MAKE
SURE THERE IS CONSISTENCY ARE
YOU KNOW FOR INFORMATION THA'S
BEING GENERATED NOW. LET ME
JUST ALSO ADD THAT. I WE
TARGETING TWO PARTICULAR
SCENARIOS NUMBER ONE ODD
SCENARIO WITH A SITUATION WHERE
THE INFORMATION IS BEING
COLLECTED BY THAT'S A DIVISIVE
FITBIT. AND THEN TRANSMITTED TO
ANOTHER PERSON FOR USE LET'S
SEE A DOCTOR. NOW THAT
INFORMATION IS NOT COVER UNDER
CLIA. NOW THE OTHER SCENARIO IS
THAT LET'S SAY IF A COP AND-
APPLICATION COLLECTS A LOT OF
INFORMATION FROM YOU ME AND
EVERYBODY. ELSE AND THREE.
AGGREGATE DOT DATA FOR EXAMPLE
CREATE A DATABASE THAT CONTAINS
EVERYBODY'S. INFORMATION LIKE
HEART RATE OR BREATHING RATE
AND THAT INFORMATION CAN BE
SOLD. TO SOMEBODY ELSE WITHOUT
OUR KNOWLEDGE OR CONSENT. AND
THAT'S THE SECOND SCENARIO THAT
WE WANT TO DRESS AND THAT'S
HAPPENING ALL ALREADY LET ME
SEE IF I COULD SHARE A COUPLE
OF EXAMPLES WITH YOU. ACCORDING
TO A RECENT STUDY. OUR THE
SURVEY LIKE THIRTY SIX TOP RANK
APPLICATION FOR DEPRESSION AND
SMOKING CESSATION. PROGRAMS OF
THE THIRTY SIX TWENTY NINE OF
THEM TRANSMITTED TO DATA TO
SERVICES PROVIDED BY FACEBOOK
OR GOOGLE. WITHOUT US KNOWING
IT SO THEY ALREADY AGGREGATED
THE DATA AND THEN DECIDED TO
KIND OF SHARE THAT INFORMATION
WITH SOMEBODY ELSE WITHOUT US
KNOWING T. THE OTHER SITUATION
IS OUT. THERE WAS AN INSURER.
DOT ACTUALLY OBTAINED THREE
MILLION PEOPLES INFORMATION
MEDICAL INFORMATION FROM AN
AGGREGATOR. SUIT SO THIS IS
HAPPENING YOU KNOW ALREADY SO
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW- IN THE FUTURE SO THIS IS
HAPPENING THE DATA IS BEING
SHARED WITH OTHER PEOPLE
WITHOUT US KNOWING IT SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THE
DATA IS BEING COLLECTED BY A
DEVICE BY FIFTY. FOUR BY AN
APPLICATION. SO THAT'S THE
THAT'S IF I. MAY MISTER CHAIR
JUST A FOLLOW UP QUESTION. IS I
FEEL. MUCH STRONGER AND IT'S
MUCH CLEARER- WHEN A COMPANY IS
SHARING MY INFORMATION WHETHER
IT'S MY PERSONAL I MEAN WHETHER
IT'S ON. MY INDIVIDUAL
INFORMATION OR N THE AGGREGATE
WITH OTHERS IN A CERTAIN AREA
WHATEVER- SHARING THAT WITHOUT
OUR CONSENT AND PERMISSION I
FEEL. VERY UNCLEAR AND STRONGLY
ABOUT- THE OTHER ONE IS IT'S
REALLY HARD TO. DISTINGUISH
AND- PUT CONSUMER INFORMATION.
INTO THE PRIVATE MEDICAL ALL
INFORMATION AND I'M NOT SURE
HOW TO RESOLVE THAT. BUT IT
THEY JUST SEEMS LIKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A DECEPTIVE
BABY I'M HUNG UP ON THE OLD
FASHION. YOU KNOW OLD SCHOOL
WAY YOU GO TO THE DOCTOR
ANYTHING THAT'S CONNECTED TO
YOUR DOCTOR. IT JUST SEEMS
THAT'S VERY PRIVATE- NEEDS. THE
MOST- THE HIGHEST STANDARDS OF
PRIVACY. THE OTHER SEEMS TO BE
MUCH MORE- NEBULOUS AND GREAT
BIG AS FAR AS WHETHER OR NOT I
WOULD CONSIDER THAT- MY PRIVATE
MEDICAL INFORMATION IF I COULD
FOLLOW UP- RESEARCHER ON THAT
POINT- I THINK YOU HAVE A VERY
GOOD OPS OBSERVATION ABOUT THE
SITUATION AND THE REASON FOR
THAT IS BECAUSE OF THE ADVANCES
IN TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE
TECHNOLOGY IS GROWING SO
RAPIDLY AND WE COULD START
MEASURING A COLLECTING DATA
ABOUT. SOMEBODY'S HEALTH. VERY
READILY AND EASILY SO YOU COULD
ACTUALLY GET IN A FREE APP ON
THE WEBSITE YOU CAN DOWNLOAD IT
AND SEE WHICH STARTS COLLECTING
INFORMATION. WITHOUT YOU KNOW
OKAY GETTING US OUT- YOU KNOW
IT IS A CONCERN. ABOUT CONSENT
SUSAN DOT DOT IS THAT THE
REASON YOU KNOW IT'S
TECHNOLOGY. BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO CATCH UP WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY OF THE LAW IS THAT
IS SO- TECHNOLOGIES. RAPIDLY
GROWING AND WE TRY TO MOVE THE
LAWYER THAT TRYING TO PLAY
CATCH UP TO SO THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITHIN. THIS
PARTICULAR CONTEXT. ALL RIGHT
THE ROSSES OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS SAYING NO OTHER
MICROPHONES- THEIR MOTION. SIR
WHAT COUNTS THE MOST THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT SO YOUR CHARITY CARE
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO
YOU DISABLES. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU GREAT CLOSE ALL RIGHT SO-
MADAM TO CANCER YOU CALL THE
CALL ROLL PLEASE OKAY YES THIS
IS THE A. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER CHILD THE
MOTION IS BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE KEEP THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH- BURKE
HI. AMBER GUY BURGESS NO
BORDERS NO COVERAGE AT ALL. DID
I SO I DRESS SO I CONSIDER THIS
MONTH UNLESS I HURTS BERG.
PARTS BERG HI JONES. JONES NO
LAYERED FIVE LAYERED HI STERN.
MY CASKEY HARD WAY CASKEY BY
WINNER. YOU HAVE SIXTY TWO SO
FAR WITH US SOME MEMBERS ABSENT
ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT BILL
AND CALL RIGHT NEXT THREE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU'S BILL AB
TWO FOUR FIVE- AND WELCOME TO
OUR GUESTS I THINK THIS IS THE
YOUNGEST GUESTS THAT WE'VE HAD
IN OUR GALLERY SINCE MARCH OF
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY SO WE'RE
GLAD TO SEE YOU BOTH HERE. N.
I. C. APPRECIATE THE
RECOGNITION ALSO. ALL RIGHT
SEVEN MEMBER CHIP THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT A B. TWO FORTY FIVE
TRANSGENDERED AND BINARY
STUDENTS FACE MANY BARRIERS AT
SCHOOL AND IN THE WORKPLACE IF
A STUDENT DOESN'T HAVE AN
UPDATED DIPLOMA OR TRANSCRIPT
THEY CAN FACE CHALLENGES
APPLYING FOR GRADUATE SCHOOL OR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES. A
COLLEGE DIPLOMA IS A
REPRESENTATION OF YEARS OF HARD
WORK AND ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
WE ALL KNOW IT SHOULDN'T CAUSE
STRESS OR EMOTIONAL HARM BY
HAVING SOMEONE'S DEAD NAME ON
IT. THIS BILL DOES TWO THINGS
IT ALLOWS TRANS AND NON BINARY
STUDENTS AT PUBLIC COLLEGES. TO
HAVE THEIR CHOSEN NAME PRINTED
ON THEIR DIPLOMA WHEN THEY
GRADUATE. AND SECONDLY IT
CREATES A STANDARD PROCESS FOR
UPDATING STUDENT RECORDS OF
FORMER STUDENTS. SAID THAT
NAMES AND GENDERS ARE
ACCURATELY REFLECTED ON THESE
IMPORTANT RECORDS. THIS BUILDS
ON A LAW THAT WE PASSED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TO MAKE SURE
THAT FORMER. K. THROUGH TWELVE
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO UPDATE
THEIR STUDENT RECORDS
ACCORDINGLY. WE'VE HEARD FROM
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO FACE
SIMILAR CHARGES AND SO I NEED
TO EXTEND THIS POLICY. TO
PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AND WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO TURN OVER TO OUR MAIN
WITNESS. TAMMY MARTIN FROM A
QUALITY CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
TAMMY MARTIN AVAILABLE. I BODIE
CALIFORNIA I WOULD BE HERE
TODAY AS A CO SPONSOR OF EIGHTY
TWO FORTY FIVE WHICH WILL
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS AND
GRADUATES WHO PUT SO MUCH
EFFORT AND HARD WORK INTO THEIR
SCHOOL CAREER I WILL HAVE THEIR
RECORDS REFLECT THAT HARD WORK
AS WELL AS THEIR AUTHENTIC
SELVES AND OTHER PEOPLE I
EXPECT TAKE THE PRIVILEGE FOR
GRANTED BUT FOR TRANSGENDER AND
NON BINARY GRADUATE AN
INACCURATE ACADEMIC RECORD
OFTEN TRANSLATE INTO
DISCRIMINATION AND HARM WHEN
THEY FOR EXAMPLE PRESENT
TRANSCRIPTION THE JOB
APPLICATION PROCESS. WHICH
COMPOUNDS THE SOCIETAL BARRIERS
TO EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING THAT
LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE ALREADY FACE
FOR EXAMPLE EVEN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ROUGHLY ONE OUT OF
EVERY FOUR TRANSGENDER
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN DENIED A
JOB THAT THEY APPLIED FOR OR
BEEN FIRED OR DENIED PROMOTION
BECAUSE OF THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY OR EXPRESSION AND A
THIRD OF TRANS PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING. IN CALIFORNIA ARE
LIVING IN POVERTY OR HAVE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS SO
THERE IS A REAL AND PRACTICAL
OLD ACADEMIC RECORDS PLAY IN
ALLEVIATING SOME OF THESE
DISPARITIES ESPECIALLY IN
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING FOR ME
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER GEO FOR
HELPING TO ENSURE THAT ACADEMIC
RECORDS ARE ACCURATE AND
AFFIRMING AS WELL AS SAFEGUARD
THE PRIVACY AND DIGNITY OF ALL
GRADUATE WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL AS WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISS MARTIN OF OTHERS IN
SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY ANYONE
IN THE GALLERY IN SUPPORT OF A.
B. TWO FOUR FIVE- SEEING NONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SINGLE ROOM
ONE TWELVE. ON THE PHONE LINE
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE IN FAVOR OF AB TWO FOUR
FIVE PLEASE GIVE US YOUR. NAME
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
HAMLIN JR AND- OF A TWO FIVE
PLEASE ONE ZERO AT THIS. AGAIN
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN FAVOR.
AND SURE AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
ABOUT FIVE IN OUR QUEUE ALL
RIGHT. I WILL START WITH A LINE
OF ONE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
INTEND WITH THE CAL STATE
INSTITUTION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT IN LINE ONE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT CAROLINA
APPEARED ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
COW ACTION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE LINE ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TYLER I YOU
ARE IN BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. BLIND ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU JENNIFER
POCKET THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SPORT THANK YOU.
LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JENNIFER
GONZALEZ CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE OFFICE OF LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR OR ANY KIND OF MARKET
BUT CAN THE GOVERNOR THEY PROB
CONFRONTED THE TWO FOR FIVE AND
RESPECTFULLY I FIGURE EITHER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ENSURE WE
DO HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. IT'LL
JUST BE A MOMENT. LINE ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS KIMBERLY WELL
AND I REPRESENT STUDENTS FROM
JOHN UP AND WE WON BECAUSE- OF
A. B. TWO FOUR FIVE. THANK YOU.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS
IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR
ALL RIGHT LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION I SEE NO
PRINCIPAL WITNESSES NO MAIN
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION NAMELY
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION NO ONE
MOVING THE MICROPHONE ROOM ONE
TWELVE I SEE NO ONE ALL RIGHT
LET'S TURN THE PHONE LINES.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP.
THOSE IF ANY IN OPPOSITION TO
AB. TWO FOUR FIVE. AND THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO FOUR FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
QUESTIONS BRING BACK THE
CHAMBER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CENTER MORICHES. AMERICA HAS A
VERY LIBERAL HISTORY WHEN IT
COMES TO- NAME CHANGES OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD- THE NAME
THAT YOU WERE GIVEN AT BIRTH IS
THE NAME THAT YOU HAVE IN
PERPETUITY. WITHOUT OPPORTUNITY
FOR LEGAL NAME CHANGE SO
AMERICA I THINK IS HAS A VERY
UNIQUE- TRADITION WITH ALL THE
LEGAL INSTRUMENTS THAT ALLOWS
SOMEONE TO CHANGE THEIR NAME.
MY CONCERN WITH THIS BILL I
THINK I UNDERSTAND THE
MOTIVATION FOR DOING IT IS- WHY
WOULDN'T YOU. WISH FOR PLEASE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION- TO. MAKE THESE
ACCOMMODATIONS AFTER A LEGAL
NAME CHANGE. IF I COULD POSE
THAT AND THEN FOLLOW UP THERE
AFTER THE STRUCTURE HI SALOON
OR CHIP SO- SO FIRST OF ALL ON
THE ONE HAND I THINK I HEARD
YOU SAY THAT- THAT THE NAMES
ARE CHANGED AROUND THE WORLD ON
A FREQUENT BASIS AND THAT IS
ENTIRELY TRUE. PART OF THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DRESS WITH THIS BILL IS THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME COLLEGES
THAT HAVE MADE MAKING RECORDS
ACCESSIBLE IN REVISING THEM
DIFFICULT NOT ALL BUT SOME AND
SO WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE THAT
MUCH MORE PREDICTABLE MUCH
EASIER- TO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
WHY DON'T WE ASK FOLKS TO GET A
LEGAL CHANGE- IT'S ACTUALLY
QUITE EXPENSIVE SO IT COSTS-
USUALLY OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS TO GET A
NAME CHANGE BORDER- AND IT
TAKES TIME TO USE THAT LEGAL
PROCESS AND- YOU KNOW FROM FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE I THINK.
REQUIRING A STUDENT TO PAY THAT
ADDITIONAL MONEY JUST TO BE
RECOGNIZED BY THE COLLEGE THAT
THEY WENT TO SCHOOL AS A PERSON
THAT THEY ACTUALLY ARE- IS A
BIT TO ASK- AND SO WE'RE HOPING
TO MAKE IT SIMPLE- AND- AND DO
WHAT WE DID A FEW YEARS AGO
WITH REGARDS TO K. TWELVE-
TRANSCRIPTS AND DIPLOMAS. THE
CARD AND I'M TRYING TO. I THINK
I UNDERSTAND THE RATIONALE
BEHIND IT I'M HAVING. I'M
HAVING TROUBLE FIGURING OUT HOW
MAYBE YOU CAN COMMENT FURTHER
ON WHAT PROTECTIONS WOULD BE IN
PLACE- TO AVOID FRAUD BECAUSE
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU HAVE IT SEEMS
AS IF YOU HAVE THIS TYPE OF
FLEXIBILITY. TO- TO HAVE NAMES
MOVE WITH MESSAGE FREQUENCY
POTENTIALLY THAT THERE COULD
BE- OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MISREPRESENTATION OR FRAUD CAN
YOU. GO INTO THAT A LITTLE BIT
OF UNIVERSITIES HAVE PROCEDURES
TO FOR SOMEONE TO GO AND SAY
WHO THEY ARE SO- TYPICALLY THEY
WOULD REQUIRE A SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER THEY WOULD REQUIRE
INFORMATION ABOUT AN ADDRESS
INFORMATION THAT TYPICALLY ONLY
THE GRADUATE WITH NO- AND SO
THAT'S ASKED BEFORE YOU CAN
CHANGE YOUR NAME FROM NAME
EIGHT TO NINETY. PARTS OF I'M
AN EMPLOYER. AND SO AND SO IS
APPLYING FOR THE JOB AND I'M
DOING A BACKGROUND CHECK. IN
THAT INDIVIDUAL HAS- HAS HAS
MODIFIED THEIR- IDENTIFIERS-
WHAT IS IT THE CHECK AND
BALANCE THAT WOULD OCCUR WHEN
THE NAME ON THE DIPLOMA. OR THE
RESUME CORRESPONDING TO THE
DIPLOMA IS DIFFERENT FROM THE
INITIAL SCHOOL RECORD OR WOULD
IT CHANGE THE INITIAL SCHOOL
RECORD AS WELL. WELLA PART OF
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS AREN'T OUTED IN THE
WORKPLACE SO IDEALLY THE
EMPLOYER DOESN'T KNOW THAT
SOMEONE HAD A NAME CHANGE THE
REAL ISSUE IS- WHAT IS THE NAME
ON THE DIPLOMA OR THE NAME OF
THE TRANSCRIPT THAT REFLECTS.
THE PERSON'S NAME TODAY AND SO
THE ISSUE AROUND FRAUD IS JUST
MAKING SURE THAT- THAT THAT
THAT GRADUATE THAT STUDENT. IS
ABLE TO- PREFER THEY ARE TO THE
UNIVERSITY THAT THEY ARE THE
STUDENT- THAT HAD A DIFFERENT
NAME SOME YEARS BACK- THAT NAME
GETS CHANGED THE TRANSCRIPT OF
THE DIPLOMA. REFLECTS THAT
INNOCENT TO THE EMPLOYER SO
THAT'S NOT TYPICALLY AN ISSUE
THAT- THAT THAT AN EMPLOYER
WOULD. WOULD HAVE TO GRAPPLE
WITH. OKAY ONCE AGAIN I THINK-
I THINK THERE ARE MECHANISMS IN
PLACE I UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE
WOULD WANT IF THEY HAVE CHOSEN
AN ANSWER RIGHT TO REPRESENT
THEMSELVES IN ANY FASHION THEY
SEE FIT BUT FROM A LEGAL
STANDPOINT- I THINK WE ALSO
HAVE TO HAVE SOME PROTECTIONS
FEDERAL BIT MORE SECURE AND MY
LAST IS WHAT IS THIS PERTAINING
ONLY TO. PUBLIC POST SECONDARY.
AND YES THIS AUTO WRITER THIS
BILL WOULD APPLY TO PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES HAVE YOU SEIZE THE
CS USING COMMUNITY COLLEGES. IN
THE PIVATE IS NOT. UNDER THIS
UMBRELLA THAT IS CORRECT CAN
YOU EXPLAIN WHY THAT THAT'S THE
CASE- DID. THAT IS THAT IS HOW
WE DRAFTED IT- WE WEREN'T. WE
AREN'T IMPOSING THIS ON PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS WERE ASKING THE
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS TO- TO STEP
UP AS WE DID WITH PUBLICATION
TWELVE SCHOOLS. ARE ALL IN WITH
THIS I HAD MY MIDDLE NAME IS
ALEXANDER AND- I ASKED FOR MY
DIPLOMA. JUST WITH MY FIRST AND
LAST NAME NOW WITH MY MIDDLE
NAME. AND NOBODY WOULD DO IT.
THEY INSISTED ON MAKING CERTAIN
THAT- THE DIPLOMA WAS AS IT WAS
SOME INSTITUTIONS WILL ALSO
ONLY ISSUE YOU ONE DIPLOMA. AND
ANYTHING THERE AFTER LET'S SAY
YOUR DAMAGES. ANYTHING AFTER
THAT THERE'S A BIG DISCLOSURE
ON THE BOTTOM OF THE DEPLOYMENT
THIS IS A REPRODUCTION OF THE
ONE THAT WAS ISSUED- YOU GOT
THE RESOLVE THAT NOW BUT YOU
MAY WANT TO BRING UP. OUR LOOK
INTO- WHETHER THESE PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS HAVE THOSE TYPES
OF POLICIES ARE IN THE ISSUANCE
OF THE REASSURANCE OF DIPLOMAS
THANK YOU AND I THINK WHAT I
WOULD SUGGEST IN RESPONSE TO
THAT I THINK THE IDEA THAT. YOU
CAN'T GET A DIPLOMA WITH THE
NAME THAT. THAT IS YOUR LEGAL
NAME THAT YOU WOULD WANT THAT
TO ME TRUCKS ARE SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS AND I
AGREE THAT THAT THAT THAT
POINT. IT IS RIGHT AND THAT'S
EXACTLY YOU KNOW I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT FOR VERTICALLY FOR
TRANSGENDER AND NON BINARY.
CONSTITUENTS THIS IS- AT A VERY
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE- THAT WE
OUGHT TO ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE UNIVERSITIES- THAT
WILL PRESENT THOSE TYPE OF
PLAYERS- COULD BE. INCREDIBLY
HARMFUL WHEN IT COMES TO THE
DISCRIMINATORY IMPACT THAT.
THESE INDIVIDUALS MAY FACE IN
THE WORKPLACE FROM PLAN TO
GRADUATE SCHOOL SO IT MAKES IT
THAT MUCH MORE ACUTE FOR US TO
ADDRESS THIS. THANK YOU. PARTY
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT- IS THERE A
MOTION. YES SENATOR DOLE'S
MOVES THE BILL- ALL RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO. IF US UNDER
BOARD HAS BROUGHT HIS DIPLOMA
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO STRIKE
ALEXANDER FROM HIS DIPLOMA IF
HE PRESENTED IT TO YOU I
ABSOLUTELY WOULD I ALSO THINK
THAT IF HE HAPPENS TO SPILL
SOME COFFEE ON THE DIPLOMA. HE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET ANOTHER
DIPLOMA THAT- REFLECTS IN PART
OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
TO STANDARDIZE THE FACT THAT.
SOME UNIVERSITIES DO A GOOD JOB
OF ALLOWING. RECORDS ACCESSIBLE
ALLOWING RECORDS TO BE REVIVED
WITH APPROPRIATE- GUARDS
AGAINST FRAUD AND I'M NOT AWARE
OF ANY CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE FRAUD
IS OCCURRED. IN THIS AREA- BUT
THERE ARE OTHER UNIVERSITIES AT
HOW THEY WERE TRYING TO JUST
AGAIN PRADA ALL PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES TO- TO MAKE THIS
ACCESSIBLE TO ENSURE. REAL
FAIRNESS AND ACCESS FOR FOLKS
WHO HAVE SPENT YEARS GETTING
THOSE DIPLOMAS AND FROM HOME.
NOT THAT INFORMATION IS SO
IMPORTANT AS THEY'RE MOVING
INTO DIFFERENT STAGES OF THEIR
LIVES ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SIMILAR TO WE WON'T REQUIRE AS
AN AMENDMENT THE ACTUALLY
STRIKE HIS NAME. ALL RIGHT- MAN
SHE CANCELED THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION IF YOU CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS A B. TWO FORTY FIVE A
FAMILY MEMBER TO. WITH THE
MOTION BY SENATOR GONZALES THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED. TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS A MEMBER- HI.
AMBERG FIVE. PORTIS NO CARRIER
DON'T. THE I SAW IT I THOUGHT
I'D GONE. GONZALEZ I HURTS
BURKE HERZBERG HI JONES. JONES
NO LAYERED LAYERED I STERN.
WHITE HOUSE GATE MY CASKEY I
WINNER. YOU HAVE SIXTY TWO SO
FAR WITH SENATORS MISSING ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
ENTERS OTHER AUTHORS. OKAY
GREAT SOME REMEMBER- ONE IS
HERE- THIS YOU TAKE PART IN
WELCOME TO OUR GUESTS- WE WERE
PLEASED TO SEE AS A CALIFORNIA
OPENS UP THE FOLKS ARE COMING
TO VISIT US AND WATCH YOUR
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT IN
PROGRESS SO. THANKS FOR BEING
HERE. THERE'S A THERE'S A
FAMOUS PRIME MINISTER IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM THAT ONCE SAID
THERE ARE TWO THINGS YOU SHOULD
NEVER SEE MADE EVERYONE HERE
KNOWS THAT EXPRESSION. ONE IS
SAUSAGE THE OTHERS LAW SO
YOU'RE WATCHING BOTH BEING
MADE. ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WITH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR- BUT- AND
SENATORS. I AM HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT TO EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT BILL HAT A LOT IN OUR
STATE LAWS ON CHARITABLE GIVING
TO ACCOUNT FOR NEW ONLINE
METHODS OF DONATING THIS BILL
IS AN ONGOING WORK PRODUCT. OF
NEARLY FOUR YEARS OF EFFORT BY
MY OFFICE AND EXTENSIVE
STAKEHOLDER NEGOTIATIONS TO
UPDATE CALIFORNIA LAW. I'M
HAPPY TO HAVE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BONTA JOINED AS A
SPONSOR OF THIS YEAR'S BILL.
THIS COMMITTEE PASSED A NEARLY
IDENTICAL VERSION OF THE BILL
LAST YEAR. OVER THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF WITH MANY PROBLEMS
FACING OUR STATE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS HAVE TURNED TO THE
INTERNET TO PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
LOCAL CHARITIES. THERE ARE
VARIOUS WAYS TO GIVE ONLINE
INCLUDING GIVING DIRECTLY TO
THE CHARITY. L. AND INDIRECTLY
TO VARIOUS CHARITIES
THROUGHOUT- ONLINE PLATFORMS
THAT WILL LIST ALL CHARITIES
REGISTERED WITH THE IRS. EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT WILL ALLOW
CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING
PLATFORMS TO PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EVERY CHARITY TO
REACH FAR BEYOND ITS
TRADITIONAL DONOR BASE. WHILE
PROVIDING KEY OVERSIGHT
CAPABILITIES FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ENSURE A LEVEL.
PLAYING FIELD. THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS IS READY RESULTED IN
ADDRESSING DOZENS OF CONCERNS
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
RESULTING IN THE STRONG ABILITY
FOR YOU. WE WILL CONTINUE TO.
REVIEW STAKEHOLDER CONCERNS AS
THEY ARE RAISED THAT ARE PROUD
THAT NEARLY ALL STAKE HOLDERS.
ARE IN SUPPORT OR NEUTRAL I
THINK THAT- TODAY I HAVE
TESTIFYING WITH ME ANTHONY LIU
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND LUCY SALCEDO CARTER FROM
CAL NOT PROFITS. ALSO THE ALSO
AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE IS BRIAN ARMSTRONG
FROM THE DOJ'S. CHARITIES
SECTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIMPLY MEMBER- WHEN- MISTER LIU
OR MISS- SAUCEDO CARL R. CARTER
EITHER YOU ON THE PHONE. HI
THIS IS ANTHONY FROM D. O. J.
ALL RIGHT MISTER LIU
FLEISCHER'S. YEAH ATTORNEY
GENERAL BY THE POLICE THE
FUNCTOR ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT A BILL THAT WOULD
PROVIDE VALUABLE OVERSIGHT AND
CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING I
INTERNET PLATFORM. AND BUT ALSO
ENSURE TRANSPARENCY AND PROTECT
OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA FROM
DEFECTIVE OR MISLEADING
CHARITABLE SOLICITATION. WE
AGREE WITH THAT COMMITTEE THE
FACT I'M PAGE OF THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THE ACTIVE
AGAIN IN NEED OF UPDATING TO
CAPTURE THE RAPIDLY EXPANDING
INDUSTRY OF ONLINE CHARITABLE
GIVING. AND THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE AT THAT POINT
AFTER THE EXECUTIVE SUMMARY
BECAUSE THE COVE IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IT'S XCELERATED BEGIN
THE ONLINE FUNDRAISING. FOR
CHARITABLE PURPOSES- IN SHORT
THE CURRENT BUT WITH THE CASE
ALLOWED ADOPTED BEFORE THE
INTERNET AGE YOU'RE NOT
PHYSICALLY REACH THE NEW
CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING CLAFLIN.
SO IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT HE
DID CONTINUED ABILITY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. OUR OFFICE
NEEDS TO BE IN POSITION OVER AT
THE CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING
PRACTICES. THAT ARE CURRENT
INTERNET PLATFORMS AND TO
RESPOND NIMBLY. THE NEW
CONCERNS AND WHATEVER THEY ARE
NOT- THE STOKE THE RESULT OF A
ROBOT THEY CALL IT A PROPER
FACILITATED BY THE ONLY WOMEN'S
URBAN. AN AGING IS OFTEN THAT
DATE BACK. A COUPLE YEARS TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AT LENGTH. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE DISCUSSIONS
AND FEEDBACK WE BELIEVE THAT
THE PROPER. AND HAVE YOU HARD
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
TODAY WE THINK THAT SELLING
WOMEN HER WHEN HER LEADERSHIP
I'M AT THE PARTITION AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE HI
AND THANK YOU FOR GETTING.
THANK YOU MR LOWE OF MISS
SAUCEDO CARTER. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR- BURKE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FINALLY
PEOPLE FEEL CARTER POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT.
POLICY ALLIANCE OF MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND ORGANIZATIONS AND
THE VOICE OF THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA. KELMAN
PROFITS IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD WITH THE FAMILY.
MEMBER WHEN AND THE AG'S OFFICE
TO ADDRESS EARLIER CONCERNS.
ONLINE FUNDRAISING IS AN
IMPORTANT SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
NONPROFITS AND THIS HAS BEEN
ESPECIALLY TRUE DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WHEN IN PERSON
FUNDRAISING EVENTS HAVE COME TO
A HALT. BUT NOT PROFITS ALSO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT ONLINE
FUNDRAISING INCLUDING DELAYS
AND DONATIONS TO RECIPIENT
CHARITIES. DONOR CONFUSION
ABOUT PLATFORM FEES AND
SOLICITATIONS WITHOUT THE
NONPROFIT IN FACT. IT AS A
RESULT IN CONSULTATION WITH NON
PROFITS ACROSS THE STATE WE
DEVELOPED PRINCIPLES FOR ONLINE
FUNDRAISING THAT SUPPORTS
STRONG DONOR NONPROFIT
RELATIONSHIPS. AND PROMPT
PAYMENTS TO NON PROFIT. EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTY IF I CAN. WITH
THOSE PRINCIPLES AND IT'S
CRITICAL FOR THE WELL BEING OF
OUR NONPROFIT SECTOR FOR MANY
REASONS I'LL JUST LIST A COUPLE
HERE. THE BILL STRENGTHENS
TRUST BY POTENTIAL DONORS IN
THE ONLINE DONATIONS PROCESS.
BY REQUIRING CONSPICUOUS
DISCLOSURES MANDATED CONTENT
FROM RECIPIENT ORGANIZATIONS
WITH LIMITED EXCEPTIONS THAT
EVEN WITH THOSE EXCEPTIONS ON
NON CONSENSUS. WITH TEAMMATE.
AND REQUIRING THAT
SOLICITATIONS BE ONLY FOR
CHARITIES IN GOOD STANDING. THE
BILL ALSO SUPPORTS PROPER
DISTRIBUTION OF ONLINE
DONATIONS TO NONPROFITS SO THEY
CAN MORE QUICKLY YOU DONATED
FUNDS TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES.
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT WILL
HELP ENSURE DONOR CONFIDENCE IN
ONLINE FUNDRAISING PROTECT A
FUNDING SOURCE THAT NONPROFIT
ACCOUNTING WORK. AND MAKE SURE
THAT NEEDED RESOURCES GET THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES. FOR
THESE REASONS CANNOT PROFIT
SURGES HERE SUPPORT OF A. B.
FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF IN. THE GALLERY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY- ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN PRESENTER FRED
NOWHERE REPRESENT LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATIONS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU OTHERS IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY ROOM ONE TWELVE NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE MR
THE PHONE LINE MODERATE IF YOU
WOULD. QUEUE UP THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. FOUR EIGHT
EIGHT. AND IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE V. FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. DENTURE AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE THREE IN THE QUEUE ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL START WITH LINE
ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ERIN MILLER
REPRESENTING PAYPAL INTO PORT
THANK YOU. LINE ONE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE COULD
DRESS ON BEHALF OF THE
NONPROFIT ALLIANCE SUPPORT IF
THE MANDATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. ONE ONE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS MARTIN
DOCUMENTS ON BEHALF OF CANDID
IN THEIR SUPPORT AT A MAN I
THANK THE AUTHOR AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH HER THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT LET'S TURN
THE OPPOSITION I BELIEVE CHRIS
BOLLINGER- IS ONLINE TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MR CHAIR-
CHRIS BOLGER ON BEHALF OF CLASS
B. CLASS HE'S A PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATION THE TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY EMPLOYEES BASED IN SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA. WE PROVIDE
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS FOR NON
PROFIT. CIVICALLY CLASSY
PROVIDES A SOFTWARE AS A
SERVICE PLATFORM TO NON PROFITS
THE END DIRECT CONTRACT BETWEEN
CLASSY IN THE NONPROFIT. THIS
ALLOWS THEM TO ORGANIZE RUN AND
REPORT ON THEIR OWN CHARITABLE
CAMPAIGNS. HE DOES NOT CONTROL
ANY FUNDS ON BEHALF OF THE
CLIENT. ALL DONATIONS GO
DIRECTLY INTO AN ACCOUNT
CONTROLLED BY THE NON PROFIT IN
THE CAMPAIGNS ARE DESIGNED AND
CARRIED OUT SOLELY BY THE
NONPROFIT. WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHORS OFTEN COMMITTEE
OFFERS OFFICE AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR HEARING OUR CONCERNS.
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR
CONFIRMED LAST WEEK THE CLASS
IS NOT THE INTENDED TARGET OF
SOME OF THE MOST PROBLEMATIC
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDED IN THE BILL.
UNFORTUNATELY THE BILL AS
WRITTEN IS AMBIGUOUS AND SEEMS
TO IMPLICATE CLASSY IN
SIMILARLY SITUATED SOFTWARE
PROVIDERS AS BEING SUBJECT TO
THOSE DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
AS SUCH WE PROPOSED A SIMPLE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENT. THAT IS
IN LINE WITH OUR CONVERSATION
WITH THE AUTHOR'S INTENT AND
WOULD CLARIFY THE SCOPE OF THE
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS UNDER
THE BELT. WE THINK THE BILL HAS
MERIT WITH OUR TECHNICAL
CLARIFICATION WILL BE HAPPY TO
WITHDRAW. OUR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BOLGER. ANYONE
ELSE AN OPPOSITE TO- AV ONE
EXCUSE ME A. B. FOUR EIGHT
EIGHT. SAYING NO ONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY SEEING KNOWN IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE OTHERS ON THE
PHONE LINE. AND IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO A V. FOUR EIGHT
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
TEN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AT
THE TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN OUR
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
RESEARCHER ALL RIGHT A VERY
BACK TO FLOOR SEE MISTER JONES
MICROPHONE UP MISS JONES. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- AS A MEMBER-
FOR ONE- I HAD THE SAME
CONCERNS AS THE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION AND MY UNDERSTANDING
IS. THAT THE AMENDMENT THAT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR IS PRETTY
SIMPLE DID YOU WANNA SPEAK TO
THAT MATTER AND- LET US KNOW
AROUND THAT- YES IT CERTAINLY I
WILL AND- HOPEFULLY I STATED
THAT WE HAD NEARLY ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND SUPPORTER
NEUTRAL AND I HAVE TO JUST SAY
THIS HAS BEEN A VERY LONG AND
ARDUOUS PROCESS WE ARE
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS HAD UP TO
FORTY STAKEHOLDERS- SO- THERE
IS THAT THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF PROGRESS
THIS IS ONE OF THESE. LAST
ISSUES WE DID FACILITATE A CALL
BETWEEN CLASS C. L. AND A AND
D. O. J. AND WE APPRECIATE
THEIR EFFORTS WITH THE
AMENDMENTS BUT WE THINK THEY
OVERSTATE- WHAT WAS SHARED ON
THE CALL AND THE DOJ IS THE
SOLE ENFORCER ON THIS BILL AND
SO WE'RE NOT SURE WHY THEY'RE
UNCONCERNED PROCESS AFTER DOJ
SHARE THEIR INTERPRETATION BUT
WE WILL CERTAINLY CONTINUE TO.
ADD THEIR INTERPRETATION OF HOW
CLASSY IS AFFECTED BY THE BILL
THAT WILL CERTAINLY CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THAT. ALL RIGHT
MISTER CHAIRMAN JOHNSON IF I
CAN ASK FOR CLARIFICATION ON
THE MOTION SURE WILL IT. EIGHT
IT GOES TO APPROPRIATIONS
APPROPRIATIONS FROM HERE RIGHT
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT IS IT SAID IT
ALSO IS YOUR MICROPHONE UP YES
MA'AM I JUST WANTED TO-
REITERATE WHAT- THE SENATOR.
JUST MENTIONED- WITH REGARDS TO
THE OPPOSITION- CLASSY WE HAVE
I HAVE A LIST OF SOMETHING LIKE
FORTY FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS
NONPROFITS THAT. BENEFIT FROM
THE KIND OF SERVICE THAT THEY
PROVIDE SO- YOU KNOW THEY'RE
VERY LEGITIMATE. ESTABLISHED
NONPROFITS THAT RELY ON THAT
KIND OF SERVICE I WOULD REALLY
URGE IF WE COULD ALL FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GIVEN THE COMFORT LEVEL
THAT THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO CARRY OUT THAT
SERVICE. ALL RIGHT SIR HERBERT.
THEY CAN I JUST PICKED UP I
WANT TO MOVE THE BILL BUT I
ALSO AND I HOLD THIS AUTHOR IN
EXTREMELY HIGH REGARD. SHE JUST
REALLY DOES HER HOMEWORK IMAGES
IS FABULOUS SAID. ADDITION TO
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY- I JUST
THINK THAT FROM WHAT I CAN
GATHER I DIDN'T EXAMINE IT I
JUST HAD ONE MEETING WITH SOME
FOLKS. FROM THAT GROUP AND IT
SOUNDED LIKE. BECAUSE THERE'S A
LOT OF DIMENSION TO THIS AND I
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO HAVE
THOSE BIG GROUPS TOGETHER AND
WHAT IT TAKES. BUT IT SOUNDS
LIKE THIS IS A NOT FOR PROFIT
AND SHE GETS A PLATFORM FOR.
INFORMATION THAT GRANT MAKERS
AND OTHERS CAN GO TO BOMB ABOUT
ABOUT GETTING INFORMATION THEY
DON'T RAISE THE MONEY THEY
DON'T DO ANY OF THE KINDS OF
ACTIVITIES THAT I COULD BE
WRONG. BUT I JUST THINK THAT
YOU KNOW HE'S ON A JOINT AND AS
YOU DO THE HOMEWORK WHICH ALLOW
IT WAS DO OR MOVE THE BILL BUT
I ALSO WANT TO JUST A JOINED IN
WITH. A SENATOR RAWSON CENTER
JONES THAT REGARD JUST BE MAYBE
THERE'S A WAY TO FIX IT BECAUSE
IF I LOOK AT THE KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT THE LEGITIMATE BUT IF
THEY'RE A GOOD ORGANIZATION.
THAT ISN'T REALLY INTENDED TO
FALL WITHIN WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS WE MODERNIZE
FUNDRAISING BUT IS SIMPLY A
PLATFORM. THAT FOLKS CAN GO TO
FOR A REFERENCE POINT EIGHTY
TWO IS A NOT FOR PROFIT IT MAY
BE WORTH CONSIDERING THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG ANY
OTHER CAR YES SIR JONES. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THE
RECOGNITION I CERTAINLY SHARE
SINNERS BURGERS OPINION OF THE
AUTHOR- WE'VE ALWAYS HAD A
GREAT CONVERSATIONS AND
ACTUALLY I'VE LEARNED QUITE A
BIT. FROM A SIMILAR NUMBER ONE
ON THE PRIVACY STUFF AND EVEN
MY OWN IPHONE SO I I'M GOING TO
VOTE AGAINST THE BILL TODAY BUT
I WILL SEE AN APPROPRIATIONS
AND- IF WE GET TO THE POINT-WHERE. IT'S THERE'S A COMFORT
LEVEL ALL EVEN- YOU KNOW SPEAK
IN SUPPORT ON THE FLOOR IF THAT
HELPS BUT- TODAY AND I'M GOING
TO VOTE NO. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONE
FAN CLUB SEEING NONE ALL RIGHT
SO HERS FIRST MOVE THE BILL. SO
REMEMBER- WHEN YOU TO CLOSE-
CERTAINLY I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
GO A MOMENT TO MAKE. THAT
MISTER LIU FOR DO DIDN'T HAVE
ANY COMMENTS ON. HIS
CONVERSATION WITH CLASSY WOULD
THAT BE OKAY OR ARE WE TOO LATE
FOR SURE GO AHEAD. MR LIU ARE
YOU AVAILABLE HI YEAH YES I'M
HERE THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME AN
OPPORTUNITY- SO WE'RE
DEFINITELY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THE DISCUSSION ABOUT
CLASS BEING ABOUT THEIR
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS YOU KNOW
THEY'RE SEEKING. TO CLARIFY.
DEFINITION OF CHARITABLE FUND
RAISING PLATFORMS. I'VE BEEN
THERE BUSINESS MODEL- WE
RECEIVED THE AIR REVIVE AND
THEN MEN FIND FRIDAY AFTERNOON.
AND WE JUST NEED A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME TO REVIEW THEM AND
HOPEFULLY HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH DENNIS I
THINK THAT I WOULD BE ABLE TO
BE ACCEPTED BEFORE THE HEARING
AND WE JUST HAVE TO BE
CONCERNED BUT I HAVE. THE
PARTICULAR WAY ELEVEN WORDED
DOES NOT CREATE A LOOPHOLE THAT
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. AND SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ANALYZING HAS
BEEN MOVED FORWARD WITH THAT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN YOU CARED
TO CLOSE THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL TIME OF MOTION BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG. BENCH ACCOUNTS IF
YOU CALL THE ROLL. YES THIS IS
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT BY A
FAMILY MEMBER- WHEN. THE MOTION
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE HI.
AMBERG FIVE BURGESS. IT'LL BE
AT ALL I DID ASAL. DRESSED SO I
A. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HURTS
BERG. PRESSBURGER I'D JONES.
JONES NO LAYERED LAYERED I
STERN STERN I WAKE. BY CAL SKI
I WINNER BUT. THE VICTIMS NEED
TO CHANGE THAT AT ONE TWO FOUR
FIVE SIX SEVEN THAT'S EIGHT TO
ONE SO FAR WITH MEMBERS MISSING
WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL SOME
OF THEM- WHEN YOU HAVE A B. ONE
ONE ZERO ONE AS WELL YES YOU
HAVE ME AGAIN- I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
SUGGESTIONS AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AB ELEVEN NO ONE
WILL PROVIDE CLARITY ON
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
I AUTHORED AB TWENTY NINE
TWELVE THAT UPDATED THE TOOLS
AVAILABLE FOR HOAS TO PREVENT
FRAUDULENT ACTIVITIES- SINCE
ITS PASSAGE WE HAVE HEARD FOR
THE NEEDS OF COURSE
SPECIFICATIONS AS SOME OF THE
TERMS THAT WERE IN THE ORIGINAL
BILL AB ELEVEN A ONE IS A
TECHNICAL CLEANUP MEASURE THAT
DIRECTLY RESPONDS TO
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS FROM
STAKEHOLDERS THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT OUR EFFORTS TO
COMBAT FRAUD ARE CLEAR SO THAT
HOAS CAN. EFFECTIVELY PROTECT
THEIR FUNDS TODAY- TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT I HAVE THOMAS WHERE
AN ATTORNEY WHO LITIGATED H.
AWAY FRAUD CASES AND STACEY
DONNELLY AN EXPERT IN FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT FOR COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS ALREADY THANK YOU
MR WHERE. OR MISS DONNELLY ARE
YOU AVAILABLE. YES THIS IS OUR
PROMISE. ALL RIGHT MISTER WE'RE
GO HEAD ON- GOOD AFTERNOON- I'M
CURRENTLY THAT LISTED CO CHAIR
FOR COMMUNITY SERVICE STATIONS
INTO JIM'S- CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE ACTION COMMITTEE
KNOWN AS CLASS. AND A MONUMENT
JOURNEYS REPRESENT HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION AFTER THIRTY TWO
YEARS- WITH A PARTICULAR
EXPERTISE. SOLUTIONS THE DELHI
BONDS AND INSURANCE CLAIMS TO
RECOUP MONIES THEY ARE IN
BATTLE AND I REALLY WANT TO
FOCUS ON ONE PARTICULAR ASPECT
OF IT THE ELEVEN OH ONE AND
THAT HAS TO DO WITH THE
INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS.
CURRENTLY CIVIL CODE SECTION
FIFTY EIGHT OF SIXTY MANDATES
THAT THIS LOCATION BUT THE
TANKER TELEFON COVERAGE TO
ENSURE GET STAFFED DIRECT UP BY
DIRECTORS OFFICERS MANAGEMENT
AGENTS AND MANAGEMENT. COMPANY
EMPLOYEES ARE- ALL CLEAR THAT
THERE'S OTHER CUT OF INSURANCE
TO THAT ARE AVAILABLE I'M- MORE
CALM IN THE HOME ASSOCIATION-
UNITY THAT WOULD GUIDE THE
PROTECTIVE. TYPE OF I GET THE
SAME TYPE THAT THERE'S A
FIDELITY BOND BUT THEY ARE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF INSURANCE-
WHICH INCLUDE VICTIMS I'M
PLAYING BALL- CRIME LOSS AND
EMPLOYEE DISHONESTY- CUT THE
COVERAGE IN THIS BILL- PROVIDED
THAT THOSE TYPE OF- INSURANCE
INSTRUMENTS ARE SUFFICIENT TO
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF. ITO
SIX BOMBS ON IT THEY HAVE THE
SAME COVERAGE REQUIREMENTS AS
IN THE ORIGINAL BILL- WE THINK
THIS IS A NON CONTROVERSIAL
BILL IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
GOAL OF THE BABY TWENTY NINE
TWELVE OF PROTECTING
ASSOCIATION FINANCES AND
ACCORDINGLY WE. ORDERED YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU
MR WHERE- MISS DONNELLY OR
AVAILABLE. I AM HERE THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS STACY DONNELLY I AM THE
C. F. O. OF CONDOMINIUM
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT WE PROVIDE
BOOKKEEPING SERVICES FOR COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS AND HAVE
DONE SO FOR FORTY SIX YEARS. I
HAVE PERSONALLY BEEN INVOLVED
IN THE INDUSTRY FOR TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS AND I ALSO SERVE ON
THE LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT
COMMITTEE ALONG WITH MR WHERE.
ABC ELEVEN OH ONE IS TO PROVIDE
TWELVE WHICH
JANUARY OF TWENTY NINETEEN. NOW
THAT WE HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE
WITH AB TWENTY NINE TWELVE IN
ACTUAL PRACTICE. WE SEE SOME
AREAS THAT NEED SOME FURTHER
CLARIFICATION. CURRENTLY THERE
IS A CALCULATION WITH. REQUIRED
WITH RESPECT TO TRANSFERS THAT
ARE ALLOWED BY A MANAGING
AGENT. AND NOT CALCULATION CAN
CHANGE ON A DAILY BASIS AS IT
RELATES TO BALANCES THAT BANK
ACCOUNT. SO WHAT WE ARE ASKING
FOR IS A MORE DEFINITIVE
THRESHOLD HERE. THERE ARE ALSO
FURTHER PROTECTIONS ON HOW HOAS
INVEST THEIR MONEY REQUIRING
PROTECTION OF PRINCIPLE. AND
LASTLY I WANT TO POINT OUT
FURTHER PROTECTIONS WITH
RESPECT TO COMPUTER FRAUD AND
FUNDS TRANSFER FRAUD INSURANCE
MY COMPANY PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCED A LOSS IN THIS
ARENA AND IT IS THE FASTEST
GROWING LOSS LEADER FOR OUR
INTERESTS INDUSTRY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU MISTER ALI-
OTHERS IN SUPPORT I SEE NO ONE
IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE MODERATE IF YOU
WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF A B. ONE ONE ZERO ONE. I
WOULD BE GRATEFUL. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF A B. ELEVEN OH
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE ONE IN OUR
QUEUE IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT.
YEAH WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE OH
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN
THE CHAIR MEMBERS BECAUSE THE
TERRORISM YEAH THE COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT MODERATOR. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT. ARM. NOT TURNED
OPPOSITION- WE HAVE ONE
PRINCIPAL WITNESS LISTED IN
OPPOSITION MISS MARJORIE
MURRAY. THIS MURRAY AVAILABLE.
MISS MERRY CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN GO AHEAD I'M HERE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU. I'M MARJORIE
MURRAY CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION LAW GOOD
AFTERNOON- GERMAN NUMBER TEN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. ABC
ELEVEN OH ONE SEVERAL THINGS
I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON ONLY ONE
OTHER ELEMENT. AND I'M GOING TO
BEGIN BY SAYING THAT THE
COLLAPSE OF THE FLORIDA
CONDOMINIUM TOWER LAST THURSDAY.
IT'S A STARK LESSON IN WHY THE
AGENTS IN FLORIDA AND ELSEWHERE
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA NEED
RESERVE ACCOUNT. UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW RESERVES ARE TO
BE USED BY A BOARD TO MAINTAIN
REPAIR AND REPLACE. BUILDING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOUNDATIONS
ROOFS THAT FEDERAL ALL THE
CAPITAL ITEMS. THE COLLAPSE OF
THE TOWER IS ALSO A LESSON IN
WHY RESERVES NEED TO BE
PROTECTED AND IN SHORT. SUPPLY
THE BUILDING HELP. IT ELEVEN OR
ONE COLOR TO DO JOE THAT TO
OFFER. TO THE THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION NOW CONTROL ALL OF
THE COLLECTED FROM HOMEOWNERS.
HOWEVER WE DON'T SEE ANY
EVIDENCE. OF THAT IN THE BILL
IT'S NOT THE BE ALL PROMISES A
NUMBER OF THINGS. IT'S GOING TO
PUT HOMEOWNER MONEY INTO WORK
ACCOUNTS INSURED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IT'S GOING TO GUARD
THE PRINCIPAL IT'S NOT GOING TO
RISK THE MONEY IN STOCKS OR
OTHER RESTRICTIONS. INVESTMENTS
HOWEVER WE DON'T SEE ANY
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS TO MAKE SURE
THAT BOARDS DELIVER ON THE
PROMISES. NOR ARE THERE
PENALTIES FOR FAILURE TO
DELIVER. WE POINTED OUT
BECAUSE- IT'S ALREADY LAW THE
BOARD DEPOSIT HOMEOWNER MONEY
IN FEDERALLY INSURED ACCOUNTS
HOWEVER. BOARDS ARE ALREADY
TAKING MONEY OUT OF INSURED
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AND
HANDED OVER TO BROKER DEALERS
TO INVEST IN THE CAPITAL
MARKETS AND THEY'RE DOING THIS
WITHOUT PENALTY OF ANY KIND. IN
ONE SAN LUIS OBISPO ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU MISS VERY BORED MISS
MERRY IF YOU WRAP IT UP PLEASE.
I'M I'M ON MY OWN. OPPOSITION
WITNESS DO I HAVE THE
ADDITIONAL TWO MINUTES. ALL
RIGHT I'LL GIVE YOU AN
ADDITIONAL TWO MINUTES A LOT OF
A LOT OF THE OTHER SIDE. GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. ONE ST LOUIS
OBISPO ASSOCIATION IS MOVING
ITS ENTIRE RESERVE ACCOUNT OF
ONE POINT ONE MILLION OUT OF AN
INSURED BANK AND GIVING IT TO
BROKER DEALERS THE PARTY MODE
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND OUT OF ONE
THING AND THEN MOVING ANOTHER.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DO A
SECOND BOCA JUNIORS. IT IS A
GOOD THING. NOT IF YOU ASK THE
HOMEOWNERS. THE RETIREMENT
COMMUNITY AND SENIORS AGE FIFTY
FIVE TO NINETY EIGHT. THEY ARE
PEOPLE OF MODEST MEANS WITH THE
BOARD LOSES THE MONEY IN THE
CAPITAL MARKETS. FIFTEEN YEARS
CAN'T RETURN TO THE WORKFORCE
TO PAY FOR SPECIAL ASSESSMENT
LEVIED BY THE BOARD TO RESTORE
THE RESERVES. I'M CALLED THE
TRANSACTION. FROM YOUR HOMEWORK.
ONE HOMEOWNER ARE REQUIRED
COUNTY WHAT A WORKER AND
AUDITORS HAS QUESTIONED THE
BOARD'S DECISION TO MOVE THE
RESERVE INTO THE CAPITAL
MARKETS. WHAT IS THE BOARD'S
RESPONSE. IT HAD SUMMONED HIM
AND HIS WIFE IT WOULD BE A VERY
HEARING FOR ALLEGEDLY HARASSING
THE BOARD QUESTION. THE BOARD
HAS ALSO DISTRIBUTED A LETTER
TO ALL OTHERS TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE HOME OWNERS IN THE
COMMUNITY CRITICIZING HIM FOR
ASKING TOO MANY QUESTIONS.
ABOUT MOVING THE RESERVE
ACCOUNT. HE HAD THE HOMEOWNER
HAS NOW RETAINED AN ATTORNEY TO
DEFEND HIMSELF AGAINST THE
CHARGES. WE HAVE BEEN PROPOSING
FOR SOMETIME ON AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD ALLOW HOMEOWNERS TO TAKE
DIRECT ACTION TO STOP FORD.
FROM DOING WHAT A DILEMMA NO
ONE.HAS BEEN TRYING TO DO IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THE RESERVE
ACCOUNT. WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
HIM IS VERY ABLE. VERY IF YOU'D
WRAP UP. YES WE HAVE PROPOSED
AN AMENDMENT THAT WOULD ALLOW.
HOMEOWNERS SORRY RIGHT RIGHT.
ASSUME YOUR BILLS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON- ALL RIGHT
OTHERS THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION I
SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLEYI SEE
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE-
OTHERS ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO- A. B. ONE ONE
ZERO ONE. AND IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO A B. ELEVEN OH
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
AT THE TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. PLEASE CONTINUE MR TRUMP
ALREADY THANK YOU LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE FLOOR. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS ON THE FLOOR. BUT YES
AND A GOOD SOLACE. BUT I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IT SEEMS VERY COMMON
SENSE AND- CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOUR WITNESSES AND
SUPPORTERS ARE SAYING AND I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE BUILDING
UP OF ALL RIGHT THINKING IT'S
ALL SUPPOSED TO BILL SENT A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. YES I DO
HAVE A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR-
IT COULD YOU ADDRESS THE ISSUE
OR TALK TO THE ISSUE THAT WAS
RAISED BY THE LAST SPEAKER IN
REGARDS TO THE- THE- TRUST
ACCOUNT FOR- THAT THAT FACILITY.
I AM SO AS WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION BUT-
CONCERNS ABOUT NFORCEMENT OR
OTHER PORTIONS OF THE DATA
STERLING ACT ARE ADDRESSED ON
PAGES SEVEN AND EIGHT OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHICH TALKS
ABOUT A LOT OF THE CONSOLE THE
OPPOSITION'S- CRITICISMS AND
WHAT THE ANALYSIS SAYS IS THAT
THOSE CRITICISMS ARE OF MORE
APPROPRIATELY DIRECTED AT
CURRENT LAW RATHER THAN
ANYTHING THAT THE BILL.
PROPOSES TO DO. SORRY THANK YOU
OTHER QUESTIONS THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR GONZALEZ-
SIMILAR- INDICATE A CLOSE AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE THE OTHER EXCELLENT CLOSE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. NOT IN
CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS A B. ELEVEN OH ONE
BY A FAMILY MEMBER- WIN WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR GONZALES
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED AMBERG HI. AM BERG I
BORJAS. PORTIS I. GORGEOUS I
HAVE A IT'LL CARRY IT OUT I DID
I STILL. THE REST SO I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HURTS BERG HERZBERG
BY JONES JONES I LAYERED
LAYERED I STERN. STERN HIGHWAY
CASKEY Y. CASKEY I WINNER. WELL
YOU HAVE TEN TO ZERO WITH A
MEMBER MISSING ALL RIGHT WE'LL
PUT THAT BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR THANK YOU
NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW A. B. ONE FOUR SEVEN FIVE
AND WE'VE GOT- TWO MORE BILLS
AFTER THAT. YEAH WELL EXCUSE
ME. ONE MORE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ONE MORE BILL AFTER THIS
SO. IF YOU- ARE INTENDING TO.
VOTE ON THEIR BILLS YOU MAY
WANT O PRESENT YOURSELF- MY
CONGRATULATIONS AND KUDOS TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR MOVING WITH
GREAT ALACRITY. DEMONSTRATING A
GREAT DEAL OF DISCIPLINE THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
DOESN'T JOY AT SUPPORT
RECOGNITION ON BOTH SIDES I
ALSO ALLOW ME TO BE BRIEF TO
HELP ENSURE THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR PUBLIC. AND SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE ON ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE. THANK.
SENATOR BYRD'S PROPOSAL ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS SEEING NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT
OF LET'S GO TO- SUPPORT- I AM
ESTEBAN NOON YES ONLINE IN
SUPPORT. A CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AND- ITEMS UP FOR NEW YEAR'S
TIME THE DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY
AND COMMUNITY ORGANIZING WITH
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
ALSO KNOWN AS A. R. C. MUG SHOT
POSTED ON SOCIAL MEDIA IS JUST
ANOTHER INSTANCE OF HOW SOCIETY
DEMONIZES CHAINS AND OSTRACIZED
AS INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE YET TO
BE FOUND GUILTY OF ANY CRIME. I
WANT TO SPEAK TO THE DAMAGES
THAT MAY OCCUR WHEN SOMEONE'S
MUG SHOT IT POSTED ONLINE OF
COURSE THERE ARE THE DAMAGES TO
THE EXCUSE MY OWN FACE WAS
CHARACTERIZED AS A MURDER BUT I
WASN'T IN A SENSE AND THAT WAS
JUST ONE OF THE MANY
CONSEQUENCES OF MY CHOICES.
SOMEONE WHO WAS INNOCENT AND
HAD NO CONTROL OVER MY CHOICES
WITH MY FAMILY AND THAT'S WHAT
COMPELLED ME TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY. AFTER MY MUGSHOT WAS
POSTED ONLINE MY BROTHER ELEVEN
YEARS YOUNGER AND NINE YEARS
OLD AT THE TIME WAS RIDICULED
BY CLASSMATES AND ANOTHER JUST
BECAUSE OF ME. SO MUCH SO THAT
HE DENIED. HAVING SIBLINGS FOR
MUCH OF HIS UPBRINGING. AND I.
ME TO MY CORE TO THIS DAY. MY
MOTHER A LONGTIME NURSE SHE
WENT INTO A DEPRESSION FROM THE
CATASTROPHIC DECISIONS I MADE
IN MY YOU. EVERYWHERE YOU TURN
PEOPLE RECOGNIZE HER AND FOUND
CREATIVE USES OF LANGUAGE TO
BELITTLE AND DEMEAN HER AND THE
MOTHER OF A MURDERED. MY SISTER
TWO YEARS YOUNGER FOUND HERSELF
IN CONSTANT DISARRAY SHE TRIED
TO DEFEND HER BROTHER'S NAME
AND CHARACTER. THE PAIN AND
GRIEF BECAME SO OVERWHELMING
SHE FELL VICTIM TO DRUGS I HAVE
HAD SO MANY SUICIDE ATTEMPTS
I'VE LOST COUNT. MY FATHER HAS
BEEN SPENT ON. TROLLED AND
SHAMED. A MUGSHOT REPRESENT THE
LOWEST MOMENT IN SOMEONE'S LIFE
POSTED A MUGSHOT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA DOES NOTHING TO HELP A
LEGAL CASE PROGRESS IN ANY
DIRECTION OTHER THAN
HUMILIATING AND SHAMING
SOMEONE. APRIL SIXTEENTH MARCH
MY FIVE YEARS OF BEING HELD AND
I'VE DEVOTED MY LIFE TO THIS
WORK NO MATTER HOW MUCH GOOD
IDEA OF THE IMAGERY OF MY
MUGSHOT WILL FOREVER BE BRANDED
IN THE MINDS AND HEARTS OF
PEOPLE WHO WILL ALWAYS JUDGE
ME. IT NEVER KNOW ME. WE MUST
REMEMBER AND DO ALL THAT WE CAN
TO PRESERVE THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE AND RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANT HARM CAUSED BY
DEMONIZING PEOPLE. REQUIRES LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO REMOVE
MUG SHOT THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA
IF THE INDIVIDUAL. WHO IS THE
SUBJECT OF THE POST I HAD
DIRECTED FIELD. CONVICTION
DISMISSED EXPLAIS ARE
RELEGATED OR RECEIVED THE
CERTIFICATE OF REHABILITATION.
THIS RESTORES HOPE THAT ONE DAY
PEOPLE SUCH AS I CAN BE
REMEMBERED NOT FOR THE HORRIBLE
DECISIONS WE MADE UP FOR WHAT
WE DID WITH OUR LIVES AS A
RESULT OF THOSE DECISIONS. IT
IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
ARGUE ABOUT IT IN SUPPORT OF A.
B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISMAS ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT- I SEE NO ONE
OF THE GALLERY NO ONE ROOM ONE
TWELVE OTHERS IN SUPPORT. OF.
AB ONE FOUR SEVEN FIVE.
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD QUEUE
THEM UP. AND IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF A B. ONE FOUR SEVEN
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AND
WE DO HAVE TWO IN THE QUEUE.
ALL RIGHT. CALLS WILL STORYLINE
ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAROLINA APPEARED ON BEHALF OF
A FEEL YOU CAL ACTION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE ONE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
LINE ONE SEVENTY TWO NEW LINES
OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES HI THIS IS JENNIFER WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
EVERYONE ELSE AND SUPPORT ON
THE LINE. AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT WELL LET'S
GO TO OPPOSITION ANYONE ON THE
LINE I SEE NO LAPSES IN THE
GALLERY KNOWN OPPOSITION ROOM
ONE TWELVE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB ONE
FOUR SEVEN FIVE. AND AFTER AN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE FOUR SEVEN
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE
ZERO PROPOSITION. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT- NOW
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
FLOOR- QUESTIONS I SEE SENATOR
HERTZBERG SAID HERZBERG. I
MOVED THIS BILL MR CHAIRMAN.
AND I WANT TO COMMEND MY DEAR
FRIEND SIMPLY NUMBER LOW. AND I
WANT TO STAND HERE AS A PERSON.
AND TELL YOU THAT MY HEART
SINKS TO LISTEN. TWO SEVEN.
TESTIFIED THE WAY HE JUST DID.
BUT FAMILY ABOUT HIS MOTHER
ABOUT HIS FATHER. IF OUR JUDEO
CHRISTIAN I THINK OF IT
ATTENTION. JUST DEMONSTRATED.
THANK YOU CENTERS BURKE. ALL
RIGHT- THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
CENTER HERZBERG MOVES THE BILL-
THANK YOU COUNSEL RECALL ROLE.
WELL I'M SORRY A SIMILAR NUMBER
LOW I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE I THANK YOU. A HUNDRED
THIS IS ABC ONE FOUR SEVEN FIVE
BY FAMILY MEMBER LOW- WITH A
MOTION BY SENATOR HERTZBERG THE
MOTION IS TO PASS ON BURKE BY A
BURGER I BURGESS. BURGESS HI
COVEY IT'LL- I DID I SAW. THAT
I SAW I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
HURTS BERG. HURTS BERG I A.
JONES JONES I LAYERED. LAYERED
ICE STERN STERN I WAKE HOUSEKI
Y. CASKEY I WINNER. YOU HAVE
TEN TO ZERO WITH ONE SENATOR
MISSING ALL RIGHT. SO THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LAW- THAT WOULD
THAT BILL GOES ON CALL. ALL
RIGHT. LAST BILL TO BE HEARD
LAST BILL TO BE HEARD- IS AB.
ONE FOUR SIX SIX. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY ASSUME
IS ON HIS WAY. AFTER THAT WE
WILL- OPEN THE ROLE. I'D LIKE
TO GIVE A FIFTEEN MINUTE SPEECH
AND THEN WE'LL CLOSE THE ROLE.
YEAH. WE CAN OPEN THE ROLE YOU
KNOW WHAT WHY DON'T WE DO THIS
WHY DON'T WE OPEN THE ROLE
WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AND
LET'S JUST GO THROUGH THE ROLE.
I'M SORRY. SENATOR HERTZBERG WE
SHOULD BE RECOGNIZED. NO ALL
RIGHT. BUT LET'S LET'S OPEN THE
ROLE- WAR WINNING FORCIBLY
MEMBER CARD ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
ALRIGHT JONES JONES HI STERN
STERN I WINNER YOU HAVE TEN TO
ZERO WITH ONE MEMBER MISSING
ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT BACK
ON CALL OKAY THE NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY THREE
SEVENTY ONE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I. REGIS NOT VOTING
JONES. JONES NOT VOTING STERN.
MR AND I A WINNER. YOU HAVE
EIGHT ZERO SO FAR ALL RIGHT
WE'LL PUT THAT BACK ON CALL AND
I SEE SALOON MCCARTY IS HERE SO
WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE THE
OPENING OF THE ROLE AND- PERMIT
SENTIMENT MCCARTY SUDANESE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY RESENT
AB ONE FOUR SIX SIX ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SIX THE VERY LAST- BILL
BE HEARD TODAY SIMILAR MCCARTY
DISCLOSURES JUST DON'T CALL ME
CONGRESSMAN MCCARTHY. OKAY I AM
REALLY GOOD AT IT I. THAT WOULD
BE DEFAMATORY BUT I THINK THIS
PRIVILEGE IN ANY EVENT THANK
YOU I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON THIS
MEASURE WOULD YOU AND YOUR
STAFF- THIS IS RELATED TO AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF CALIFORNIA
HISTORY HISTORY UNFORTUNATELY.
A SAD PIECE AS FAR AS THE
RACIAL INJUSTICE ON ON OUR
HOUSING POLICY- RELATED TO-
HOUSING COVENANTS SET FOR
EXCLUDED INDIVIDUALS-
MINORITIES- YOU KNOW OTHER.
ASIANS AFRICAN AMERICANS
LATINOS IN JEWISH INDIVIDUALS-
FROM PURCHASING HOMES IN
CERTAIN NEIGHBORHOODS AS THIS
HAS A CHANCE TO RIGHT A WRONG
AND I WENT THINK UNIQUELY STAFF
WORKING WITH US- AND START OFF
BY SAYING WE WILL- ACCEPT THE
SUGGESTIONS AND PAGE SEVEN OF
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND
CHARTING A PATH FORWARD AND-
PENDING TODAY'S POSSIBLE
PASSAGE OF THE AMENDMENTS WILL
BE TAKEN NEXT COMMITTEE. TO
ESTABLISH A TASK FORCE TO
IDENTIFY REDACT RACIST
COVENANTS ON A LARGER SCALE AND
REMOVE- REMOVE THIS GREAT
EASIER PROCESS FOR PEOPLE TO
REMOVE THEM ON THEIR OWN- WE
KNOW THAT THESE COVENANTS WERE
PRIVATE AGREEMENTS BARRING NON
WHITES FROM OCCUPYING OR OWNING
HOMES AND PROPERTY AND KEY
ELEMENTS. OF A SEGREGATIONIST
POLICIES IN THE EARLY PART OF
THE LAST CENTURY- THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF EXAMPLES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA RIGHT HERE IN THIS
MY OWN DISTRICT RIGHT HERE IN.
IN SOUTH LAND PARK IN FRANKLIN
TOP PARK WHEN I BOUGHT MY FIRST
HOME I REMEMBER MY REALTOR
SAYING HEY KEVIN I KNOW THAT
YOU ARE BI RACIAL AND- YOUR
DAD'S AFRICAN AMERICAN- YOU KEY
AND YOUR AND YOUR SPOUSE'S
ABOUT THAT YOU KNOW YOU GUYS
GOING TO BE A BIRACIAL.
MULTICULTURAL FAMILY LIVING IN
THIS NEIGHBORHOOD I JUST
IGNORED PAGE FIFTY SEVEN IT
TALKS ABOUT HOW YOU CAN'T LIVE
IN THIS HOUSE AND LITERALLY I
OPENED THE PAGE TO PAGE FIFTY
SEVEN AND I WAS FLOORED-
SHOWING THAT YOU KNOW WHO COULD
LIVE THERE WHO COULD NOT LIVE
THERE THOSE OF COURSE WERE
DEEMED UNCONSTITUTIONAL BY THE
SUPREME COURT NINETEEN FORTY
EIGHT. BUT THE THEY THEY REMAIN
AND SOME WOULD SAY. WELL THERE
ARE A RELEVANT JUST LET THEM BE.
WELL WE DON'T BE- OVER WATER.
OF SAY WHITES ONLY WE TAKE THEM
DOWN BECAUSE THEY ARE. UGLY
REMINDERS OF OUR PAST SO THIS
WILL ALLOW US TO TAKE PROACTIVE
STEPS. AND REMOVE THESE RACIAL
COVENANTS FROM OUR DEEDS. THIS
WE WHAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE- OUR LOCAL REALTORS IN
A LAND TITLE ASSOCIATION-
RECORDERS TO COME UP WITH THIS
ELEGANT SOLUTION. THAT WILL
REMOVE OPPOSITION AND WITH THAT
IT WAS THE LAST BILL TODAY I
ASK THE ARRIVAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY LET
ME JUST MAKE SURE THAT THAT
WE'RE ON THE SAME SHEET MUSIC I
THINK YOU STATED IT BUT BUT- I
WANT TO CONFIRM THAT THE STAFF
ANALYSIS OF THE BILL INCLUDES
AN OUTLINE OF THE DIRECTION YOU
PLAN TO TAKE. WITH THE BILL
THAT PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE IN
VERY BROAD TERMS THAT SCHIFF
WOULD CONVERT THE BILL FROM A
PASSIVE TRANSACTION BY
TRANSACTION APPROACH FOR
REDACTED DISCRIMINATORY
RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS TO A
PROACTIVE APPROACH. TO BE
UNDERTAKEN BY TASK FORCE
DEDICATED TO THAT PURPOSE DOES
THAT ACCURATELY CHARACTERIZE
WHERE THIS BILL IS HEADED
CORRECT MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU- OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- NONE IN
THE GALLERY OF PRINTS WILL
WITNESS AND SUPPORT SOMEONE
MEMBER CARTY SEVEN BILLION TO
ON THE PHONE JAMIE LEWIS HELLO
I'M SORRY MY YES JAMIE LEWIS-
MR LEWIS. BY JAMIE LEWIS IS
HUNG UP- OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IS IT- TO MAKE WHAT
MOSS OR JOANNE COURAGE MORE.
ARE EITHER OF THEM ON THE PHONE
YES. YET TO MAKE A MOCK OKAY.
JUST GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CHAIRMAN- AND THANK YOU AT
THE MOMENT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
MCCARTY FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THE BILL HI MY NAME IS TO MAKE
A MARK AND I'M THE FOUNDER AND
CEO OF ALL HOME WE ARE A
REGIONAL ORGANIZATION IN THE
BAY AREA LOOKING TO REDRESS
RACIAL DISPARITIES FOR THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
LOOKED AT RISK OF HOUSING AND
SECURITY IN THE BAY AREA AND I
THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY
TALKED ABOUT THIS. IN TERMS OF
THE DISCRIMINATORY LEGACY THAT
CONTINUES TO REVERBERATE IN OUR
COMMUNITY- IN THE DE FACTO
SEGREGATION IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
THAT REALLY. EVEN THOUGH IT IS
NOT LEGALLY. I IT. WE CAN'T
DISCRIMINATE LEGALLY THESE-
PRACTICES PRACTICES BUILD
NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR COMMUNITY
AND REALLY SPECIFICALLY IN OUR
HIGHER- NEIGHBORHOOD
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH HIGHER RATES
OF POVERTY- AND REALLY LIMITING
OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS- FOR A
BLACK BROWN AND INDIGENOUS
NEIGHBORS AND SO THIS
LEGISLATION IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND I AM I AM REALLY
PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF IT TODAY I HAVING
YOU KNOW WORK IN THIS. FIELD
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
WE CAN'T IGNORE THE STATE
SANCTIONS ARE DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES IN OUR HOUSING POLICY
THAT CONTINUE TO LIMIT
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR SO I URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO BE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX AND I'M
HONORED TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
IT. THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
MOSS. BY JAMIE LEWIS OR JOANNE
KARCH MAR ARE YOU AVAILABLE.
EMAIL ALL RIGHT. OKAY I'M SO
THANK YOU CHAIR AND BURGER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SIXTY SIX MY NAME IS JAMIE
LEWIS I'M A RESIDENT AT ST
LOUIS OBISPO I NEED INTO WHAT'S
CALLED THE N. HOME DISTRICT IN
FAMILY FOR THIS LOW IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHILE I WAS
PURCHASING MY HOME I WAS
FILLING OUT A STACK OF
PAPERWORK AND MY REALTOR SHARED
WITH ME AND MY FUTURE HOME
COVENANTS CONDITIONS AND
RESTRICTIONS. BUT AS READING
THROUGH THESE I WAS APPALLED TO
FIND A PROVISION PROHIBITING
ANYONE OTHER NON CAUCASIAN RACE
FROM OCCUPYING OR OWNING THE
HOME I KNEW I WANTED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS P. C. AND
R. BUT I WASN'T SURE WHAT TO DO
THEN IN THE WAKE OF GEORGE
FLOYD'S MURDER I HAD A MOMENT
OF RECKONING WHERE IT BECAME
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT THE
RACIST LANGUAGE IN MY C. AND R.
AND THE MURDER OF BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE AT THE HANDS OF
THE POLICE. ARE ALL A PART OF
AMERICAN MULTI FACETED RACIST
PAST AND PRESENT THIS IS WHEN I
BEGAN THE PROCESS OF HAVING
THAT LANGUAGE REMAINS I STARTED
SPEAKING TO NEIGHBORS I'M
GUESSING THAT THE COVENANTS
WERE PERVASIVE THROUGHOUT THE
N. HOME DISTRICT. DESPITE
KNOWING THESE CABINETS ARE NO
LONGER LEGAL OR ENFORCEABLE
IT'S POSSIBLE IMPOSSIBLE TO
UNSEE SOMETHING SO OUTWARDLY
PREJUDICE THE COMPETITION IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD IS THE DIRECT
PRODUCT AT BCC AND OURS WITH
88% OF PEOPLE LIVING IN
FAMILIES WITH BOTH BEING WHITE.
FOURTEEN NEIGHBORS AND I WERE
ABLE TO GET THE LANGUAGE AND
THEN ENGAGING AN UNCOMFORTABLE
BUT NECESSARY CONVERSATIONS
AROUND THE COMPOUNDING IMPACTS
OF THE CCN OURS HOW THEY BARRED
BLCK FAMILIES FROM ACCESSING
WHAT THE PREHEATED. OVER
GENERATIONS OF HOMEOWNERSHIP.
FOR ME REMOVAL OF THE COVENANTS
IS A SMALL STEP IN ADDRESS.
THAT THE MY LARGER IN. AT THE
DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM. HOWEVER IT
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP IN
ELEVATING THE MUCH NEEDED
CONVERSATION AND KNOWLEDGE AND
THE SYSTEMIC RACISM AND
PRIVILEGE. THE PRESENCE OF THE
CCN OURS UNDERSCORES HOW MUCH
WORK STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
PROVIDE RACIAL EQUITY IN THE
UNITED. STATES AND FOR THAT
REASON I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SIXTY SIX TO HELP CALIFORNIANS
LIKE MYSELF. GET THIS LANGUAGE
REMAINS AND I JUST WANT TO ADD
ONE SINGLE THING WHICH IS. 88%
OF PEOPLE LIVING FAMILY BUT SO
ARE WHITE. THERE ARE AS THERE
ARE. IN THE COUNTY OF SAN LUIS
OBISPO. SOMETHING LIKE EIGHT
HUNDRED- BLACK FAMILIES BLACK
RESIDENTS IN THE IN THE COUNTY
ITSELF. IN OUR LOCAL AND- STATE
PRISON JUST AROUND THE CORNER
FROM MY HOME. THERE ARE
THIRTEEN HUNDRED BLACK
INCARCERATED MEN ARE AND I
THINK THAT THAT JUST GOES TO
SHOW. AND HOW THEY GET IT MISS
LEWIS. ARE INTERESTED WAS ABOUT
FORTY TWO MINUTES THE YOU YOU
YOU'VE GOT TWO MINUTES AND
THIRTY SECONDS SO- THANK YOU
I'M DONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. ALL ALL RIGHT-
OTHERS IN SUPPORT I SEE NO ONE
IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. MODERATOR IF
YOU TWO UP OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF. EIGHTY ONE FOUR SIX SIX.
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF A B.
ONE FOUR SIX SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
FOR IN OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL START WITH A LINE ONE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
MAKE SURE NOT- YOU. MOVE ON TO
LINE ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PARTNER DOCUMENTS ON
BEHALF OF THE BLACK LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAROLINA FOOD ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU CAL ACTION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JENNIFER PRODUCT ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT LET'S TURN
THE OPPOSITION I SEE THERE ARE
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION CRAIG PAGE AND MIKE
BLOAT MR PAGER MR BELOW ARE YOU
AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE. I AM A
STRUCTURE CAN YOU HEAR ME. BUT
WE CAN. GO AHEAD. THIS IS YOUR
THANK YOU MR CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SOME QUICK PAGES
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT. AND
COUNSEL FOR THE CALIFORNIA LAND
TITLE ASSOCIATION. HELLO WE
RECENTLY RECEIVED THE
AMENDMENTS FROM THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
YOUR YOUR STAFF- FOR WORKING SO
HARD ON THIS WE THINK THESE
AMENDMENTS IF WHAT WAS SENT TO
US WILL ARE GOING TO BE ADOPTED
BY THE- THE- AUTHOR OF THE
BILL. MOST OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WE HAVE WILL GO AWAY THERE MAY
BE NEED TO BE SOME TWEAKING TO
THE ACTUAL. NOTICE PROVISIONS
ROLLED TO THE TITLE COMPANY
THAT'S FOR COMPANIES AND
OTHERS- AND ONE THING I WANT TO
FLAG TO WITH THE- RECORDING FEE
AMOUNTS OF CITED IN THE-
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. MADE
SIGNIFICANTLY RECORD THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY GENERATED FOR THIS
PROGRAM. IF THE RETAINS THE
VIEW WE APPRECIATE AGAIN YOUR
STAFF WORKING VERY HARD. ON
THIS ON THIS ON THIS
LEGISLATION WE SUPPORT. THE
OBJECTIVES OF THE LEGISLATION
AND ALSO THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR- CONSIDERING OUR OUR
POINTS. RIGHT THANK YOU MISS
PAGE RELOAD. MR KERR THIS IS
CLIFF COST UNFORTUNATELY MR
BELOW IT IS ACTUALLY TESTIFYING
IN SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE IF IT'S ALRIGHT WITH
THE COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO SPEAK
A FEW WORDS ON BEHALF OF OUR
CLIENT THE CALIFORNIA ESCROW
SITUATION SURE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MR THANK YOU MR CHAIR-
AGAIN CLICK COSTS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ESCROW ASSOCIATION
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR- HIS STAFF AS WELL AS
THE COMMITTEE AND THEIR STAFF
FOR A WONDERFUL ANALYSIS AND
FOR WORKING WITH US AS WE
CONTINUE TO GO THROUGH THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE- AS MR
BALOCH HAS SAID. PUBLICLY MANY
TIMES- TO BE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND OTHERS THIS ISSUE
HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR MORE THAN
FORTY YEARS THIS IS NOT AN EASY
ISSUE TO ACCOMPLISH- BUT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE RECEIVE THE AMENDMENTS
ARE KLEIN IS STILL REVIEWING
THAT- BUT WE APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT THAT THE APPROACH AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY. MISTER CHAIR
THANKS ARTI THANK YOU- OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION SAYING NONE OF
THE GALLERY SAYING NOT EVERYONE
TWELVE OTHERS IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE MODERATOR. ANYONE
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. AND IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION TO AB ONE
FOUR SIX SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. SECOND ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. THERE IS ONE IN OUR
QUEUE. THE LITTLE LINE ONE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- MATURE MEMBERS ROB
GROWS CLOSER REPRESENTING KENYA
RECORD ATION OF CALIFORNIA
WOULD LIKE ALIGNED MYSELF WITH
THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE PRIOR
TO CONVINCE THE COURT TO
LOOKING AT- THE LANGUAGE AND
APPRECIATE THE THOUGHT MY
NUMBER FOR WORKING ON THE ISSUE
BOTH DILIGENTLY IT IS NOT
SIGNIFICANT AND IMPORTANT. I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A ONE POINT
TWO ON THE FEED THAT PROPOSAL
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE ON OUR HALF THAT
THANK YOU MAKE SURE TO APPLY.
TO ALL DOCUMENTS ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. I RIGHT. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN OUR QUEUE ARGENTINIAN GREAT
BACK TO THE FLOOR ALL RIGHT
CENTER LAYERED. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- I WANT TO APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR FOR- TAKING THIS ON
AND DOING THIS BILL AND- OF
IT'S CLEAR THAT BASED ON THE X.
WOULD EXIST AND NOW ASSISTANT
EXCHANGE WITH THE CHAIR THAT
IT'S CHANGING DIRECTION A
LITTLE BIT IN HOW IT'S BEING
DONE MOVING ON AND I THINK.
WE'LL ALL WANT TO LOOK AT IT
AND MAKE SURE THAT DIRECTION
STILL WORKS IS AS INTENSE AS
THE AUTHOR BUT I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SECOND WITNESS.
IN FAVOUR WHO IS FROM MY
DISTRICT IN SAN LUIS OBISPO I
THOUGHT THAT WAS A- VERY MOVING
TESTIMONY IN VERY SIGNIFICANT
TALKING ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
FAMILIES VERSUS THE NUMBER OF
INCARCERATED. INDIVIDUAL TO SAN
LUIS OBISPO MEN'S COLONY AND
SO- I THINK THAT- THIS IS VERY
WORTHY AND I WOULD MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU SAID EARLIER
THE SECOND TALLEST. YES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I TOO WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- MANY OF
OUR CITIES HAVE A VERY HORRIBLE
HISTORY OF REDLINING OF ARCHAIC
DOCUMENTS THAT- CERTAINLY ARE
ARE VERY RACIST IN NATURE AND I
JUST APPRECIATE YOU PROVIDING
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
TALK ABOUT THIS. I WOULD GLADLY
PAY TWO DOLLARS TO INSURE THAT
WE ARE DIGGING THROUGH THESE
AND REMOVING THEM COMPLETELY-
AND FOR THAT I'D LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF I COULD
AS WELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. SALOON THE CARTY-
ANYONE ELSE SEEING NO THE- I'M
SORRY. ABOUT SENATOR JONES IN
IN CENTER MORICHES THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY THANK YOU FOR. THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE COMMITTEE
I DID COME IN- TO THE COMMITTEE
TODAY WITH SOME. WITH THE
CONCERNS THAT ARE OUTLINED IN
THE NOW SINCE I'M GONNA LAY OFF
TODAY- BUT I WILL SEE IT
INSURANCE AND- HOPEFULLY BE
ABLE TO EXCITEDLY VOTE FOR
INSURANCE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SIR BORDERS. I'D LIKE
TO COMMEND THE AUTHORS WELL- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE- THE
NEW FIVE AMENDMENTS- TAKE AWAY
THE CONCERNS THAT I HAD ABOUT
MAKING CERTAIN THAT THERE COULD
BE AN EXPEDITIOUS TRANSFER
PROPERTY THAT WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY ENCUMBER WITH SO
MANY EXPENSES THOSE THAT ARE
TRYING TO DEAL WITH-
REFINANCING OR CHANGING
PROPERTY SPECIALLY IN OUR
HOUSING CRISIS- ALL OF US I
THINK REPRESENT DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE. HAD TO SOME DEGREE OR
ANOTHER- RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS-
IN THE FRESNO AREA THAT I
REPRESENT YOU KNOW IT WAS NOT
UNCOMMON FOR THERE TO BE-
CONFIDENCE THAT RESTRICTED
PROPERTY TRANSFER AGAINST EASY
ADDICTS INCLUDING ARMENIANS YOU
KNOW SEMITIC AND OTHER GROUPS-
AND THOSE THINGS ARE A RELIC OF
THE PAST AND IF THERE'S A WAY
OF. INVENTORY IN THOSE- ISSUES
AND REMOVING THEM IN A WAY THAT
DOESN'T IMPEDE TODAY'S TRANSFER
OR REFINANCING I THINK IT'S A
SMART WAY AND MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THE AUTHORS AGREE TO
THOSE MOMENTS AND BECAUSE OF
THAT ALL BE SUPPORTIVE AND-
LOOK FORWARD TO ITS- IT'S FINAL
VERSION X. COMMITTEE. ALREADY
THANK YOU OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS ARE ALL RIGHT A
CENTRAL AIR IS MOVED THE BILL
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY- FOR YOUR PASSION YOUR
DEDICATION IS VERY WORTHWHILE
EFFORT AND ALSO YOUR-
WILLINGNESS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE PRACTICAL REALITIES OF.
DEALING WITH THIS ODIOUS- PAGE
FROM OUR PAST SO ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT IN TWO COUNTS OF A
CULTURAL- I'M SORRY WOULD LIKE
CLOTHES I THINK THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US I THINK
EVERYBODY WOULD AGREE THAT
THERE IS. AN ISSUE HERE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RIGHT A WRONG
THE REMEDY IS THAT IS THAT IS
THE ISSUE WE'VE BEEN GRAPPLING
WITH AND WE THINK THIS-
ACHIEVES THAT THAT THAT
DIRECTIVE- THIS IS A TWO THIRDS
ISSUE. NOW SO I WILL TAKE THE
COMMENTS SOME FOLKS OVER HERE
ON THE OTHER SIDE TO MAKE SURE
WE GET HOSE THAT. TWO THIRDS
VOTE BUT I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I LIKE TO REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION BUT DO IT. IN IN
A QUICKER TIME PAIR OF
CALIFORNIA TO REMOVE THESE
RACIST WORDS FROM OUR HOUSING
PIZZA THANK YOU ARI THANK YOU.
ARE YOU MEANT TO CANCEL THE
CALL THE ROLL YES THIS IS AB.
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY- WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR LAYER THE
MOTION IS DEEP PASS BUT FIRST.
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
INSURANCE UMBERG I. AM BERG HI
BARGES. BARGES I CARRY IT ALL.
AT ALL I DID ASAL. DID I SO I
WANT SOME LESS THAN ZEALOUS I
HEARD SOME BURG. HERTZBERG BY
JONES JONES NOT VOTING LAYERED
LAYERED ICE STERN STERN I Y.
CASKEY WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER.
WINNER I'D YOU HAVE TEN ZERO
WITH EVERYONE VOTING. ALL
RIGHTY OF SO THAT BILL IS OUT.
RIGHT LET'S OPEN THE ROLE WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH I THINK WE
GOT ALL THE NUMBERS HERE WHO
WISH TO BE INCLUDED IN THE ROLE
SO LET'S OPEN THE ROLE GO
THROUGH ONE TIME AND THEN WE'LL
ADJOURN AND I'LL SAY MY FIFTY
MINUTE SPEECH FOUR. ALL RIGHT
OKAY ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WEINER. THE WINNER HI THAT'S
ELEVEN ZERO ALL MEMBERS VOTING.
ALL RIGHT BILLS OUT. THE THING
CALENDARS OUT ADOPTED THING ON
AB OKAY FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
THREE SEVENTY ONE WITH THAT
CHAIR VOTING HI. BARGES NOT
VOTING. JONES NOT VOTING WINNER.
WINNER HI SO YOU HAVE. YOU HAVE
NINE TWO ZERO ALL SENATORS
HAVING VOTED ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU FILLS OUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE IS NEXT EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CALL THEY DON'T. WITH THAT
YOU'RE VOTING I JONES JONES HI
STERN. STERN I WEINER WEINER I
THAT'S ELEVEN TO ZERO WITH ALL
MEMBERS VOTING BILLS OUT FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX IS NEXT AB
EIGHT NINE OH ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BECAUSE THEY
DON'T- WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI.
JONES JONES I. STERN STERN I
WINNER WINNER HI THAT'S TEN TO
ONE BILLS OUT. THE NEXT ITEM IS
FILE NUMBER. SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
FORTY SIX BY FAMILY MEMBERS HAD
RUN THIS WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I BURGESS. PORTIS NOT VOTING
STERN. STERN I WAKE HOUSEKI Y.
CASKEY I WINNER WINNER I THAT'S
TEN ZERO WITH EVERYONE VOTING
BILLS OUT. THE NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM TEN AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHILD WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I.
GOT IT ALL. FEB ZERO I. STERN
STERN I WINNER WINNER HI THAT.
THAT'S NINETY TWO WITH EVERYONE
VOTING BILLS OUT THE NEXT ITEM
IS FILE ITEM THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO FORTY FIVE BY FAMILY MEMBER
SHOE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING BY
CAPITAL. CARRY IT OUT I STERN
STERN I WINNER. WINNER HI THAT
IS NINE TWO TWO EVERYONE VOTING
BILLS OUT. THE NEXT ITEM FILE
ITEM EIGHTEEN BY AB FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI
BURGESS. THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN FOR JUST NOT VOTING.
JOHN I'M SORRY PURCHASE OF A
WINNER. WINNER I. THAT'S NINE
TWO ONE EVERYONE HAVING VOTED
THOSE OUT THE NEXT ITEM FILE
ITEM NINETEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN IT'S AB ELEVEN OH ONE THE
CHAIR VOTING HI WINNER. WINNER
HI THAT'S ELEVEN ZERO. ELEVEN
TO ZERO THE BILLS OUT THE NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW A. B. ONE
FOUR SEVEN FIVE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI WINNER. WINNER HI
THAT'S ELEVEN TWO ZERO BILLS
OUT. NEXT ITEM FOR ITEM. TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOSE THREE OF
US BUT THE CHAIR VOTING I'D
BURGESS. THIS IS IT'S OKAY IT'S
FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE AND IT'S
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY FOUR. WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I FILE ITEM.
TWENTY NINE. OKAY SO GORGEOUS
NOT VOTING. STERN STERN I AM
WIENER. WINNER I. THAT'S TEN
ZERO ALL MEMBERS HAVING VOTED
BILLS OUT THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE
ITEM THIRTY TWO AB TWO ONE
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI FORGES.
THE BOARD JUST NOW. STERN STERN
BY WACO SKI Y. CASKEY I WINNER
WINNER ALL RIGHT THAT'S NINE
TWO TO ALL MEMBERS HAVING VOTED
THOSE OUT- THE LAST MEASURE IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AB ONE
FOUR FIVE FIVE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'D- BOARD YES. PORGES
NOT VOTING JONES. THIS ABSENT
OKAY- STERN STERN I WINNER.
WINNER I THAT'S NINE TWO ZERO
ALL MEMBERS HAVING VOTED BILLS
OUT. AND THAT'S EVERYTHING WE
ARE ADJOURNED. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MEMBERS FOR YOUR DILIGENCE
AND DISCIPLINE.